ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
TODAY'S TUESDAY APRIL TWENTIETH
WE DO NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM
QUITE A WAY SHORT OF THAT AT
THIS POINT. BUT WE CAN START AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE WHICH WE WILL DO.
SOME HOUSEKEEPING THINGS.
MISTER SMITH I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME TO OUR COMMITTEE WHO IS
HERE IN PLACE OF MR GALLAGHER
THAT IS THE ONE CHANGE THE- WE
ARE HAVING TODAY. AND SO
PROCEDURALLY THOUGH I WOULD
LIKE TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO
THIS HEARING AND REMIND
EVERYONE THAT AS WE ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC THAT WE
ARE EXHIBITING SOCIAL
DISTANCING. AND EVERYONE MUST
BE WEARING A MASK AND STAY AT
LEAST SIX FEET APART THAT'S
TRUE IN THE HEARING ROOM AS
WELL AS THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN THE ROOM THAT IS
ALLOW BUT WE WERE ONLY ALLOWING
A LIMITED NUMBER OF STAFF WERE
WITNESSES. HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. WE HAVE A REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. THAT ARE
OUTSIDE THE NORTH SIDE OF THE
CAPITAL WHICH IS A POSSIBILITY
FOR BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY
EITHER AS A WITNESS. OR SOMEONE
WHO IS JUST TESTIFYING WERE.
SUPPORTING OR OPPOSING A BILL
SO THAT IS A GOOD PLACE TO BE
ABLE TO GO IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE
TO COME INTO THE HEARING ROOM.
AS WELL AS TELEPHONIC. SUPPORT
SO IN THIS ROOM AGAIN WE ARE.
MAINTAINING DISTANCING WE DO
HAVE A MICROPHONE IF YOU WANT
TO SPEAK ON A BILL MAKE SURE
YOU INDICATE THAT YOU DO AS
THAT TIME COMES UP FOR EITHER
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OR FOR
WITNESSES WE HAVE A MICROPHONE.
TO BE ABLE TO. HERE YOU AND
MAKE SURE THAT YOU DO NOT TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE SO THAT WE CAN
MINIMIZE CONTAMINATION. IF YOU
ARE ON THE TELEPHONE HEAD
WANTING TO CALL IN. THE TOLL
FREE NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AGAIN THAT IS.
877-692-8957 THAT NUMBER SHOULD
BE UP ON YOUR SCREEN IF YOU'RE
WATCHING THIS. ONLINE AND IS
AVAILABLE ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO
AGAIN THAT IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR. TWO OH TWO AND THAT
SHOULD BE ALSO ON THE WEBSITE
AND- ON THE SHOULD BE SHOWING
UP ON YOUR SCREEN IF YOU WANT
TO PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S
HEARING. WE ALSO I WILL NOTE
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
DISRUPTIONS IN SOME OF THE
COMMITTEE HEARINGS. AND I WILL
TELL YOU THAT THAT AS MUCH AS
WE WANT ACTIVE PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT. IN OUR PROCESSES WE
ARE NOT GOING TO STAND FOR
DISRUPTIONS FOR THE SAKE OF
DISRUPTIONS YOU WILL BE WARNED
AND THEN NOT ALLOWED TO FURTHER
PARTICIPATE. IN THE HEARING OR
HERE IN THE HEARING. ROOM OR ON
THE TELEPHONE DEPENDING ON HOW
THE DISRUPTION IS BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE A LOT OF BUSINESS TO GET
THROUGH. AND WE WILL GET
THROUGH THAT TODAY. ALL RIGHT.
SO. STILL NO QUORUM. RIGHT
FIRST UP WE HAVE A READ OF
NUMBER ONE AGAIN WE'LL TAKE HIS
OF COMMITTEE A. B. FOURTEEN
THIRTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA.
WELCOME. THANK YOU MISTER.
BEFORE I START MY PRESENTATION
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS BILL AND I'D
LIKE TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED WITHIN THE COMMITTEE
REPORT THANK YOU. AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY WILL HELP CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER SAFEGUARD OPIOID
MEDICATIONS AND REDUCE THE ACT
OF PILFERING A POWERFUL ON RAMP
TO THE NATION'S CURRENT OPIOID
ADDICTION CRISIS THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE PHARMACISTS TO
PROVIDE SCHEDULED TO END TO END
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS SUCH AS
MORPHINE OXYCODONE AND RITALIN
IN A LOCKABLE CONTAINER.
OFFERING THE ACT OF SNEAKING A
SMALL NUMBER OF PILLS HOPING IT
WILL GO UNDETECTED IS THE
LEADING SOURCE OF YOUTH OPIOID
ABUSE. STUDIES SHOW THAT EACH
YEAR NEARLY SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND CHILDREN FROM ACROSS
THE COUNTRY BETWEEN THE AGES OF
TWELVE AND SEVENTEEN INITIATE
PRESCRIPTION DRUG ABUSE BY
PILFERING MEDICATION FROM AN
ADULT IN THEIR HOME. THE OUT
DATED CHILD RESISTANT
PRESCRIPTION VIALS CURRENTLY IN
USE HAVE NOT BEEN MODIFIED IN
NEARLY FIFTY YEARS. WHEN THE
FEDERAL POISON PREVENTION
PACKAGING ACT WHICH WAS ENACTED
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY THE GOAL
WAS TO PREVENT CHILDREN UNDER
THE AGE OF FIVE FROM GAINING
ACCESS TO ASPEN. TODAY THOSE
SAME CHILD LOCKS ARE USED TO
PROTECT MEDICATIONS RANGING
FROM COUGH MEDICINE TO
PRESCRIPTION PAIN MANAGEMENT
MEDICATIONS THAT ARE EIGHTY
TIMES STRONGER THAN MORPHINE.
WE PUBLIC HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE CALLED FOR IMPROVED
PACKAGING OF OPIOIDS AND OTHER
ADDICTIVE MEDICATIONS FOR
SEVERAL YEARS. REQUIRING
LOCKING PRESCRIPTION VIALS FOR
POWERFUL NARCOTICS IS A LOW
COST WAY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
MODERNIZE THE ANTIQUATED
FEDERAL LAWS THAT ARE PARTIALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR CAUSING THE
NATIONWIDE EPIDEMIC. WITH ME
TODAY ARE MARK BURKE GAS WITH
AND BE ADVOCACY AND SHERRY
DAILY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION
PROGRAMS AND PROFESSIONALS.
THANK YOU SO I DO HAVE TO
SUPPORT WITNESSES BOTH-
INDICATED TO BE ON THE
TELEPHONE SHERRY DAILY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS. AND MARK FORGET
FROM M. B. ADVOCACY. IS DALY OR
MR BIRKHEAD ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
THIS IS MARK GO AHEAD SIR. BUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ACCORDING TO RECENT
STUDIES MOST THE RECENT STUDIES
FROM THE- PEDIATRICS JOURNAL-
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
ADOLESCENTS BEGIN ABUSING.
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATIONS EVERY
YEAR THAT COMES OUT YOU KNOW
WHAT NEW NEW ADOLESCENT EVERY
MINUTE TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY.
EIGHTY FOURTEEN THIRTY CAN
PARTIALLY ELIMINATE- THIS
EXPERIMENTATION BY ELIMINATING
PILFERING WHICH IS AT THE
AUTHOR INDICATED TAKING JUST A
FEW PILLS AT A TIME. THIS BILL
HAS THREE MAIN POINTS NUMBER
ONE IT ALERT THE PATIENT. THAT
THE MEDICATION THEY'RE
RECEIVING IS A SERIOUS
MEDICATION- THAT NEEDS TO BE
TREATED APPROPRIATELY. NUMBER
EXACTLY THE DISINCENTIVES. TO
PILFERED THAT MEDICATION- AND
NUMBER THREE IF QUICKLY ALERTS
WHOEVER IS. HOLDING THE
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATION THAT
THEIR MEDICATIONS HAVE BEEN
TAMPERED WITH AND AS WE KNOW
FROM HISTORY THE EARLIER WE CAN
IDENTIFY THAT SOMEONE IS
BEGINNING TO ABUSE- A
MEDICATION OR DRUGS THE BETTER
THEIR CHANCES OF HAVING A LONG
TERM. POSITIVE OUTCOMES- THESE
NUMBERS ARE ALL PRE PANDEMIC
NUMBERS AND WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
FOR EVERY STUDY THAT'S BEEN OUT
THERE RECENTLY AT THAT THESE.
THE USES AND ABUSES OF THIS
MEDICATION HAS INCREASED
GEOMETRICALLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND KIDS ARE AT HOME
AND LOOKING FOR SOMETHING
ADDITIONAL TO DO. AS THE AUTHOR
INDICATES THE LOCKABLE FILES
HAVE NOT BEEN. UPDATED SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE. AND THIS
IS SIMPLY THE NEXT STEP. IN
INCREASING AT THE PROTECTION OF
THE USE OF THESE MEDICATIONS.
R. COSTA- FACTOR IS VERY SMALL-
WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT A
TYPICAL OPIOID- ONE IN
PARTICULAR CALLED NORCO A ONE
MONTH SUPPLY WILL RUN YOU
ANYWHERE FROM SIX HUNDRED EIGHT
DOLLARS THE SIXTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS THE CURRENT CHILD
RESISTANT CAPS COST ABOUT
TWENTY CENTS A PIECE. WE
ANTICIPATE THAT WITH THE
PASSAGE OF THIS LEGISLATION BE
WALKABLE FILED- COST TO PRODUCE
THEM WILL BE ABOUT THIRTY FIVE.
CENTS A PIECE SO IT'S A VERY
SMALL ADDITION TO THE COST IN
ADDITION AT THE PHARMACIST WILL
BE COMPENSATED FOR THE FULL
COST. OF THE FILE. AS WELL AS
ANY COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
ADDITIONAL TIME. HM
CONSULTATIONS AND DISPENSING
FEE. THIS WILL HAPPEN ON A
MONTHLY BASIS- IN IT WILL. THIS
BILL WILL NOT ONLY SAVE LIVES-
BUT IT WILL FULLY COMPENSATE
THE PHARMACIST AND THE
RETAILERS OR BOTH THE PRODUCT
THAT THEY APPLY AS WELL AS THE
TIME THAT THEY SPEND WE FEEL
THAT WE CAN SAVE MANY LIVES.
EIGHT THE DEATH CAMP COSTS IN
HEALTHCARE ALL WITH THIS VERY
COMMON SENSE APPROACH- AND WE
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE DAILY
ALIVE. YES I AM THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING AUDIBLE CHAIR MEMBERS
JERRY DEALING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS REPRESENTING OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND ADDICTION
COUNSELORS MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED TO THE PROGRAMS THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY RECOVERY
RESIDENCES AND THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE IN RECOVERY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE I'M HERE TODAY TO
VOICE SUPPORT FOR A BI FOURTEEN
THIRTY BOTH THAT EXPERT IN A
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT FIELD AND PERSONALLY
AS A PARENT. FROM A POLITICAL
STANDPOINT BLOCKING PILL WHILE
TURNING EXPENSIVE AND VERY
EFFECTIVE PREVENTION MEASURE
CONCERNING YOUNG ADULTS AND
ADOLESCENTS THIS AGE GROUP IS
MATURE ENOUGH TO CALCULATED
RISK REWARD POSSIBILITIES FOR
THEIR ACTIONS STEALING TWO OR
THREE PILLS FROM A CONTAINER
REPAIR YES TIME IS FAR LESS
LIKELY TO BE DETECTED THAN AN
ENTIRE CONTAINER OF MEDICATION
SUDDENLY GOING MISSING
THEREFORE EXPERIMENTINGWITH
PHARMACEUTICALS FROM HOME
MEDICINE CABINET HAS VERY
LITTLE CONSEQUENCE FROM A
PARENTAL PUNISHMENT
PERSPECTIVE. BUT FROM A LIFE
AND DEATH STANDPOINT
CONSEQUENCES FROM THIS BEHAVIOR
CAN LITERALLY BE DEADLY
INCLUDED IN OUR LETTER OF
SUPPORT WITH A NEWS REPORT
ABOUT A FAMILY IN INDIANA WHO
EXPERIENCED THE TRAGEDY THAT
CAN OCCUR WHEN HE'S POWERFUL
MEDICATIONS ARE SURE CATHOLIC
PARTY AND MIXED WITH ALCOHOL
BECKY SAVAGE HAD TWO AMAZING
SONS NICK AND JACK WHO LEFT
TALKY TALK ABOUT WHEN LATE NOW
NIGHT HANG OUT WHEN I CAME HOME
FROM COLLEGE TO CELEBRATE
YOUNGER BROTHER JACK HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION. THE TO
ATTEND A SMALL PARTY WITH
FRIENDS WERE OPIOID AND ALCOHOL
WERE SHARED IN THE MORNING WHEN
BECKY WENT TO PICK UP LAUNDRY
IN JACK'S ROOM SHE FOUND HIM
UNRESPONSIVE UNBELIEVABLY WELL
SHE WAS ADMINISTERING CPR
PARAMEDICS ARRIVED BUT WENT
TOWARD THE BASEMENT OR ANOTHER
CALL FOR ASSISTANCE HAVE BEEN
RECEIVED THAT NIGHT BECKY LOST
TWO OF HER FOUR SONS TO OPIOID
EPIDEMIC. FROM A PERSONAL
PERSPECTIVE I HAVE EXPERIENCE
COVERING IN MY OWN HOME
ALTHOUGH I WAS SPARED THE
HORRIFIC TRAGEDY BABBAGE THE
LOOKS WITH TODAY AS AN ADVOCATE
IN THE GO TO THE KITCHEN
TREATMENT COURT OVER THREE
DECADES I BELIEVE MY CHILDREN
HAD SOMEHOW BECOME IMMUNE TO
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER AFTER
ALL I DID ALL THE RIGHT THINGS.
I HAD THE TALK I GAVE ALL THE
COMMISSION. AN EXTRA THEM FROM.
WHERE I CAN. DRUG AND ALCOHOL
MAY BE AVAIL. THEIR STATUS.
BEAUTICIAN ANSWERED. NONE OF MY-
LOOK WOULD BE A- BY DISEASE I
THANK. ONE MY YOUNGEST CHILD
WHICH FROM YOUR IN EUROPE WITH
THE TECHNICAL CUTS IN HOUSTON
THANK YOU WITH. I WAS AND
CONFUSED HOW DISCARDED TO
INCLUDE WHY WHICHEVER USING I.
IT WAS NOT UNTIL IT MONTHS
INTEREST THAT I. OF QUESTIONS
WHICH TOLD ME SHE BEGAN AND
MARK THE ELECTED NORCO FROM
SURGERY I HAD I'M SHOCKED AND
IN DISBELIEF. MY HEART SANK I
THOUGHT IF I ONLY KNEW HOW MUCH
PAIN AND SUFFERING BECAUSE I
STATE IN HER LIFE AND MY OWN
FAMILY. HOW MUCH TIME DID WE
LOSE HOW MUCH MONEY WAS LOST
THANK FOR MONTHS OF RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT ALL BECAUSE HE COULD
NOT HAVE AN EARLY WARNING
SYSTEM IN OUR HOME. IT IS TOO
LATE FOR BECKY ABOUT PARENTS
WHO JUST DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THEY
COULD BE NOW WE CAN CHANGE THAT
WITH AB FOURTEEN THIRTY I
RESPECTFULLY RESPECTFULLY. URGE
YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU. I
BEFORE WE- OUR AS LIKE TO. A
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE
HERE. CHAU CHIU DAVIES.
GONZALEZ. HOLDEN KALRA KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN REYES. SMITH THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A QUORUM RIGHT.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
IS THERE SECONDS. I WILL SECOND
THAT. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
PHONES- OR IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE REMOTE.
TESTIMONY. VISIBILITY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO. SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOURTEEN THIRTY. SEEING
NONE THERE OPERATOR COULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR A BI
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOR THOSE WHO'D
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT WE'RE
GOING TO BE ASKING THAT PEOPLE
JUST GIVE THEIR NAME THEIR
AFFILIATION AND THAT THEY
SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN THIRTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
MOMENT FOR HER FIRST LINE
NUMBER. IT WOULD BE JUST A
MOMENT LONGER ONE MOMENT.
YOUR
MIND IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI YES I HAVE A WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE ONE
OPPOSITION WITNESS LISTED.
INSEEGO HORN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION AND NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF CHAIN DRUG
STORES WHO IS WITH US ON THE
TELEPHONE. ARE YOU WITH US THE
COMING YEAR I AND I AM GOOD YES
I'M HERE NEAR ME YES OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS ONE
OF THE CALIFORNIA REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION. AND THE NATIONAL
COULD BE SNACKING DIRECTORIES
AND WE ARE OPPOSED EIGHTY
FOURTEEN THIRTY WE APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLY MAN ARAMBULA GOAL TO
MITIGATE FAST AND IF YOU THINK
OPIOID AND OTHER PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS AND WE SHARE A COMMITMENT
TO THAT EFFORT. UNFORTUNATELY
WE DON'T THINK EIGHTY FOURTEEN
THIRTY WILL ACHIEVE THAT GOAL
FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS MOST
NOTABLY AT FOURTEEN THIRTY OR
EVEN. PATIENT SAFETY
GRANDPARENT SOME PATIENTS MIGHT
HAVE A HEALTH CONDITION AND
THEN TO THE PHARMACIST THAT
MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
OPEN ALL APPLE PIE OUT. OR AT
LEAST IN MY FORGET THEIR
PASSCODE IN MIGHT NOT BE ABLE
TO REACH THEIR PHARMACY AFTER
HOURS TO RETRIEVE IT WE CAN
UNABLE TO ACCESS THEIR
MEDICATION WHEN THEY NEED IT.
BY REQUIRING PHARMACIES IN
MAINTAIN PATIENT PASSCODE FOR
THE LOCKABLE VIALS EIGHTY
FOURTEEN THIRTY LAW TO CREATE A
NETWORK ISSUE. ADDING THE
CAPABILITY WOULD BE PROBLEMATIC
TO IMPLEMENT MAINTAIN BECAUSE
WE DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE A
DIFFERENT REPLACE THE TRACK OF
THE FACT THAT. ORDER FARMING
PEOPLE HAVE TO DEVELOP A NEW
ACCOUNTING PROCESS TO SEEK
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE LOCKABLE
VIALS MANUFACTURED AND HAVE TO
FIGHT WITH THE COP AWAITING TO
BE REIMBURSED. IMPLEMENTING
THAT THEY'VE BEEN CONSTANTLY
FOLLOWING UP WITH MANUFACTURE
COMPLETE THE NEW FINANCIAL
BURDEN ON PHARMACIES AND
DISTRACT THEM PATIENT CARE.
BEYOND ITS PATIENT SAFETY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE ISSUES THE
PARKING THIRTY IS UNNECESSARY
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN A
LEGISLATURE ENACTED EIGHTY
TWENTY FIFTY NINE WHICH
REQUIRED PAYING PHARMACIES
POPPER LOCKABLE STORAGE
PRODUCTS FOR CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES. INCLUDING WALKABLE
PRESCRIPTION VIAL. AGUIAR-CURRY
THE PROM DISPLAY IN OUR FOR. SO
THEY ARE EASY ACCEPT TO
PATIENTS WHO TO USE THEM.
FINALLY AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
PROVIDE CENTER. FOR AGAINST BY.
ONE FUSION UNABLE TO. THEIR A
LOCKABLE FILE FORMAT THAT
THEY'RE NOT A FOR THE SAME. AS
THE BILL. I LIVE LIKE TO KNOW
THAT THE CAL. FOR EQUIPMENT THE-
WHO IS ANY TO BE TODAY IF ALSO
A OF THE FOURTEENTH. HOWEVER WE
ARE HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN- HER
ACT. TO THE BILL AND WALKABLE
BY THEY MADE AND BRING THEM IN
MINISTRY TO. ARGUMENT AND WE
ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
OSCAR IN FONG BUT TODAY WE AND-
ARE OPPOSED AB FOUR. THIRTY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. SO SEE NO. WITH THIS IN
THE HEARING ROOM ARE THERE ANY.
THIRTY ONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY IN THE WITNESS
VIDEO ROOM THE REMOTE SITE.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION TO A. B. FOURTEEN
THIRTY. GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION AND THAT YOU'RE
OPPOSED AB FOURTEEN THIRTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NINE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING PROTEON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
BUT REMAIN AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE
OPPOSITION Q. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SEND QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. RIGHT SIGNAL. UP
DRESS. I DO WANNA THANK YOU
DOCTOR IT ON THE LOT FOR
PRESENTING THIS I THINK- THE
OPIOID. YOUR SHOES SO HUGE AND
FINDING WAYS TO PROTECT OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE- IS REALLY
IMPORTANT RIGHT I HEAR THE
OPPOSITION AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE WORKING. WITH THEM TO
TRY TO FIND THE BEST WAY TO
MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD SO I'M
VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE. ALL
RIGHT SIGNAL DR EMILY YOU MAY
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE
A MOTION TO SECOND THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA PLEASE
STONE AYE STONE AYE CHAU. CHIU
DAVIES NOW DAVIS NOAH GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES
FIVE REYES R. SMITH SMITH NOW.
THE BILL NEEDS TO MORE SO WE'LL
PUT IT ON CALL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND WE WILL MOVE TO OUR
ITEM- WELL HERE BEFORE. THIS
RACE. BEFORE YOU LEAVE CAN WE
TAKE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SINCE WE HAVE A FORM
HERE. OKAY SO WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CHOLERA
PLEASE STONE HI STONE I CHAU
CHIU DAVIES DAVEY SECOND SALAS
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES REYES
AYE SMITH SMITH OKAY. SO THOSE
ARE ALL OUT. OKAY AND THAT IS
A. B. THREE ONE FIVE STONE AB
THREE FORTY THREE FONG AB FOUR
THIRTY GRAYSON AB SIX SEVENTY
CALDERON. A. B. NINE FORTY FIVE
ROMMEL'S ED AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR FROM THE JOBS COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU ALL THERE WE NOW MOVE
TO OUR ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH IS
AB TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN AS FAR
CARE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS FIRST I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR AND THE STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK ON THE BILL AND
I WANT TO ACCEPT THE PROPOSED
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL THANK YOU TODAY I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB TWELVE EIGHTY
SEVEN WHICH PROHIBITS
DIFFERENTIAL PRICING ON THE
BASIS OF GENDER OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS THE PINK TAX. WOMEN PAY MORE
ON AVERAGE FOR IDENTICAL
PRODUCTS THAT ARE SIMPLY A
DIFFERENT COLOR A PHENOMENA
KNOWN AS THE PINK TAX THIS
MEANS THE PRICE FOR BEING A
WOMAN. MULTIPLE STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT WOMEN ON AVERAGE
PAY. 7% MORE FOR GENDERED ITEMS
LIKE TOILETRIES AND CLOTHING.
THEY ALSO FACE HIGHER PRICES
FOR SEEMINGLY NEUTRAL PRODUCTS
LIKE MORTGAGE RATES. THESE
PRICE DIFFERENCES ATA THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE STUDY
ESTIMATED THE YEAR AFTER YEAR.
A TYPICAL CALIFORNIA WOMAN PAYS
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE DOLLARS
MORE. FOR THE SAME GOODS AND
SERVICES THAN HER MALE
COUNTERPART. THIS ARBITRARILY
PENALIZES WOMEN AFTER FORTY
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
WOMEN HAVE BEEN HIT HARD IN
THIS PANDEMIC. ECONOMIC
INEQUITIES BETWEEN WOMEN AND
MEN HAVE INCREASED. ON THAT JOB
LOSSES HAVE BEEN FROM WOMEN AND
SPECIFICALLY WOMEN OF COLOR.
THESE IMPACTS THREATEN THE WELL
BEING OF FAMILIES IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. 41% OF MOTHERS WERE
THE PRIMARY BREADWINNERS FOR
THEIR FAMILIES. PRIMARY
BREADWINNERS WHO STILL MAKE 70%
OR LESS THAN THEIR MALE
COLLEAGUES. THE PINK TAX
AUGMENTS AND REINFORCES THESE
INEQUITIES WOMEN ALREADY
UNDERPAID- EXPECTED TO MAKE PAY
MORE FOR BASIC NECESSITIES.
THIS BILL STRIKES THE BALANCE
WE WORKED HARD TO CRAFT THE
BILL WITH PROPONENTS AND
OPPONENTS OF PREVIOUS
ITERATIONS OF THIS LEGISLATION.
AND I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT THE
CHAMBERS NEUTRAL ON THE BILL.
AND WE PROTECTED SMALL
BUSINESSES. FROM BURDENSOME
LITIGATION WHILE ALSO HOLDING
RETAILERS ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
SYSTEMIC GENDER IMBALANCE IN
PRICING. PAYING HIGHER PRICES
BECAUSE OF YOUR GENDER IS
SIMPLY UNJUST. IT HURTS WOMEN
IN A MARKET AT A TIME WHEN THEY
ARE DEEPLY VULNERABLE. WITH ME
TODAY IN SUPPORT IS TIFFANY
BOYD LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS. AND JESSICA
STENDER SENIOR COUNSEL AT EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES. THANK YOU I
DO HAVE THOSE TWO LISTED AS
BEING WITH US ON THE TELEPHONE.
HIS BLADE AND MS STENDER ARE
YOU WITH US. YES I'M HERE.
OKAY- WILL TAKE EITHER ONE. BOB
GOOD MORNING CHAIRED THE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS FIFTY FOUR
EIGHT AND AGAIN I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS THE COMMISSION
SERVED AS AN INDEPENDENT
ADVISORY AND NEED TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR OUT
POLICY THAN OTHER ISSUES.
PERTAINING TO SYSTEMIC ISSUES
AND CONDITIONS AFFECTING EQUITY
FOR THE NINETEEN POINT NINE
MILLION WOMEN AND GIRLS THAT
CALL CALIFORNIA HOME INTERFACE
PRICING ALSO KNOWN AS TAX IS AN
ATTRACTIVE PRODUCT HE DISNEY
INTERNET FOR WEDDING WHICH I'VE
ONLY COSMETIC DIFFERENCES FROM
INTENDED FOR MEN IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE PACKAGE UNDER TAX
REPEAL ACT. THAT ENSURE GENDER
BASED DISCRIMINATION AND
ASTELLAS EVERYTHING EFFECTIVE
CARE QUITE DRY CLEANING AND
ALTERATIONS WHAT EFFECT THE
OUTLAW YES GOOD FOR PRODUCTS
SUCH AS CLOTHING TOYS SPORTS
EQUIPMENT AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS WERE LEFT OUT AND THE
DESPERATE FINANCIAL IMPACT OVER
THE COURSE OF A WOMAN'S LIFE
HAVE BEEN SUBSTANTIAL ONGOING
GAP IN PRICES FOR SIMILAR DATES
HAVE COST THE- AVERAGE
CALIFORNIA WOMAN OF PAYING TAX
OF APPROXIMATELY. A HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND OVER THE
COURSE OF HER LIFE IN AN
AGGREGATE PENALIZES WOMEN
ACROSS CALIFORNIA TO THE TUNE
OF FORTY SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
EACH YEAR WE KNOW THAT WOMEN
AND GIRLS IN HERE FACE. ANY
QUALITY IN MANY ASPECTS OF
THEIR DAILY LIFE NUMBER WOULD
HAVE BEEN WORKING BY THE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WOMEN ARE
ALREADY PAID LESS THAN MEN AND
WITH THE PINK TAX THEY'RE
CHARGED MORE ON TOP OF THAT OUR
GREAT EIGHTY EIGHT THAT. FOR
EVERY DOLLAR A MAN EARNS THAT
AND- THOSE EARNING FALL TO
FORTY PORTIONS WERE BROKEN DOWN
BY RACE WOMEN ESPECIALLY WOMEN
OF COLOR ARE SUFFERING DURING A
PANDEMIC I CANNOT AFFORD AGREE
HERE ARBITRARY AND REPRESSIVE A
TARGET AND THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE
YOU ANY THE PINK TAX AND
DISCRIMINATORY PRICE SETTING%
SUCH AS- AB TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN
FIFTY DO IT IS A NECESSARY STEP
TOWARD TAKE GARDEN EQUAL.
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY FOR WOMEN.
AND OUR COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. JESSICA STENDER.
GOOD MORNING CHANNEL I'M HERE
TO AND SAW SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTY
I NEED TO TALK STAND AND ACT
ACCOUNT FOR PLEASE JUST AND
PUBLIC POLICY EQUALLY ADVOCATES
WORKABLE RIGHT ARE GONNA BE
DATA TO PUT AND ECONOMIC AND
EDUCATIONAL ACCESS FOR ONE GIRL.
HAVE A LONG S. FAMILIES HAVE A
GREAT WONDER BREADWINNER MOTHER
YET WOMEN CONTINUE TO FACE
OBSTACLE TO A QUALITY IN THE
WORKPLACE AND THE BROADER
COMMUNITY AS YOU HEARD CENTERS
BUREAU DATA SHOWS THAT WOMEN ON
AVERAGE EARN EIGHTY TWO CENTS
TO EVERY DOLLAR PAID BY MEN OF
THE TWO MEN FOR WOMEN OF COLOR
THAT WE GET AS MUCH WORSE IN
BANKRUPTCY NOTHING CALIFORNIA
FACE ONE OF THE WORST FEET
WE'VE GOT TO THE COUNTRY WOMEN
ALSO EXPERIENCE FAR HIGHER
RATES OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT WORK
WHICH CREATE FURTHER BARRIERS
CREATE CAREER ADVANCEMENT
FURTHER HINDERING ECONOMIC
SECURITY. DISCRIMINATORY
PRICING AND CONSUMER PRODUCTS
THEREFORE ADDS TO EXISTING
STRUCTURAL DISCRIMINATION AND
ECONOMIC INEQUALITY THAT WOMEN
FACE FURTHER HARMING OUR
ECONOMIC STABILITY AB TWENTY
SEVEN AS LONG OVERDUE
COMMONSENSE LEGISLATION THAT
ADDRESSES THE REALITY THAT COST
MORE FOR WOMEN TO EXIT SECTORS
MARKETING GENDERED STEREOTYPES
I'M SUCH AS EXPECTATIONS RESULT
IN AN OVERALL TREND WHY WOMEN
PAY MORE FOR PRODUCTS BASED
SOLELY ON THEIR GENDER THIS
INJUSTICE IS NOT LIMITED BY THE
MARKET AND IT REINFORCES
WOMEN'S ECONOMIC INEQUALITY
THIS BILL ENSURES GENDER
EQUALITY FOR COMMERCIAL GOODS
AND HELPS REMOVE INCENTIVES FOR
HUMBLE MARKETING AND SECURES
YOUR PRICING IN CALIFORNIA. FOR
THESE REASONS I URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE AB TWENTY
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WILL NOW MOVE
TO THOSE WHO WOULD JUST LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB. TWELVE
EIGHTY SEVEN ANYONE IN THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. I
DON'T SEE ANYONE OR THE WITH
VIDEO. I DON'T SEE ANYONE THERE
NO ONE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM A
PRETTY WHICH OPEN THE FOR THE
WHO WOULD TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR A. TO EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WIH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE EIGHTY
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. LINE
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS BECCA
KRAMMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION AND
SUPPORT. NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT ON THE
SUPPORT QUEUE FOR TWELVE EIGHTY
SEVEN ALL RIGHT THANK YOU I DO
NOT HAVE ANY OPPOSITION LISTED.
IS THERE ANYONE IN. SEEING
NONE. NO ONE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM OPERATOR OPEN THE LINES
FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION. FOR AB.
TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISHTO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU OPERATOR I'M
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. THIS CONSULT WITH SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
I SIGNED ON AS A JOINT AUTHORS
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN JOINT AUTHORS
OF PAST ITERATIONS OF THIS I'M
A LITTLE CONCERNED I HAVE TO BE
HONEST ABOUT WHERE THIS BILL
LANDED- I JUST DON'T SEE A
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM THAT'S
GOING TO HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL
FACT. OUTSIDE OF THE IDENTICAL
PEAK IN BLUE RAZOR- KIND OF
SITUATION WHERE WHERE DO YOU
SEE HOW DO YOU SEE THIS WOULD.
HAPPENED BE ENFORCED I'M JUST
NOT REALLY BIG INTO SAYING WE
PASSED LAWS THAT DON'T REALLY
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM. I FEEL
GIVEN THE KIND OF STRICTNESS OF
HOW THIS IS CONSTRUED ALONG
WITH THE LACK OF ENFORCEMENT
CAPABILITY WERE KIND OF SAYING
SOMETHING BUT WE'RE NOT REALLY
CAN CAN LIVE. RAZOR M. EXAMPLE
THAT USED TO BE YEARS AND
HONESTLY I WENT CHECKED ISN'T
ISN'T A PROBLEM ANYMORE THEY'VE
SOLVED THE PINK AND BLUE REYES
ARE PROBLEMS AT LEAST IN MY ARE.
SO DID YOU TOUCH ON THINGS THEM
UNDERSTOOD THE QUESTION CRACK
ONE IS IMPORTANT. ONE IS THE
QUESTION OF. HOW WORKING. AND
GENERATE. I THINK. SO THE
ENFORCEMENT PERSONALLY YES- SO
I MEAN REQUIRE. YOU KNOW IT'S
THE IS CURRENTLY CRAFTED HAVE
THE ATTORNEY JOHN AS THE
ENFORCER OF. AND THE I BELIEVE
THE MOST IN. MECHANISM THERE IS
AN ENGINE I THINK WE ALL. TO
THIS TO BE CORRECTED RIGHT NEAR
DRUGS OR IT COULD CRACK THAT'S
THE GOAL. AND SO WHAT HAS BEEN
A PROBLEM IN THE PAST IS THIS
QUESTION OF WILL THERE BE GIVEN
HOW COMPLICATED THIS IS BECAUSE
I THINK HOPE HI I PERSONALLY
BELIEVE THAT IF SOMETHING IS.
MORE EXPENSIVE TO MANUFACTURE
WHICH IN SOME CASES WOMEN'S
GARMENTS FOR EXAMPLE MIGHT BE
MORE EXPENSIVE TO TAYLOR THEN
EMAIL GARMENT THAT YOU CAN
CHARGE FOR THAT RIGHT FOR THE
COST OF THE DIFFERENTIAL IN
PRODUCTION OF GOODS. AND SO
THIS IS A COMPLICATED QUESTION
OF WHERE IS THAT DIFFERENT FROM
PRICE APPROPRIATE BECAUSE IT
COSTS MORE TO MANUFACTURE THE
GOOD AND WHERE IS IT JUST. A
GENDER TAX RATE. AND SO THAT.
GIVE THE COMPLICATED NATURE OF
THAT. YOU KNOW THIS ITERATION
OF THE BILL SAYS THAT WE
BELIEVE THAT THE ENFORCEMENT IS
APPROPRIATELY PLACED IN THE
HANDS OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL-
IT IS WHAT ARE THE THINGS THAT
WE ARE THINKING ABOUT IS DO WE
WANT IT. GIVEN HOW MUCH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS TO DO. WE
WANT TO EXPAND THAT OUT TO
LOCAL CITY ATTORNEYS TO GIVE
LOCAL AUTHORITIES THE RIGHT TO
DO THIS YOU MIGHT HAVE MORE
BAND WITH TO DO THAT SO THAT IS
ON THE TABLE AND IF THAT'S
SOMETHING. THAT I WOULD SUGGEST
ADDING THAT BEFORE IT GETS TO
APPROACH IT'S FEELING A LITTLE
BIT LIGHT- STATEMENT BILL WHICH
I'M COOL WITH BUT IT'S NOT
REALLY SOMETHING THAT- PROVIDES
PEOPLE WITH THE KIND OF RELIEF.
THAT WOULD BE NECESSARY I DON'T
SEE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
SPENDING A LOT OF TIME DOING IN
JUNCTION FOR TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
TWO. DOLLARS I MEAN. YOU KNOW
FOR THAT BEING THE FIND AYE AYE
IT JUST. IT'S NICE BUT LIKE IF
WE'RE GOING TO PASS A LOT AND
SAY WE'RE DOING SOMETHING ABOUT
THAT AND LET'S PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING SO I WOULD SUGGEST
ADDING SOMEONE FOR SPENT THERE.
EVEN IF IT DOES GIVE YOU
OPPOSITION. THAT'S FAIR AND YOU
WANT ME TO ADDRESS THE OTHER
QUESTION. ABOUT THE NARROW
NATURE OF THE- I. THINK RIGHT
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. CORRECT SEEING RK YOU
MAY CALL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
THANK YOU I LOOKING FOR A
MOTION. ALL RIGHT WE DO HAVE A
MOTION TO A SECOND STAVING.
THANK YOU AND THAT MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AMENDED TO A- KALRA
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE CHAU.
CHIU CHOI AYE DAVIES. DAVE AYE
CONSULT. CONSOLES I HOLDEN.
KALRA CORRECT MANGE. REYES
SMITH. THAT BILL NEEDS ONE VOTE
I WILL PUT IT ON CALL THANK YOU
MISTER. ALL MISS FRIEDMAN WE
WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE. HI OF
THE LORD HELLO MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I WOULD I THINK TELL YOU IN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORK ON THIS BILL I AM
ACCEPTING THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS ON PAGES TWELVE
THIRTEEN AND FOURTEEN IN THE
ANALYSIS THANK YOU GLOBALLY THE
ECOMMERCE INDUSTRY USED TO BE
REALLY TWO POINT ONE BILLION
THAT'S BILLION WITH A B. POUNDS
OF PLASTIC PACKAGING IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. AND OF THAT
E. COMMERCE BUSINESSES IN THE
U. S. GENERATED SIX HUNDRED
FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE
MILLION POUNDS OF PLASTIC
PACKAGING WASTE. LAST YEAR
CONSUMERS SPENT EIGHT HUNDRED
AND SIXTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS
ONLINE WITH U. S. MERCHANTS UP
44% OVER TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
WITHALMOST A THIRD OF THE
WORLD'S POPULATION NOW BUYING
ONLINE THE AMOUNT OF PLASTIC
PACKAGING GENERATED IS
ESTIMATED TO DOUBLE BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. THE STAGGERING
GROWTH IS EXPECTED TO OUTLIVE
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND
IT'S CREATING A WAVE OF PLASTIC
PACKAGING WASTE WHICH IS ALSO
EAGLE USE AND VERY LITTLE OF
WHICH IS RECYCLABLE IT IS
ALMOST ALL HEADED TO LANDFILLS
INCINERATION OR INTO THE
ENVIRONMENT WHERE IT POLLUTES
WATERWAYS. AND OCEANS. I BUY
THINGS ONLINE PROBABLY YOU ALL
BUY THINGS ONLINE I'M
CONSTANTLY SHOCKED AT HOW MUCH
PLASTIC PACKAGING COMES WITH
ITEMS THAT ARE NOT EVEN FRAGILE
OR EASY TO DAMAGE. PLASTIC THAT
WE HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO THROW
INTO OUR- TRASH BIN I TO GO TO
OUR LANDFILLS AND- MEMBERS.
IT'S VERY EASY AND CONVENIENT
AND CHEAP TO BUY THINGS ONLINE
BUT WE DON'T THINK ABOUT THE
BACK AND COST THAT WE PAY AS
REPAIRS. ALL OF US WHO LIVE IN
CITIES WITH YOUR TENANT OR YOUR
AN OWNER OF A HOUSE YOU'RE
PAYING A TRASH FREE THAT IS
INCREASINGLY GOING UP. TO
REFLECT THE COST THAT YOUR CITY
YOUR MISTER POLITY HAS TO BEAR
TO DEAL WITH PLASTIC WASTE. NOW
THERE'S A LOT OF CONFUSION FROM
PEOPLE ABOUT WHAT IS AND WHAT
IS NOT RECYCLABLE WHEN IT COMES
IN THOSE BOXES IN FACT I'M
STILL HAVING AN ARGUMENT WITH
MY ROOMMATES HERE IN SACRAMENTO
TO KEEP THROWING PLASTIC FILM
IN THE RECYCLE BIN BECAUSE A
LOT OF TIMES WERE TOLD FROM THE
INDUSTRY THAT ALL YOU HAVE TO
DO IS RECYCLE PLASTIC AND IT
GETS RECYCLED BUT THAT PLASTIC
RIGHT NOW MAYBE RECYCLABLE IN A
LAB SOMEWHERE BUT THERE IS NO
AGENCY IN ON CALIFORNIA THAT I
HAVE FOUND THAT IS CURRENTLY
RECYCLING PLASTIC FILM OF ANY
KIND SO LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT THIS IS. RIGHT STAFFER HAS
DONE IS VERY HANDY CRIB SHEETS.
SO IS BAD NOT RECYCLABLE
PROBABLY YOU'VE GOTTEN SOME OF
THIS I GET TONS OF THIS TONS OF
BACK I GOT A PLOT A SKI MASK IN
THE MAIL FOR MY DAUGHTER FROM
FROM ONE OF THE ONLINE SHOPPERS
THE OTHER DAY THAT WAS WRAPPED
IN GOBS OF THIS EVEN THOUGH IT
WAS IN A BOX PRACTICALLY
UNTOUCHABLE NOT RECYCLABLE.
SEEING ALL OF THESE PLASTIC
BAGS NOT RECYCLABLE. WHAT IS
RECYCLABLE. THIS IS RECYCLABLE
INCLUDING THE TAPE ON THE
INSIDE WHICH IS MADE OUT OF
PAPER. WHICH IS NOT PLASTIC SO
EVEN IF IT'S NOT RECYCLED IT
DOES NOT HARM THE ENVIRONMENT
IS A GOES INTO THE ENVIRONMENT
HERE'S A BOX MADE WITH
COMPLETELY RECYCLED AND
RECYCLABLE PAPER. PATTERNS FOR
MORE MORE OF OUR ONLINE
RETAILERS ARE SWITCHING TO THIS
TYPE OF PACKAGING AND INVESTING
IN IT WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
THAT BY A DATE CERTAIN IT SAYS
YOU CAN NO LONGER USE THE BAD
NON RECYCLABLE PLASTIC
PACKAGING AND INSTEAD YOU HAVE
TO SWITCH TO ONE OF THE MANY
DIFFERENT PRODUCTS AS A SHIPPER
AT LARGE ONLINE CHIPPER. OF
RECYCLABLE NON PLASTIC
PACKAGING MEMBERS THIS IS LOW
HANGING FRUIT THIS IS A MOVE
IT'S ALREADY BEING EMBRACED BY
LARGE PORTIONS OF THE INDUSTRY
THIS WILL MOVE THEM MAKE THEM
MOVE QUICKER IT WILL SEND
SIGNALS TO THE MANY CALIFORNIA
COMPANIES THAT ARE DEVELOPING
EXACTLY THIS KIND OF VERY GOOD
ALTERNATIVE PACKAGING. AND IT'S
OF IT'S A IT'S AGAIN THIS IS A
HUGE AMOUNT OF WASTE TO THAT'S
UNNECESSARY COMPLETELY
UNNECESSARY IN TODAY'S WORLD
THIS IS NOT ADVANCE TECHNOLOGY
THAT WE HAVE TO DEVELOP AT NASA
THIS IS ALREADY HERE IN THE
MARKET PLACE AND THERE'S NO
EXCUSE TO NOT REQUIRE WITHIN A
COUPLE OF YEARS ALL SHIPPERS TO
USE THIS. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU I DO HAVE. TO
SUPPORT WITNESSES LISTED BOTH
ON THE TELEPHONE TERROR BROUGHT.
AND LAUREN COLUMN FROM SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA TERROR BRACHER
LAUREN CULLIMORE YOU ON THE
LINE. YES THANK YOU MISTER GET
HAIR- THIS IS TERRIBLE WITH
OCEANIA A WE ARE VERY PLEASED
TO SPONSOR AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
ONE TO REDUCE THE HARMFUL
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC IMPACT OF UNNECESSARY
SINGLE USE PLASTIC PACKAGING.
YOUR FIRST SHIPMENT THANKS FOR
CALIFORNIANS FROM ONLINE RETAIL
PARKING SAID. A SURVEY
CONDUCTED LAST SUMMER REVEALED
THAT 85% OF AMAZON CUSTOMERS IN
THE US ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
PLASTIC POLLUTION. AND OVER 70%
WOULD USE PLASTIC FREE
ALTERNATE PACKAGING IF OFFERED.
SIMPLY PUT THE PUBLIC SUPPORT
POLICIES LIKE AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE AND AS YOU JUST
HEARD FROM THE FAMILY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
PRACTICAL ALTERNATIVES TO
SINGLE USE PLASTIC FILM AND
FIRE FROM PACKAGING ARE ARE
AVAILABLE ALREADY BEING USED IN
THE MARKET. LAST YEAR AMAZON
INDIA AND NOW BUT COMPLETELY
AWAY FROM SINGLE USE PLASTIC
PACKAGING LESS THAN A YEAR
AFTER THEIR COMMITMENT AND USE
THAT. AMAZON HAS THE TO THE
KERR RECYCLABLE PADDED PAPER
MAILER BEING USED HERE IN THE
S. THE FELT OR- THE GLOBE ECON
LEADER ACTION ADDRESS A SINGLE
USE PLASTIC PROBLEM.
DEMONSTRATE WHAT A POP WHEN
CLASSIC REDUCTION IS A-
CALIFORNIA MONTHLY AS WORLDWIDE.
CONTINUE THANK AND BY IT IS A
SENSE THAT WE HAVE REQUIRE
TWENTY OUR- ARE AT THE END OF
LEE AND REFINE OF POP. I YOU
HEARD WITHOUT A CHANGES WAY WE
CLASSIC THE COURT AMOUNT
PLASTIC WASTE CHEN. IS EXPECT
TO DOUBLE IN THE FIVE YEAR. AND
BY FIFTH AND PROTECT IT SAID
THAT GREENHOUSE GAS AND FROM
FULL CYCLE CLASSIC. WOULD BE
EQUIVALENT TO HUNDRED AND- CALL
BY POWER PLANTS ACCOUNTING
TWENTY PER. OF GLOBAL CAN. WE
APPRECIATE THAT COMMITTEE FOR
THANK. IN STRONG THE BAY. AND
WE THANK OUR FAMILY MY FREE FOR
LEADERS. AND THANK YOU CHAIRMAN.
ASSEMBLY GET BY AND MEMBER
KALRA BURKE OCCURING AB
THIRTEEN ONE WE ARE CAN I.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
HELLO MORNING MISTER NUMBER
MARIN COLUMN BEHALF OF HERE CAL
REPRESENTING HAPPEN MEMBERS IN
SUPPORT ACROSS THE STATE AB
THIRTEEN SOME ONE WILL ADDRESS
THE GLOBAL PLASTIC CRISIS BY
PHASING OUT BEYOND. AND ON A
NOT OF SINGLE USE. USED TO SHIP
ALL MY PURCHASES IN INTO
POWERFUL. HUMAN HEALTH AND OUR
QUALITY OF LIFE OF CALIFORNIANS
SIGNIFICANTLY CONTRIBUTE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE THROUGHOUT THEIR
LIFE CYCLE AND COST CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES OF FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS EACH
YEAR THE CLEAN UP AND PREVENT
THEM ENTERING OUR OCEANS AND
WATERWAYS. POPPET MAILING
ENVELOPE. HELLO THE BUBBLE WRAP
AND EXPANDED POLYSTYRENE
INCLUDING BRUXELLES COMMONLY
REFERRED TO AS PACKAGES DO NOT
MOLDED FROM. OUT OF THE ONLINE
PURCHASES DURING SHIPMENT OUR
FINANCIAL CONTRIBUTOR TO THE
CARPET. OTHER PARTS OF PACKAGE
USED EAT MARKETPLACE NEED
SOMEONE THAT YOU'RE NOT TO LAST
FOR GENERATIONS ALMOST ALL THE
PACKAGING DISCARDED IMMEDIATELY
AFTER PACKAGE OPENS EITHER
REUSED OR RECYCLED. PLASTIC
INSTEAD BECOMES LANDFILLS
BURNED OR ENTERS OUR
ENVIRONMENT WORKING COOKING
HOLDEN FOR GENERATION. AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE EGGMAN
PORTENT ENCOURAGING BILL AIMED
AT ADDRESSING THE PROBLEMATIC
WASTE STREAMS WE THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN FOR HER
LEADERSHIP. AND URGE YOUR ITEM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. RIGHT SO
WILL MOVE MOVE TO OTHERS WHO
WANT INDICATE SUPPORT I SEE NO
ONE HERE IN OUR HEARING ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE AT THE- WITNESS
VIDEO ROOM. I SEE NINE WHAT
ABOUT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NINE SEVENTY ONE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND MOVING ON. TO NINE NINETY
NINE NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'M. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE FIND FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS CYNICAL
OPPOSITE CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE IN STRONG SUPPORT. BY
NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN THIS IS JENNIFER
FAN TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE ON BEHALF
OF THE CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY
THANK YOU. MY NINETY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE MORNING CARE MEMBERS ARE
SELECTED US ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL AND NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP ACTION COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE NINETY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
DANIELLE HORA CALLING ON BEHALF
OF CALPERS AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT. NINE NINETY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING KAREN MEMBERS-
THIS IS GENEVIEVE AVEDON ON
BEHALF OF THE ELEVEN CLEAN SEAS
LOBBYING COALITION MEMBER
ORGANIZATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE
THANK YOU. NINE ONE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JEN WHEN
BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU OPERATOR WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO OPPOSITION I HAVE TO
OPPOSITION WITNESSES NOTED ADAM
RIGGLE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND DAWN
KEPT ME FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION BOTH AVAILABLE ON
THE TELEPHONE. OR THE WITNESSES
AVAILABLE. WE ARE HERE THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING NUMBER THE
COMMITTEE ADAM RAGLEY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
ONE IN THE BILL WITH A LOT OF
LONG PANTS. DO YOU THINK
PACKAGING WASTE AND POLLUTION
OUR NATURAL ENVIRONMENT. OUR
GOAL CALCHAMBER SHARES AND A
COALITION PARTNER SHARE.
CHAMBERS AND WORKING FOR TWO
AND A HALF YEARS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON A COMPREHENSIVE
AND IMPLEMENTABLE RECYCLING
INITIATIVE THAT CREATE AND
MARKET. WHICH IS SOURCE
REDUCTION AND INCENTIVIZE
INVESTMENT IN RECYCLING
COMPOSTING INFRASTRUCTURE EIGHT
FOUR BY THOSE WHO MANUFACTURE
THE PACKAGING IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT A BILL AIMED AT REDUCING
WEIGHT WE BELIEVE EIGHTY
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE WILL
ARBITRARILY BANNED PACKAGE
MATERIAL THAT IS ESSENTIAL TO
ENSURING THAT DERIVE UNBROKEN.
AND GROW RIGHT SAFETY FOR
CONSUMERS FROM LIKE TRONIC
MONITORS TV AND HERE'S TO
APPLIANCES OVEN REFRIGERATOR
THE MICROWAVE. TO EPF PACKING
FOR MEDICAL DEVICES IT ALL
REQUIRES EXPANDED POLYSTYRENE
WE ARE NOT AWARE OF HOW YOU
WOULD SHIP A TV LITERALLY A
CROP- YOU KNOW HALF THE WORLD
TO CALIFORNIA WITHOUT USING
EXPAND POLY STYRENE ENSURING
THAT THESE PRODUCTS REMAIN
UNBROKEN. WE THINK THE BILL
ARBITRARILY SET UP IN THE FIRST
HALF. A TAKE BACK PROGRAM WHICH
DOES GET DRIVING YOUR
COLLECTION IMPROPER INDEED
MATERIAL ONLY TO THEN
ARBITRARILY BANNED ALL OF THAT
MATERIAL JUST TWO YEARS LATER
WIRING REQUIRING SMALL LARGE
AND MEDIUM AND LARGE BUSINESSES
TO OFF SET UP A KICK BACK
ELECTION SYSTEM. IN WHICH WE
THEN LITERALLY TWO YEARS LATER
BANNED ALL THAT MATERIAL IT
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE AND WE DO THINK
TAKE BACK PROGRAMS AND ENSURING
AND MARKET AND INVESTING IN
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE IS ALL
IMPORTANT BUT AT AGE THIRTY
SEVEN ONE IS ACTUALLY
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO ACHIEVING
ALL OF THAT NECESSARY OVERALL
TO OUR SYSTEM. AND THAT COULD
BE ANY MATERIALS THAT DO
PROVIDE AND MARKET LIKE ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT- RECYCLED
CONTENT PACKAGING CAN'T FOR
EXAMPLE THAT AN END MARKET FOR
PLASTIC THAT WE I THINK WE
SHOULD BE INTENSIFIED IT NOT
BANNING- ERR PULLOVER HELD UP
AS AN EXAMPLE THAT THAT MIGHT.
BETTER THAN 95% AIR PACKAGE IF
YOU WERE TO PROVIDE THE SAME
PROTECTION FOR THAT PRODUCT AND
SUBSTITUTED WITH A DIFFERENT
MATERIAL YOUR FAMILY TO LOOK AT
THE FULL LIFE CYCLE ANALYSIS OF
NEARLY SHIPPING TENS IF NOT
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF
PRODUCT. WITH HAVE YOUR
PACKAGING THAT WILL REQUIRE
MORE FUEL AND MORE GHG
EMISSIONS I THINK THE BILL IS
WELL INTENDED BUT COMPLETELY
MISSES THE MARK AT THE WHAT IS
TRULY NEEDED TO REDUCE WASTE
REDUCE PLASTIC POLLUTION AND
ACHIEVE A CIRCULAR ECONOMY IN
OTHER REASONS WE OPPOSE THE.
BILL I CAN'T GET ALL OF THAT
OUR TODAY IN A FEW MINUTES HAVE
BEEN ON BUT WOULD LOVE ANSWER
ANY. THAT WITH THE- ON- WAIT WE
THINK WOULD BE A MORE. WAY OF
AT THE- LAW INTENT AS THEY GET
THEIR SEVENTY ONE- WE WERE. ASK
FOR ANOTHER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WITH KATHY. THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBER DON HAPPY WITH ME
Q. CAT THE FIFTY ON BEHALF TELL
FOR MANY AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE AB IS NOTED AT A BY
A REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALCHAMBER SEE MPA AND ITS
MEMBERS AGREE THAT INCREASED
APPLETS ARE NEEDED TO ENSURE
PACKAGING MATERIAL IS
RECYCLABLE AND APPROPRIATELY
RECOVERED AND RECYCLED. TO THAT
END IF YOU CAME UP MEMBERS OF
SPENT THE BETTER PART OF THE
LAST THREE YEARS WORKING IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE CALCHAMBER
AND OUR COLLEAGUE ORGANIZATIONS
DEVELOPING A WORKABLE FRAMEWORK
FOR THE RECOVERY AND RECYCLING
OF SINGLE USE PACKAGING
MATERIALS AS WELL AS EFFORTS TO
DEVELOP POLICY TEAM CENTRALIZED
NEW DOMESTIC MARKET TO RECYCLE
MATERIALS IMPROVED PACKAGING
DESIGNED TO INCREASE
RECYCLABILITY AND DEVELOP VALUE
CHAIN FINANCING FOR COLLECTING
AND STORING VARIOUS PACKAGING
FORMATS. WILL SEEM J. PRESHEAF
THE INTENSITY. THIRTEEN SEVENTY
ONE. LEAVE THAT IS IMPORTANT A
POLICY OF TAKES IN ACCOUNT THE
NECESSARY WILL AFTER G. SEND.
AND PROTECTING. EXCEPT INSTEAD.
AND MULTI OF AN- AFTER SUCH AS
RECYCLE. WE PREVENT
MATERIALISES. ENERGY EMISSIONS
RELATED TO VARIOUS PACKAGE
MATERIALS AND ARRIVED A
SOLUTION- MAKES SENSE
ENVIRONMENTALLY WHILE PROVIDING
THE REGULATED COMMUNITY AND
BROADER SUPPLY CHAIN BUT
PRACTICAL AND IMPLEMENTABLE
COMPLIANCE OBLIGATIONS AND
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
UNFORTUNATELY EIGHTY THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE INCLUDE STAMP ON
SOME PACKING MATERIALS USED FOR
SHIPPING BUT FAILED TO TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT POTENTIAL
UNINTENDED ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS. AND IN FACT COULD VERY
WELL LEAD TO INCREASE WAGES
WERE SOLD THE PRODUCT BREAKAGE
OR SPOILAGE. AT THE SAME TIME
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE THING
OF THESE MATERIALS IT SEEMS TO
ALSO REQUIRE TAKE BACK PROGRAMS
BEATS JOBLESS FOR THE SAME
PACKAGING ITEMS THAT WOULD BE
BANNED. FURTHER AS AMENDED THE
PENALTY STRUCTURES EVEN MORE
CONCERNING OF THE MANDATE OF
REMAINS UNCLEAR IN SOME
RESPECTS BUT PENALTIES BEING
RAISED TO A LEVEL THAT IS NOT
COMMENSURATE WITH THE
CONSIDERATIONS RELATED TO
PRODUCT PROTECTION NEEDS. TO
AVOID. INCREASED WASTE ANY
COMMERCE. I AB THIRTY SEVEN
TAKES A PUNITIVE. RATHER THAN
FOR ON MARK FROM BURKE AND RISK
AND- HIM K. IT'S MEMBERS UNDER.
THEY NEED TO PLAYING YOUR
REDUCTION RECYCLING EXTINGUISH
PACKAGING WASTE PUT INTO THE
MARKET PLACE. TO THAT END CMJ
LOOKS FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR AND LEGISLATURE TO
CRAFTING APPROACH FOR SINGLE
USE PACKAGING THAT IS WORKABLE
AND IMPLEMENTABLE. AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE UNFORTUNATELY WILL
ONLY SEEK TO INCREASE WASTE AND
NEGATIVELY IMPACT CALIFORNIA
BASED MANUFACTURERS WHO
MANUFACTURE AND USE THE
PACKAGING THAT WOULD BE THE END
OF THE BILL. FOR THESE REASONS
CMJ MUST REMAIN OPPOSED AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE I
RESPECTFULLY URGES THE NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION THE VIN WITNESS ROOM
I DON'T SEE ANYONE THERE THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. I
DON'T SEE ANYONE THERE ARE
PRETTY MUCH OPEN THE LINES FOR
THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE LOOKING
FOR NAME AFFILIATION. AND
OPPOSITION TO THIRTEEN SEVENTY
ONE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR
FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM MINE
ONE OH THREE ONE ONE OF THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CARE
MEMBERS JULIE MALACHOWSKI BALL
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION.
TO EIGHTY THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE.
AND ONE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS GAIL CALLAHAN
WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION- OUR MEMBERS GROW
PACKED AND SHIPPED FRESH
PRODUCE I'M SORRY. YOUR
TESTIMONY JUST INDICATE THAT
YOU ARE OPPOSED TO AB. THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE. YEP THERE WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE
ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU HEAR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LOUIS
BROWN ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION. THE BILL
THANK YOU. NINE ONE SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING STEVE
MCCARTY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NINE ONE
OH TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DON'T OFTEN ON BEHALF
OF INTERNET ASSOCIATION ALSO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. NINE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
WE ONLY TALKED ON BEHALF THE
FACT THAT AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS JACOB KATHY WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF HOME APPLIANCE
MANUFACTURERS AND WE ARE CLOSED
RESPECTFULLY A. B. THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU. NINE ONE
OH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WALTER RIDER ETS
INDUSTRY ALLIANCE ON BEHALF OF
THE TWELVE CALIFORNIA MEMBER
MANUFACTURERS IN RECYCLING
LOCATIONS OF EXPANDED
POLYSTYRENE IN OPPOSITION. NINE
ONE OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
OF MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE CHAU
ACTOR ON BEHALF OF THE PLASTICS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION BECAUSE.
NINE ONE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
KAREN MEMBERS LAUREN AGAR
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
INSTITUTE WERE PACKAGING AND
THE ENVIRONMENT AND THE
FLEXIBLE PACKAGING ASSOCIATION
ALSO OPPOSITION. NINE ONE
THIRTEEN YOUR MIND IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHAIR MEMBERS
RJ SETTLEMENT THAT SOME BEHALF
OF THE CONSUMER TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME RIGHT
THANK YOU ARE PRETTY MAY CLOSE
ALLY I WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. WHAT IS RIGHT. I
UNDERSTAND THERE IS A LITTLE
BIT OF TRASH TALK. EARLIER. I
DO THINK THAT- THANK YOU TO
HAVE A MOTION IS THEIR SECOND
SECOND AND THE SECOND THANK YOU
BIZRATE'S CONTINUE. I THINK
THAT- THE THING. THE
PRESENTATION OF WHAT IS- WHAT
IS AND IS NOT RECYCLABLE I
THINK IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
ONE AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
EXPERTISE IN THIS AREA EXPERT I
WOULD BE FOR SHAKE THE
EXPERTISE OF ALL OF MY
ROOMMATES. THANK YOU OTHER.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT
SEE THAT THANK YOU THIS
FRIEDMAN FOR BRINGING THIS AND
I DO SHARE YOUR FRUSTRATION AND
IT JUST SEEMS THAT THERE ARE
CONSTANTLY BILLS MOVING TO TRY
TO DRESS PLASTICS IN THE
ENVIRONMENT AND THEY NEVER GET
ANYWHERE WE HEAR THE SAME
THING- WE AGREE WITH YOU BUT
IT'S NOT THIS WE AGREE WITH YOU
JUST NOT THAT JUST NOT THIS
JUST NOT THAT WELL THEN WHAT IN
IN IN THE END WE KEEP THROWING
RESPONSIBILITY. ON PUBLIC
AGENCIES WHO RESPONSIBLE FOR.
THE TAXPAYERS ULTIMATELY
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL OF THAT.
THAT THE CLEAN UP THE RECOVERY
RECYCLING EVERYTHING AND- IT'S
LONG PAST TIME THAT THE
INDUSTRY ACTUALLY COME FORWARD
WITH SOMETHING TO HELP. THEY'RE
THE ONES MAKING THE MONEY OFF
OF THESE PRODUCTS IN THIS
DISTRIBUTION. THEY NO LONGER
DISAGREE COMPLETELY BUT YET
NOTHING IS QUITE GOOD ENOUGH I
THINK THIS IS A FINE BILL
APPRECIATE THE- THE WORK THAT
YOU. ARE PUTTING INTO IT. AND-
RECEIVE THE- THAT YOU BROUGHT
THIS TO US TODAY. RIGHT WITHOUT
YOU MAY CLOSE I'M IF IT'S OKAY
WITH YOU I WANTED TO MAYBE
ADDRESS A FEW OF THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION BUT I'LL TAKE YOUR
PICTURE. WHATEVER YOU YOU CAN
CLOSE IN ANYWHERE YOU LIKE WELL
I DO APPRECIATE- YOU KNOW THE
RESPECTFUL CALLS- FROM THE
CHAMBER AND FROM OTHERS AND WE
ARE MORE THAN HAPPY TO SIT DOWN
AND TALK TO ANYBODY ABOUT HOW
WE CAN MAKE THIS MORE WORKABLE
I DO BELIEVE THAT THIS IS LOW
HANGING FRUIT AND SOME OF THE-
THE CLAIMS THAT WERE MADE JUST
AREN'T BORNE OUT BY WHAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN THE
MARKETPLACE- TELEVISIONS AND
OTHER BREAKABLE- ELECTRONICS
WERE BROUGHT UP. SAM SONG NO
LONGER USES PLASTIC OR
POLYSTYRENE THEIR PACKAGING
THEY USED TO FOR A KIND OF
FOAM- MOLDED- CARDBOARD FOR
THEIR TELEVISIONS AND THEIR
BREAKABLE ELECTRONICS- SO THE
INDUSTRY IS ALREADY MOVING IN
THIS DIRECTION THEY'RE SHOWING
NOT IN THE FUTURE BUT RIGHT NOW
EVERY SINGLE DAY THAT THIS IS
POSSIBLE EVEN FOR VERY
BREAKABLE OBJECTS. WE HAVE
LIMITED THIS TO LARGE ONLINE
RETAILERS I THINK IT MAYBE IS
TELLING THAT ONE OF THE LARGEST
ONLINE RETAILERS HAS NOT YET-
COME IN OPPOSITION BECAUSE THEY
ARE ALREADY MOVING IN THIS
DIRECTION VERY RAPIDLY AND KNOW
THAT THIS IS WHAT THEIR
CUSTOMERS ARE ARE LOOKING FOR.
A WAY TO THE WERE THE TALK
ABOUT US INVESTING IN
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR RECYCLING
AND I WOULD SAY TWO THINGS
NUMBER ONE IT SHOULDN'T BE ON
PUBLIC AGENCIES AND CONSUMERS
AND RATEPAYERS TO PAID UP ALL
THE BURDEN OF THIS AND IT EVERY
TIME IS LEGISLATURE IS TRIED TO
HAVE MORE PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY AND SHIPPER
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE TRASH
THAT THEY ARE LITERALLY DUMPING
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES. WE'RE
THEY THEY DON'T SUPPORT THOSE
EFFORTS AND. THOSE BILLS VERY
RARELY MAKE IT THROUGH. AND
THIS MAN. IS NOT RECYCLABLE
THERE IS NO MARKET FOR IT IT'S
MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE TO TRY TO
RECYCLE IT OVER AND OVER AND I
DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT IT CAN BE
RATE RECYCLED MORE THAN ONCE.
THE AT THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT
IT IS A DANGEROUS PRODUCT IT'S
A DANGEROUS PRODUCT IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT. IT BREAKS DOWN
INTO MICROPLASTICS IT END UP
EVEN WHEN IT'S AN LANDFILLS IN
OUR WATER STREAMS THAT NOW IS
DETECTABLE AT. PRETTY HIGH
LEVELS IN THE BLOOD OF EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF US IN THIS ROOM
AND EVEN IN THE BLOOD OF NEW
BORN BABIES. THAT'S
UNACCEPTABLE AND IN THIS CASE
IT'S UNNECESSARY AS WE'VE SEEN
IT'S JUST UNNECESSARY. WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST A YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THREE WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. TO APPROPRIATIONS
KALRA PLEASE STONE HI STONE I
CHAO. CHU CHU I. DAVIES. DAVIES
NO GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I HOLDEN
KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN REYES. THREE NINE
REYES I. SMITH SMITH NOW. THE
BILL NEEDS ONE MORE SO WILL BE
PUTTING IT ON CALL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT WILL NOW GO TO
OUR ITEM NUMBER THREE AB NINE
THIRTY SEVEN MS CARILLO.
GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT TO YOU TODAY I'M
HERE 2% AB NINE THREE SEVEN THE
VISION ACT. WHICH WOULD PROTECT
REFUGEE AND IMMIGRANT
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE BEEN
DEEMED ELIGIBLE FOR RELEASE
FROM BEING FUNNELED INTO THE
IMMIGRATION DETENTION. SYSTEM
BY CALIFORNIA LOCAL JAILS AND
PRISONS. THESE ARE CALIFORNIANS
WHO HAVE COMPLETED THEIR TIME
EARNED THEIR PAROLE AND HAVE
HAD THEIR SENTENCES COMMUTED.
BY GOV BY THE GOVERNOR AFTER A
CLOSE REVIEW OF THE CLEMENCY
APPLICATION. WHEN LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION ASSIST WITH
TRANSFERS OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
TO ICE. THE NORTHER RECORD OF
REHABILITATION STABLE REENTRY
PLAN. AND THEIR NETWORK
COMMUNITY AND FAMILY SUPPORT.
MANY CALIFORNIA COUNTIES
INCLUDING LOS ANGELES SANTA
CLARA SAN FRANCISCO HUMBLED SAN
JOAQUIN SANTA CRUZ AND CONTRA
COSTA. HAVE RECOGNIZED THIS.
AND HAVE HALTED OR CUT BACK ON
TRANSFERS TO IMMIGRATION
OFFICIALS WHEN SOMEONE HAS
SERVED THEIR TIME. MEMBERS IF
NOT WERE FOR WHERE THESE
INDIVIDUALS WERE BORN. THEY
WOULD BE ALLOWED TO RETURN HOME
TO THEIR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES. AB NINE THREE
SEVEN WILL MOVE OUR STATE
CLOSER TO FULFILLING ITS
COMMITMENT. TO IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM DISPROPORTIONATELY HARMS
BLACKS LATINOS INDIGENOUS. AND
AAPI COMMUNITIES IN RECENT
YEARS THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE
DEMONSTRATED A COMMITMENT. AND
A WILLINGNESS TO REFORM OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
MASS INCARCERATION. HOWEVER FOR
IMMIGRANTS WHO HAVE EARNED
THEIR RELEASE THIS JUST MEANS
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE HANDED
OVER TO ICE AND FACE PERMANENT
SEPARATION. FROM THEIR FAMILIES
AND THEIR COMMUNITIES. LET ME
BE VERY CLEAR. THE VISION ACT
DOES NOT INTERFERE WITH FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S ABILITY TO SET
IMMIGRATION LAW. THIS BILL ONLY
DOESN'T THIS BILL ALSO DOESN'T
PRECLUDE STATE AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM PARTICIPATING
IN JOINT TASK FORCES IF THE
PURPOSE. OF THE TASK FORCE'S
CRIMINAL LAW ENFORCEMENT. NOT
INTEGRATION ENFORCEMENT. ON
MARCH THIRTIETH. A WOMAN FROM
OMANI NAME GABBY SOLANO WAS
TRANSFERRED TO BY CDCR TO ICE.
GABBY CAME TO THIS COUNTRY AT
THE AGE OF TWO AS A LAWFUL
PERMANENT RESIDENT. GABBY IS A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HOWEVER AND
SPENT HALF HER LIFE BEHIND BARS
FOR A CRIME COMMITTED. BY HER
ABUSIVE EX PARTNER. AFTER
SERVING TWENTY YEARS IN STATE
PRISON GOVERNOR BROWN COMMUTED
HER SENTENCE IN RECOGNITION OF
HER DEMONSTRATED RECORD OF
COMMITMENT. TO SERVICE
MENTORSHIP AND REHABILITATION
HOWEVER. RATHER THAN ALLOW
GABBY TO RETURN HOME TO HER
FAMILY INTO THE CALIFORNIA. THE
COMPANY CONTRACTED WITH ICE.
PICTURE OF FROM A CDC OUR
FACILITY IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND TRANSPORTED HER TO A
DETENTION CENTER IN COLORADO
WHERE SHE REMAINS TODAY.
IMMIGRANT CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
SERVED THEIR SENTENCES OR
OTHERWISE HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED
FOR RELEASE. SHOULD NOT FACE A
SECOND PUNISHMENT. WE SHOULD
NOT FUNNEL THEM INTO A FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION DETENTION AND
DEPORTATION SYSTEM. DIVISION
ACT WILL END IS TRANSFERS TO OR
FROM OUR LOCAL JAILS NCDC ARE
IN PRACTICE. A PRACTICE THE
TREATS PEOPLE DIFFERENTLY JUST
SIMPLY BASED ON WHERE THEY WERE
BORN. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME. ON IN MY OFFICE ON
THIS BILL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AS THIS MOVES
FORWARD. AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY
OVER THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF
TWO INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
DIRECTLY IMPACTED JULIE ANDREAS
IS THE SISTER OF KOUSEI LEAH
FORMALLY INCARCERATED
FIREFIGHTER. WHO WAS
TRANSFERRED TO ICE LAST YEAR
AND REMAINS AN ICE DETENTION.
FACILITY IN LOUISIANA. BORI PJ
I'D IT'S A COMMUNITY ADVOCATE
WITH AN ASIAN PRISONER SUPPORT
COMMITTEE WHO HIMSELF WAS
TRANSFERRED TO ICE AFTER
EARNING RELEASE AND SPENT A
YEAR AND A HALF IN IMMIGRATION
DETENTION HE CONTINUES TO BE.
AT RISK OF DEPORTATION TO A
COUNTRY HE NEVER KNEW SINCE HE
WAS BORN IN A REFUGEE CAMP IN
THAILAND AFTER HIS FAMILY FLED
CAMBODIA TO ESCAPE. AT THE
GENOCIDE. ADDITIONALLY ANGELA
CHAN WHO IS A POLICY DIRECTOR
AND SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY WITH
ASIAN AMERICANS. ADVANCING
JUSTICE ARE BILL SPONSOR IS
ALSO ON THE LINE FOR ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
AND TO BE CLEAR YOU TAKE IN THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE YES
INDICATED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALL RIGHT SO WE I DO HAVE.
THREE WITNESSES. LISTED ONE IS
ON STANDBY FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS AND THAT'S ANGELA
CHAN. ALL THREE ARE ON THE
TELEPHONE. JULIE ADDRESS ON THE
TELEPHONE AND PJ I AM FROM THE
ASIAN PRISONER SUPPORT
COMMITTEE. MS INTERESTS WERE
CHAU ALLY. YES YES I AM ON THE
LINE CAN YOU HEAR ME- YES GO
AHEAD PLEASE. OKAY THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING CHAIR STONE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
COREY PJ ID I WAS BORN IN A
REFUGEE CAMP IN THAILAND.
ASSEMBLY FLAT THE CAMARO'S
GENOCIDE IN CAMBODIA MUST I
MEAN I CAME TO THIS COUNTRY
WHEN I WAS FOUR I GREW UP IN A
POOR NEIGHBORHOOD IN STOPPING
BUT I SPENT MY CHILDHOOD
SURROUNDED BY VIOLENCE. AT
EIGHT YEARS OLD I SURVIVED A
MASS SHOOTING AT CLEVELAND
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL NOW KNOWN AS
THE CLEVELAND SCHOOL MASSACRE
SHOOTER OPENED EXPECTED ANTI
ASIAN SENTIMENTS. ALL THE
FATALITIES SHOT CHILDREN. AND
THOSE WHO DID WAS SOUTHEAST
ASIAN REFUGEE JUST LIKE ME.
THAT THEY HAVE WITNESSED THE
FATAL SHOOTING OF MY COUSINS
FASTER CHILD I LIVE IN CONSTANT
STATE OF FEAR. I COULDN'T FIT
IN WITH OTHER KIDS AT SCHOOL
BECAUSE OF THE LANGUAGE
BARRIERS AND I WOULD ALSO GET
PULLED BY OTHER KIDS LOOKING
ASIAN. THEY WERE SPIT ON ME
TAKE MY BELONGINGS AND TOLD ME
TO GO BACK TO MY COUNTRY. I
FELT ISOLATED AND SOUGHT
ATTENTION. TO GAINES. I DID ON
DIALYSIS OF. AND WAS AS A- FOR
YEARS OLD. DURING MY CALL
RATIONING HAVE TALKED WITH TO
LEARN THE SCHOOL. I TRANSFORM
THE JUSTICE HOW THE PRACTICES.
HELP YOU HEAL FROM OWN TRUMP. I
WANTED TO BE A CON FOR MY- GET
BACK TO MY COULD. I HAVE MY G.
D. ASSOCIATES DEGREE. BECAME A
CERTIFIED COUNSELOR AND MENTOR
AT RISK YOUTH. THROUGH A
PROGRAM CALLED SQUIRE. I
THOUGHT PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE
LIFE SKILLS AND HELP WITH FEEL
FROM THE- TRAUMA. ABOUT TWENTY
YEARS A STATE PER. THE
CALIFORNIA BOARDING KNOWLEDGE
MUCH. GRANTED ME PAROLE.
HOWEVER INSTEAD OF RETURNING
HOME TO MY FAMILY. I WAS
TRUSTED WITH ICE DETENTION
CENTER THAT WAS FORCED TO STAY
THERE FOR YEAR AND A HALF
FIGHTING DEPORTATION TO
CAMBODIA. A COUNTRY AND- I.
REALIZE I WAS. THE TONIGHT WITH
A HORRIBLE STORY PUBLIC
CONSUMING. DID MANAGE EMMA
FAMILY WAS THE PROJECT IN THE
CALL FROM MY WAY BE. ONE OF
YOUR LIKE FROM THE THINK IT
BACK TO MY COULD. LIVE A LIFE
FEAR DO TO STRONG LEGAL
ENGINEER OPPORTUNITY I WAS
RELEASED BUT STILL PLACE TO
PROTECT MANY OTHER IMMIGRANTS
TO SUPPORT ON THE FRONT OF THE
FROM LOVED ONES THE PETITION
THE VISION BACK THEY- BASED
THIS IS YOU NEED. THEN HOME
SPEAKING PROPERLY THE LAPTOP
TO. PLACE PUT THIS THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. AND THIS
ADDRESS ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
READING TEARS DOWN CAN. MY NAME
IS AND I AM THE OF. FORMALLY
PARSER FIRED AND POSITIVE SHE
FROM JOBS. I AM A COURT WANTED
TECH ANY RESEARCH GRADUATE I AN
ASSOCIATE MANAGER FAMILY
THERAPY. I WAS FORTY ENOUGH TO
WORK WITH STUDENTS RESEMBLE MY
BROTHER HOUSE LEADS UP AND
CHALLENGER. AFTER RIGHT A FIFTY
YEAR EVEN NUMBER. IN NINETEEN
SIX THEY WERE BROUGHT TO THE U.
S. AFTER. ALONG WITH A COACH
SHOCK WORKFORCE TO LIVE IN
POVERTY NEIGHBORHOOD. BUT
THAT'S FINE STRIDES MARK. THE
PRODUCT OF AN- AT AGE EIGHTEEN
CALLER SINCE THE TWENTY FIVE
YEARS SO IN THE PRISON. ON
AUGUST SIXTH TWENTY TWO. I
WAITED OUTSIDE PRISON BREAKOUT
THE RELEASE. THAT DAY WITH THE
TO BE A DAY OR SO. COOKING
KAYAKING ON LAKE WITH A
IMMEDIATE. HOWEVER THAN CALL
BACK TO AND. EIGHTY THREE POINT
EIGHTY C. R. HIM TO I WOULDN'T
MIND AND- EMOTIONS THE FILM
HELP WERE YEAH. FUNNY I MIGHT
BACK HOME. ONE AND A HALF HOURS
AWAY. I ZERO AND THAT MAKES HOW
HAVE MORE THAN NINETEEN STREET
IN WEST HAS ONLY. AS THE END
BECAUSE- FIREFIGHTER TO BEGIN
EXPECT CHANCE BUT OF HIM
CONTROL COVEN. NINETY PENSION
AND POSSIBLY NOT IT BACK HOME
SO IF YOU WANT SOME FOR. I TOOK
CAN I SEE TEN CENTER IT WILL BE
THE OUT THAT. TO MILE AWAY FROM
THEM. WHERE HE REMAINS TODAY IF
ACT AB THREE. AND DEAR TO MY-
NOT ONLY BECAUSE OF STORY BUT
BECAUSE THERE ARE STILL.
STORIES I CAN'T THANK YOU GREW
UP A LIST NEIGHBORHOOD WITH THE
SAME STORY THANK YOU THE SAME.
AND PAIN WERE THEY'RE FOUND.
BECAUSE THEIR LOVE ONE WHAT OUR
VOTE BE HANDED A TO AYE. OUR
PHONE CALL BUT I ARE GOING LOOK
HEALTHY. OF HIM SHARING HOW
INTIMATE DETAIL BECAUSE THEY
CONDITION OF THE THAT WERE YES.
WITH FOR CAR. TRANSFER TO AFTER
SERVING TIME. WHAT LIVE IN THE
STATE WITH YOUR PRESENT. THE
EMAIL. I CANNOT YOU BEGIN
IMAGINE WHAT THAT LIKE TO HIM.
WE CONTINUE TO. EACH DAY HOPE
HE WILL BE RELEASED AND NO I
FAMILY. OPTION DOOR. AS
TREATMENT. PLEASE VOTE YES THE
VISION. TRANSFERS STOP
SEPARATION OF. IT'S OFTEN. TALK
BUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU. RIGHT
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINE FOR THOSE WHO'D LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A BI NINE
THIRTY SEVEN- I'M TAKING NAME
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT FOR A
BI. NINE THIRTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE
THIRTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NINE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH MY NAME IS
PAM STADIUM I SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
WOMEN PRISONERS AND THE ALMOST
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY WOMEN
FACING ICE DEPORTATION AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB NINE THREE
SEVEN THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I COLD MORNING MY NAME
IS ELLIE I AM WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STOP COLLECTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS ERICA I'M
CONFUSED JUSTICE COALITION AND
A WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE ONE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS A LOT OF
SENTIMENTAL WITH THE NATIONAL
DAY LABORER ORGANIZING NETWORK
AND WE ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
OF NINETY SEVEN DIVISION ACT.
MY MONEY ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS KIßM
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE ASIAN
PRISONER SUPPORT COMMITTEE AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
POSITION ACT. NINE ONE FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
HARRY MARC ELIAS AND I
REPRESENT LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN WE ARE
CO SPONSORS AND PROBABLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE THIRTY
SEVEN DIVISION ACT THANK YOU.
LINE ONE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE
POLITICALLY FIGUEROA CHAIR AT
THE ORANGE COUNTY EQUALITY
COALITION IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT AT EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN
DIVISION ACT THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING JUSTIN ROWS- ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER A PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB
NINE THREE SEVEN THANK YOU.
NINE ONE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JULIE LIMóN I'M FROM
CATHOLIC COMMUNITY SYNAGOGUE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY SEVEN. NINE EIGHTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE EIGHTY NINE YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MOVING ON TO LINE TWENTY NINE
LINE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS STAN LEE AND STRONG SUPPORT
AN INVASION ACT NOTHING HAPPENS
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA. ALLIANCE
AVOIDANCE OF COLOR POLICY LINK.
AND THEN COALITION IMMIGRANT
JUSTICE RESILIENCE S. C.
RESTORE CACTUS SATURDAY PEOPLE
POWER. CAMPUS COPA DEFENDER
OFFICE YOUNG WOMAN SHE AND
TENER AND FIFTY SEVEN. THANK MY
ONE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS SALLY CHAIN WITH THE
SOUTHEAST ASIA RESOURCE ACTION
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU. OUR STATE WITH
CALIFORNIA INDIVISIBLE AND
STRONG SUPPORT AS EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU. NINE
ONE SIXTY NNE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS WILLIE LUKA
I WOULD WHEN THE SCENE- IN
VENTURA COUNTY CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF DIVISION ACT. NINE
ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ERIC MOORE
AND I'M WITH ALL WHO MAKE A
BEELINE SUBORDINATE COLOR WE
ARE COSPONSORED AND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINETY SEVEN.
NINE ONE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS NOT ON COOPER FROM THE
AUSTIN MARC MARON BEHALF WITH
THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE THIRTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. NINE ONE FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS FOR
MANY HONG FROM A TOWN BUILDING
API COMMUNITY POWER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE VISION THAT.
NINE NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
LISA BENNETT WITH ICE OUT OF
MARIN INDIVISIBLE SAUSALITO AND
SEARCH MARIN IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE VISION ACT. NINE ONE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
I'M A LARGER CHUNK FROM THE
CENTER FOR EMPOWERING REFUGEES
AND IMMIGRANTS MASON OAKLAND
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE VISION. NINE FIFTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS NEW ANA THURSTON
MILGRAM EXPAND JEWISH ACTION
CALIFORNIA WE ARE PROUD TRUMP
BUT AS A FINISHED PRODUCT. NINE
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BAKER KRAMER
MATTER ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION INTO COURT.
NINE ONE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS MONICA CANDY AND PART
OF THAT INDIVISIBLE SAN JOSE
BRING STRONG SUPPORT AT EIGHTY
NINE THIRTY SEVEN. NINE ONE
SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE NINE ONE SIX
BEFORE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
ALISON DAHLE REPRESENTING THAT
WRITES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
NINE THREE SEVEN VISION ACT.
NINE ONE ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
NINE FIFTY ONE. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. ONE FIFTY ONE YOU'RE
LIKE MAN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
EVERYONE MY NAME IS GETTING
THAT I WITH THE LONG BEACH
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS COALITION AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
VISION THAT. LINE ONE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
BANGALORE CAUGHT UP WITH THE
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT CALLING
IN SUPPORT. LINE ONE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY ONE FIFTY YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MOVING ON TO NINE ONE
NINE I'M SORRY NINE NINETY FIVE
POINT NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ERIN
FOR A LOT OF GRASSY RESULT
POLICY DIRECTOR OF ALLIANCE SAN
DIEGO AND A RESIDENT OF
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVENTY
SEVEN. ALLIANCE INDIGO CROWD TO
BE A CO SPONSORED THE VISION
ACT. NINE ONE FIFTY ONE. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN CALLAHAN JOHN WITH
THE MULTI CULTURAL CENTER OF
MONEY WE ARE A STRONG SUPPORT
DIVISION ACT. NINE ONE SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS GOD NAY ON
BEHALF OF THE JUSTICE
REINVESTMENT COALITION OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE VISION ON.
ONE ONE SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS ALLISON CANDOR
CANCER OF WHICH ARE AVENUE
BAPTIST CHURCH IN OAKLAND AND
MY CONGREGATION IS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE VISION ACT
EIGHTY NINE THREE SEVEN. NINE
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY THIRTY
DEMOCRAT SW CALIFORNIA CALLING
A STRONG SUPPORT. NINE ONE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY MY NAME IS
CARMEN MARTINEZ I'M GOING HOME
IS ON THE LIST OF ONES THAT
GENERAL FUND UNIT WHAT FOR
SUPPORT ONLY BE. NINETY SEVEN.
NINE ONE SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS LYDIA SILVA BY THE WAY
IF COMMUNITY UNITED AGAINST
VIOLENCE AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE VISION THAT.
YEAH. NINE ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
NINE FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I NEED TO
CREATE A MARKET WITH PARENTS
ARE SYSTEM COMPRISED EDUCATION
NETWORK PASSCODE CONSERVE THE
BILL AND STRONG SUPPORT. NINE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING CHRISTIAN AVI ARE FROM
THEIR IMMIGRANT WE ARE LEGALLY
SOURCE HONOR CO SPONSOR AND-
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. NINE ONE
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM YES DON'T
AND A QUORA FOR COMMUNITY LEGAL
SERVICES TO MEET PAUL ALSO AND
CHONG SUPPORT OF THE VISION ACT
AB NINE THREE. ONE ONE SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
SANDRA DOWN THERE WITH THE
ORANGE COUNTY JUSTICE BOND
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
VISION ACT THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
YOUNGER AND ENDED UP WITH A NEW
COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE ON THE PART
FOR THE VISION I. NINE ONE
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THE
DISTRICT ALL CALLING ON BEHALF
OF BOTH THE RAPID RESPONSE
NETWORK IN SUPPORT- DIVISION
ACT. EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
FOR BACK AMERICAN WITH FREEDOM
FOR IMMIGRANTS HAVE CO DIVISION
ACCURATELY ARE STAUNCH SUPPORT.
LINE ONE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JUSTIN CHANG I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE P. I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE VISION
ACT. NINE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS CHERYL AS WITH ALL
OF US ARE NOT SACRAMENTO AND I
AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
VISION NEXT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE HIRSCH AND I'M A BORN
AND RAISED CALIFORNIA THEN READ
THAT NUMBER EIGHTY FIFTY FOUR
CALLING TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE MISSION ACT. ONE ONE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JIM WEINBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINE
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU. LINE
NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NINETY
SEVEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
HAD BERRIEN ONG ON BEHALF OF
LONG BEACH SOUTHEAST ASIA ANTI
DEPORTATION COLLECTED AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
VISIONS ACT. NINE EIGHTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SH HI THIS IS KAYLA
KOEHN WITH THE INTERFAITH
MOVEMENT FOR HUMAN INTEGRITY
AND WE ARE PROUD CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT A DIVISION ACT. NINE
ONE EIGHTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME A GREAT FLANK ON CALLING
FROM HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH STATE
POWER CO SPONSOR. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. RIGHT THANK YOU
OPERATOR WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I DO NOT HAVE
ANYBODY. LISTED AS A SPEAKER IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE WITNESS
VIDEO ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THE B.
NINE THIRTY SEVEN. SEEING NONE
THERE'S NO ONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. ABOUT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE RECEIVED- MY
NUMBERS. NINE ONE FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS RETURN
MEMBERS CORY STOSSEL ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION I KNOW
THIS IS JUST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU'D LIKE A
SUBSTANTIVE TESTIMONY AND HAVE
PROVIDED OTHERWISE I CAN JUST
LET YOU KNOW THAT. REGRETTABLY
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IS IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB NINE THIRTY
SEVEN I KNOW MISTER CELLS- WE
HAVE NOT HAD ANYBODY SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SO THAT OPPORTUNITY
STILL EXISTS. HELLO THIS IS
ALSO. OKAY. WE CAN MOTHER I'M
STILL HERE. YES GO AHEAD OKAY
SORRY- AS WE SAID IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE DEBATE ABOUT SB
FIFTY FOUR SHARES DO NOT
UNDERTAKE IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT THAT SAID MANY
COUNTIES MAKE PUBLIC
CONSIDERABLE INFORMATION ABOUT
PERSONS DETAINED IN JAILS FOR
SEVERAL REASONS ALSO STATE AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
MAY BE ASKED TO PROVIDE SAFETY
SUPPORT. FOR REST UNDERTAKEN BY
OTHER AGENCIES SB NINE THIRTY
SEVEN WOULD ELIMINATE THE
ABILITY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
DO EITHER OF THOSE THINGS IF
THE ACTION HAPPEN TO INCLUDE IN
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT PURPOSE.
FURTHER ELIMINATING THE
REQUIREMENT THAT OFFENDERS
PLACE OF BIRTH BE INCLUDED IN
BASIC INFORMATION STORED IN
STATE OR LOCAL CRIMINAL
OFFENDER RECORD INFORMATION
SYSTEMS. WILL MAKE THAT
INFORMATION LESS ACCURATE AND
LESS USEFUL TO THE STAKEHOLDERS
THAT RELY UPON THAT
INFORMATION. THE RESPECTIVE OF
WHETHER THE PERSON SUBJECT ANY
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT ACTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
THOSE REASONS SEE THIS IS A
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
NINE THREE SEVEN. THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. ONE ONE SIXTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SURE MEMBERS JONATHAN
FILLED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION ALSO
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NINE
ONE FIFTY. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE IT LOOKS LIKE NINE ONE
FIFTY HAS- REJOINED THE MAIN
CONFERENCE. THERE NOT FOR THE
COMMENTED QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR WILL NOW. CLOSE THE
LINES THEN I'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE FOR. QUESTIONS COMMENTS
MR CHIU. THREE THANK YOU FOR.
CHAIR. TENSION IT IS TRULY
DOUBLE PUNISHMENT- BUT I'M
GOING SPEAK TODAY AS AN ASIAN
AMERICAN I KNOW THAT- IN
SOCIETY THEIR STEREOTYPES THAT
THE FOLKS WHO WOULD BE
ADDRESSED BY THIS BILL. ARE
MOSTLY FROM THE LATINO
COMMUNITY THAT IS NOT TRUE I'M
GONNA SPEAK AS THE- IMMEDIATE
PAST CHAIR OF THE ACCOUNT
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AND SHARE.
THE MANY STORIES I'VE HEARD
OVER THE YEARS- FROM SO MANY
FAMILY MEMBERS OF REFUGEES FROM
FROM OUR COMMUNITY BAND AND
THEY BRING TO US- MANY VERSIONS
OF THE SAME STORY SO THE STORY
OF THE KID. WHO EMIGRATED AT
THE AGE OF THREE FOUR FIVE.
FLED PERSECUTION WAR BY FROM
THEIR BIRTH COUNTRY- THEY
THEMSELVES EXPERIENCED HORRIFIC
VIOLENCE. THEY COME TO OUR
COUNTRY HAVING EXPERIENCED
INCREDIBLE TRAUMA. THEY HAVE
SOME CHALLENGES ADJUSTING IN
THEIR TEENAGE YEARS TO GET INTO
SOME TROUBLE THEY RESTED
THEY'RE CONVICTED AND THEY DO
THEIR FULL TIME. AND WHAT
HAPPENS IS THEY COME OF THE
FROM JUSTICE THERE PICKED UP
FOR DEEP. EVEN THOUGH THEY
DON'T SPEAK THE LANGUAGE OF
THEIR ORIGINAL HOME COUNTRY
HAVE NO TIES TO THEIR ORIGINAL
BIRTH COUNTRY HAVE NO FAMILY.
AND TO OUR COMMUNITY. THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE OUR FAMILY
MEMBERS THERE ARE PARENTS THEIR
SPOUSES. THEY ARE MODEL
CITIZENS ARE MODEL EXAMPLES
PARTICULARLY TO AT RISK YOUTH
FROM OUR COMMUNITY. AND HELP
THEM FROM GETTING. FUTURE
TROUBLE THESE ARE THE FOLKS.
THAT WE NEED TO HELP AND JUST
TO. PROVIDE SOME STATISTICS ON
THIS- MANY OF THESE REFUGEES.
ARE FROM OUR SOUTHEAST ASIAN
REFUGEE COMMUNITY WHO ARE THREE
TO FOUR TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE
DEPORTED. FOR PAST CONVICTIONS
COMPARED TO OTHER IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES SAID JUST AS AN
EXAMPLE TWENTY EIGHTEEN. ON
SIXTEEN THOUSAND- SOUTHEAST
ASIANS IN OUR COUNTRY RECEIVE
FINAL DEPORTATION ORDERS MORE
THAN THIRTEEN THOUSAND OF WHICH
WERE BASED ON PAST CRIMINAL
RECORDS. 80% OF DEPORTATION
ORDERS FOR OUR SOUTHEAST ASIAN
REFUGEES WERE LINKED TO OLD
CRIMINAL RECORDS COMPARED TO
TWENTY NINE PERCENT. OF ALL
IMMIGRANTS WITH DEPORTATION
ORDERS. AND DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IN THE IN THE
MIDDLE OF. THE TERM OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP. THERE WAS A
TWO HUNDRED AND 79% SPIKE ANTI.
OF CAMBODIAN REFUGEES. AND A
58% INCREASE IN THE DEPORTATION
OF VIETNAMESE REFUGEES. NOW I
WISH WE COULD SAY THAT THE
TARGETING OF OUR SOUTHEAST
ASIAN REFUGEE COMMUNITY. HAS
STOPPED BUT IT HAS NOT
UNFORTUNATELY IN THE FIRST
MONTHS OF THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION- JUST AS AN
EXAMPLE. THE MIDDLE OF MARCH
THE SAME WEEK AS THE HORRIFIC
ATLANTA SHOOTING. AND DURING
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S MORATORIUM ON
DEPORTATION. WE HAD THIRTY
THREE VIETNAMESE AMERICAN
REFUGEE COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO
ARE DEPORTED. AND FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE. AS WE FACE A VERY
DISTURBING RISE IN ANTI ASIAN
HATE. I THINK WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT THE POLICIES THAT WE MOVE
FORWARD TO REALLY UPLIFT OUR
COMMUNITIES AND I BELIEVE THE
VISION ACT. HAS TO BE CENTRAL
TO THAT SO WITH THAT I'M VERY
HAPPY. TO SUPPORT IT REALLY DO-
HOPE THAT OUR COLLEAGUES THINK
ABOUT THE HUMAN IMPACT OF THIS
AND THE WITHOUT HAVING A MOTION
TO MOVE THIS FOR. THE YOU FOR
YOUR MOTION A SERVICE. OUR O.
SUCH THAT. OTHER QUESTIONS
COMING. SIENET MISCREANT CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR HAVE TOO
MANY WINDOWS OPEN ON MY IPAD-
I. PROPITIATE THE CONVERSATION
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
FOR YOUR COMMENTS I THINK THAT
WE HAVE SEEN THE IMMIGRATION
DEBATE OFTEN LANDS ON A LATINO
LANDS AND THAT'S NOT THE CASE
AT ALL- IMMIGRANTS FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD ARE IMPACTED BY
LOSS THAT THE UNITED STATES
HOUSE. I AM A FORMERLY
UNDOCUMENTED CHILD IN THIS
COUNTRY MY FAMILY ALSO FLED THE
CIVIL WAR I HAVE MANY COUSINS
WHO HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WHO DID
NOT HAVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES
AND CHOICES- THAT I HAD AND SO
THIS IS A VERY- THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT'S VERY CLOSE TO MY
HEART AND CLOSE TO MY
COMMUNITY. I WOULD ALSO SAY
THAT THE ULTIMATE QUESTION THAT
WE ALMOST ASK OURSELVES IS DO
YOU BELIEVE IN A JUST JUSTICE
SYSTEM DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
IS ALSO DOING THEIR JOB IN THE
REHABILITATION PORTION THERE
ARE THOUSANDS OF IMMIGRANTS.
ACROSS OUR STATE THAT ARE
CAUGHT UP IN THE SYSTEM THAT
SIMPLY IDENTIFIES THEM AS NON
CITIZENS IMMIGRATION IS NOT
SOLELY SYNONYMOUS WITH BEING
UNDOCUMENTED THE CASE THAT I
PRESENTED WAS OF A LAWFUL
PERMANENT RESIDENT WHO CAME TO
THIS COUNTRY AT THE AGE OF TWO
WHO IS NOW IN AN ICE FACILITY
JUST BASED ON AFTER SPENDING
TWENTY YEARS IN PRISON. BASED
ON THE ACTIONS OF HER PERFORMER
ABUSIVE PARTNER WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING TO ENSURE THAT-
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE SERVED
THEIR TIME THAT HAVE PAID THEIR
DEBT TO SOCIETY THAT HAVE GONE
THROUGH THE RIGOROUS COURSE OF
THE PAROLE BOARD HEARINGS THAT
HAVE A DEMONSTRATED THEIR THEIR
ABILITY TO COME BACK INTO
SOCIETY TO BE WITH THEIR
FAMILIES TO START A NEW. THAT
THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SO REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY
WERE BORN THAT IS THE SIMPLE
BASIS OF A JUST SOCIETY AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE TO ENSURE THAT THE VISION
ACT HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO- A- CALL THE ROLL.
STONE HI STONE AYE CHAU. CHIU
CHU I DAVIES. DAVIES NO CONCERN.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA. KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN. REYES SMITH. SMITH
NOW. THANK THREE MORE VOTES-
PLACE TO BELONG THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MR LOW OUR- NUMBER
FIVE AB. EIGHT ONE FOUR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU FOR ALL THAT
EFFORT. AB EIGHT FOURTEEN WOULD
PROHIBIT EMPLOYEES EVERY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY FROM
ENGAGING IN CONTACT TRACING IN
PLACE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS ON
DATA COLLECTED FOR CONTACT
TRACING PURPOSES SPECIFICALLY
THE BILL PROHIBITS DATA
COLLECTED RECEIVE HER PREPARED
FOR CONTACT THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THANK YOU
TRACING PURPOSES FROM BEING
USED TO MAINTAIN OR DISCLOSE
FOR ANY OTHER PURPOSES. IN
FACILITATING CONTACT TRACING
EFFORTS AS WE'VE LEARNED OVER
THE PAST YEAR ONE OF THE
STRATEGIES DEPLOYED TO LIMIT
THE TRANSMISSION OF CODE
NINETEEN IS THE USE OF CONTACT
TRACING WHICH IDENTIFIES CODE
NINETEEN POSITIVE INDIVIDUALS
AND THOSE THEY MAY HAVE HAD
CLOSE CONTACT WITH. WHO ARE
ADVISED TO SELF QUARANTINE
LIMITING THE SPREAD OF THE
VIRUS SUCCESSFUL CONTACT
TRACING REQUIRES THE SHARING OF
SIGNIFICANT PERSONAL
INFORMATION INCLUDING A
PERSON'S NAME ADDRESS PHONE
NUMBER AND OTHER PERSONAL
IDENTIFYING DATA. IN MAY OF
LAST YEAR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH LUNCH CONNECTED
CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE
COMPREHENSIVE CONTACT TRACING
PROGRAM AND PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN IN DECEMBER THE STATE
LAUNCHED CALIFORNIA NOTIFIED AN
APPLICATION THAT CALIFORNIA'S
CAN DOWNLOAD ON THEIR PHONE
THAT WILL NOTIFY USERS IF
ANOTHER APPLICATION USER
THEY'VE BEEN IN CLOSE CONTACT
WITH HAS TESTED POSITIVE FOR
COKE IN NINETEEN. WELL THIS
INFORMATION WILL BE REQUIRED TO
SUCCESSFULLY STOP THE SPREAD OF
CODE NINETEEN AND FUTURE
PANDEMICS THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS ABOUT THE STATE OF
POTENTIALLY BEING USED FOR NON
HEALTH CARE RELATED PURPOSES
INCLUDING MARKETING AND BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR ARE LESS LIKELY TO
WILLINGLY INTERACT WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT REGARDLESS OF THE
CONTACTS DUE TO DISTRUST AND
FEAR. AND HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
COVE IN NINETEEN CONTACT
TRACING IS NOT AN APPROPRIATE
FUNCTION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
UTILIZING LINE FOR SENT TO
CONTACT TREE WILL. JUST AND
TRACING EFFORTS AND HINDER. OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH GOALS AB EIGHT
FOURTEEN WILL PROTECT THE DATA
PRIVACY OF CALIFORNIANS. AND
BUILD PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN THE
CONTACT TRACING PROGRAM NEEDED
TO SAVE LIVES AND PROTECT THE
PUBLIC FROM FURTHER SPREAD OF
COVER NINETEEN. ANY POTENTIAL
FUTURE PANDEMICS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MR LEVINE WE DO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES INDICATED BECCA
KRAMER VOTER FROM ACLU AND
SARDAR FROM THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER. BOTH
ON THE TELEPHONE ARE EITHER OF
YOU WITH US. YES GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
TARDAR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER C. A. B. C. IN SUPPORT
AT JPP WE'VE WORKED TIRELESSLY
TO COUNTER THE CHILLING EFFECT
THE LIMIT WE BROUGHT ABOUT
UNDER THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
AND TO ENCOURAGE IMMIGRANTS TO
ENROLL IN HEALTH CARE AND OTHER
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS A WHILE
BACK NICOLE BEEN NINETEEN
TESTING TREATMENT AND
VACCINATION CONCERNS AROUND
DATA PRIVACY ARE ONE OF THE
PRIMARY REASONS CITED BY
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. FOR THEIR
HESITATION TO ENGAGE WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH INITIATIVES LIKE
CONTACT TRACING WELL ADVOCATES
AND PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
ALIKE ARE MAKING EVERY EFFORT
TO CURB THIS HESITANCY IT ONLY
MAKES OUR COLLECTIVE JOB HARDER
WE CANNOT GUARANTEE STATUTORY
PROTECTIONS OF PEOPLE'S
INFORMATION PRIVACY ESPECIALLY
FROM BEING SHARED WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT STATUTORY
PROTECTIONS EXIST FOR PROGRAMS
LIKE MEDICAID AND COVERED
CALIFORNIA PREVENTING ANY DATA
SHARING WITH NOT ONLY LINE
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT BUT
WITH ANY PARTY FOR ANY PURPOSE
NOT DIRECTLY RELATED TO
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PROGRAM.
NEEDS PROTECTION THE STATUE
OPERA PARK WILL BE ASSURANCE TO
COMMUNITIES THAT MAY BE
CONCERNED ARE HESITANT TO
ENROLL SIMILARLY PRIVATE
PROTECTIONS ARE NEEDED FOR
CONTACT TRACING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND TO ENSURE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF IMMIGRANTS
AND ALL COMMUNITIES WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION POTENTIALLY BEING
USED AGAINST THEM FOR THESE
REASONS WE ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT ONE FOUR.
THANK YOU. AND THEMBEKA KRAMER
MOTOR. HI BACK MATTER BEHALF OF
EIGHT. CAL ACT AND- AB EIGHT
FOURTEEN IS A CALL SENSE
APPROACH TO ENSURE. THE HI THIS
CONTRACTS THAT. THANK AND-
COLLECT AS PART OF CO CONTACT
TRACY EFFORTS. EXISTING DATA
PRIVATE LAWS DO NOT ADDED
PROTECT US FROM THE MEN WAYS.
THAT THE STATIC BE MIS USE. IF
OF PRIVACY PROTECTION PEPPER AS
HEALTH EFFORTS IF PEOPLE NOT
BELIEVE IN. IS CON CHASE WILL
BE CAPPED CONFIDENTIAL AND YOU
ONLY TO ADDRESS PAIN THAT.
THEY'RE LESS LIKELY TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO CALL YOU. ABOUT
WHERE THEY HAVE BEEN AND HIT A
AND I THAT. VENTURING
APPROPRIATELY CONTRACTION AB
EIGHT FOUR NOT A PROTECT HEALTH
PRIVACY BUT ALSO FOR OTHERS
HEALTH GOALS FOR THESE REASONS
SUPPORT. EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY.
THANK YOU. NOW AS OTHERS WHO
WANT TO. A FOR A EIGHT FOURTEEN
IS THERE SOMEONE IN THE WITH
ROOM. SEEING NONE WITH THE
REMOTE. STATE C. NONE NO ONE IN
THE HERE CHAMBERS WOULD YOU
OPEN LINE FOR THE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATES FOR A BI
EIGHT ONE WITH NAME FILL THE
AND ADDS FOR A EIGHT ONE FOUR.
THANK YOU FOR AREN'T UP OF A
EIGHT Y. FOR YOU PRESS AND THEN
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF
ONE TO THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SHOULD MORNING ORINDA
WAY WITH LESSONS AND- I'M
POVERTY SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
TO THE LINE OF LINE FIFTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS DANIEL CANDOR
CREDITOR ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION.
AND THE PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT TO THE LINE OF ONE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
PROPOSED YOU DON'T COME OUT OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NXR GO TO A LINE
OF THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THEY MIGHT. NINETY YES GO AHEAD
THIS IS LISA BENNETT WITH
INDIVISIBLE SAUSALITO
CONSTITUENTS IT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU NEXT TO A LINE
OF THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE THREE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN DO YOU HAVE A SOME MUTE.
BUT YEAH SORRY TAKE. CONDUCTOR
ROWS ON OF. IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER ALSO IN THE THANK. THANK
YOU AND WE HAVE NO THERE'S NO
THERE'S IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
RIGHT THANK YOU. WE WILL THEN
MOVE TO OPPOSITION I HAVE TO.
OPPOSITION WITNESSES LISTED ON
THE TELEPHONE JAMIE HOW FROM
THE CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA AND CHAU MUHAMMAD
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
ARE EITHER OF YOU WITH US. YES
I AM. OKAY GO AHEAD. A GOOD
MORNING MISTER TURNER NUMBERS
LINING HAAS AND I'M WITH THE
CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SH AND I THINK IT
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHT FOURTEEN A- WELL WE
pPROPER OF PERSONAL IN.
COLLECTED FOR THE PURPOSES OF
CONTACT TREATING AND FULLY
AGREE THAT SUCH AN SHOULD NOT
BE MISSED AS WRITTEN THE BILL
NOW KILLER INTENTIONALLY TO FOR
THE IN THAT YEAR SEVEN. AND MAY
ACTUALLY. THE. SIX WEEKS ON
BUSINESSES AND HOPING TO
ATTRACT HERE FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
REASONS AND WE'RE NOT
DISAGREEMENT THAT PERSONAL DATA
SHOULD BE HANDLED RESPONSIBLY
AND IN COMPLIANCE WITH CURRENT
LAW. I THINK THAT IS A MATTER
OF PUBLIC POLICY THIS BILL IS
OVERLY PRESCRIPTIVE IN ITS
APPROACH TO HOW DATA IS HANDLED
AND COLLECTED WHICH WILL LEAD
TO MORE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ADDITIONAL LAWSUIT DURING A
TIME WHEN OUR BUSINESSES AND
CONSUMERS CAN LEAST AFFORD
SHOULD COMPARE THE COST
INCREASED LITIGATION. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU. THE QUICKNESS PLEASE.
YOUR HONOR WILL CHAIR MEMBERS
MEANING SWAT MUHAMMAD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBEROF COMMERCE
AND WE ALSO RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS DRAFTED IN UNLESS
MANDATE- ARE- FIRST START
WORKING POINT IS RELATED TO THE
DEFINITIONS OF DRAFTING AB
EIGHT FOURTEEN STATE THE DATA
COLLECTED RECEIVE HER PREPARED
FOR CONTACT TRACING CANNOT BE
USED TO MAINTAIN OR DISCLOSE
FOR ANY OTHER PURPOSE- AS
DRAFTED THIS BILL WOULD
PROHIBIT THE USE OF DATA WAS
NOT SOLELY COLLECTED RECEIVE
HER PREPARED FOR THIS PURPOSE
FOR EXAMPLE- I'D SIGN IN OR LOG
IN SHEETS OR OR EVEN SECURITY.
SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE THAT'S NOT
TECHNICALLY COLLECTED PER
PURCHASE A CONTACT RATING BUT
CAN OTHERWISE BE EXTREMELY
USEFUL AND HELPFUL TO SUPPORT
THOSE EFFORTS- WHAT WOULD BE
AFFECTED BY THIS BILL- THIS
INFORMATION WOULD BE CONSIDERED
RECEIVED OR PREPARED FOR
PURPOSES OF CONTACT TRACING IT
WAS USEFUL FOR CONTACT TRACING
BUDGET WE USE INFORMATION-
THAT'S NOT. EXPLICITLY
COLLECTED FOR THE PURPOSE OF
CONTACT TRACING TO SUPPORT
CONTACT RAISING EFFORTS WAY
FOURTEEN WOULD END UP
PROHIBITING THE USE OF THOSE
INFORMATION FOR ANY OTHER
PURPOSE EVEN THE PURPOSE OF IT
WAS ORIGINALLY COLLECTED AND
THAT'S WHAT WE MEAN WHEN WE SAY
IT LIMITS THE USE OF THAT
INFORMATION ADDITIONALLY THE
FOURTEEN REQUIRED THAT. ALL THE
DATA COLLECTED RECEIVED IN THIS
CONTEXT MUST BE DELETED WITHIN
SIXTY DAYS SIXTY DAYS BUT IT
DOES NOT PROVIDE EXPLICIT
EXCEPTIONS FOR REQUIREMENTS-
UNDER EXISTING LAW INCLUDING
CAL OSHA GUIDANCE RELATED TO
CALL THE NINETEEN- IN ADDITION
TO THE POTENTIAL CONFLICTS WITH
THIS LAW WITH THESE EXISTING
LAWS- THE DATA DELETION
REQUIREMENT MATCHLESS TOWARD
OTHERWISE USEFUL INFORMATION
FROM BEING- YEARS FOR CONTACT
TRACING AND ENTRANCE BE GOING
FROM THAT ANOTHER. I ENDED TO
THESE ISSUES WE OF COURSE TAKE
ISSUE WITH THE INCLUSION OF
OUTSIDE CIVIL LIABILITY WHICH-
AS WAS MENTIONED BY MY
COLLEAGUE IS- IS- EXCESSIVE IN
AND TO THE POINT OF CONTACT-
WITH THAT WE APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING THE TIME AND- WE'RE
OPPOSE. MUST I THANK YOU. NOW
I'M GOING TO GO TO OTHER WHO
ARE ENOUGH. ANYONE IN THE-
WITNESS VIDEO ROOM. WHO REMOTE
TEST SITE. SEEING ANOTHER NO
ONE IN THE ROOM OPERATOR YOU
OKAY LINES THOSE WHO LIKE TO UP.
TO AB EIGHT ONE FOUR WILL TAKE
NAME AFFILIATION AND OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT ONE FOUR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
WE WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHARE
MEMBERS THIS IS DAN AND BIG ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL PAYROLL
REPORTING CONSORTIUM AND WE'RE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE FOR THE
REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF ONE NINETY SIX. I'M
SORRY THEY HUNG UP SO ONE OH
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI DON
HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF INTERNET
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY. THE
THANK YOU AN ACTUAL GO TO LINE
OF ONE FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING WE ANY
ATTACK AND- THAT. ARE ONLINE
CONVERSATION FOR THE AUTHOR BUT
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE NOT AMENDED
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME RIGHT THANK YOU. MAY
CLOSE ALLIANCE IN A BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE MR LEVINE
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHARLES FACT LAST
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA PLEASE
STONE AYE STONE AYE CHAU. CHIU
DAVIES DAVIES NO GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA. KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN REYES SMITH. NOW SO
THAT NEEDS FOR MORE VOTES WE'LL
PUT THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
HAVE A GREAT DAY THANK YOU YOU
TOO MR RODRIGUEZ MOVED TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB. THREE SIXTY
FOUR. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION IS THERE A SECOND. I
WILL SECOND DEATH. PLEASE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PERCENT
AB THREE SIXTY FOUR TODAY IT
WOULD ENSURE ALL OF
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND TEMPORARY VISA HOLDERS
WHO COME TO WORK IN CALIFORNIA
RECEIVE COMPREHENSIVE
PROTECTIONS AT THE POINT OF
RECRUITMENT. THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE CORRECT A DRAFTING ERROR
MADE IN SB FOUR SEVEN SEVEN BY
THEN PRO TERM STEINBERG IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN WHICH CREATED
THE FIRST FRAMEWORK OF A
COMPREHENSIVE PROTECTION FOR
TEMPORARY VISA HOLDERS. AMONG
ALL TYPES OF THE SAID THE H.
TWO A. PROGRAM PIECE OF PROGRAM
IS A TEMPORARY VISA CATEGORY
LINK TO THE LARGEST NUMBER OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING CASES IN THE
UNITED STATES. AB THREE SIXTY
FOUR WOULD ENSURE THAT
EMPLOYERS TO USE FOREIGN LABOR
CONTRACTORS. MUST ALSO COMPLY
WITH MANDATES THAT ARE TOTALLY
DIFFERENT FROM THE EXISTING
LAWS. REGULATING FARM LABOR
CONTRACTORS AND ONLY APPLY TO
THEM. IF THE RECRUIT WORKERS
FROM OUTSIDE THE UNITED STATES.
IMPARTIAL CONTRACT FOR THE OWN
H. TWO A. WORKERS WOULD NOT BE
SUBJECT TO THE REQUIREMENTS.
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM BOTH
FEDERALLY AND IN CALIFORNIA DO
NOT ADEQUATELY PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S LAW ABIDING
EMPLOYERS AND VULNERABLE
TEMPORARY MIGRANT WORKERS
ENTERING CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE
SERVICE OF FOREIGN LABOR
RECRUITERS. I WITH ME ON THE
LINE TODAY. ELAINE BENNETT BART
WITH THE SAN DIEGO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S SEX CRIMES AND HUMAN
TRUCK TRUCKING DIVISION ALSO
CALLING IT IS A VICTIM OF THE
LABOR PRACTICES THAT THIS BILL
WOULD ADDRESS. THANK YOU MISTER
RODRIGUEZ I DO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES BOTH ON THE TELEPHONE
MARYLAND BARRETT. AND ANGELO
COLLINSON. ARE YOU BOTH ON THE
LINE. MARY ELLEN BARRETT GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU CHAIRPERSON STONE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I THINK IT COULD BE A
MARYLAND THERE IT WOULD BE A
SUMMER STEP INTO A CO SPONSOR
OF THIS BILL. THIRD PARTY LABOR
RECRUITERS EXPLOIT VULNERABLE
MIGRANT WORKERS HOW FALSE
PROMISES ARE MADE FEES ARE PAID
THIS IS A CANE OF THE WORKER
COMES TO THE U. S. ONE HERE.
MORTY IS A REQUIRED MOVEMENT IS
RESTRICTED CONTRACTS AREN'T
GIVEN OR NOT HONORED WORK TERMS
ARE CHANGED. THE WORKERS ARE
FROM HOME PARK MISTER MIGLIOR
AND THE WORKER HAS NO IDEA HOW
TO NAVIGATE OUR SYSTEM FOR
HELP. WE AT THE NEXT LEADING
GROUPS OF WORKERS IN
RESTAURANTS AGRICULTURAL FIELDS
DOMESTIC AND CHILD CARE AND
ELDER CARE IN OTHER AREAS. AND
YET SUCCESSFUL LABOR
TRAFFICKING. CASES ARE FEW AND
FAR BETWEEN. IT CRIMES
DIFFICULT DISCOVER INTO. IF
WORKERS DO RECORD WE NEED THE
DISCOVERED THEY JUST WANT TO GO
HOME. NOT STATE PROSECUTION.
MOST TIMES THEY DON'T RECORD
THE ABUSES BECAUSE WELL IF YOUR
FAMILY DEPENDING ON THE MONEY
SENT HOME EVEN IF IT'S NOT
MUCH. EVEN IF YOU'RE A HORRIBLE
WORKING CONDITIONS YOU'LL KEEP
WORKING. WE'RE NOT GONNA PROFIT
OUR WAY OUT OF THIS PROBLEM.
AND WE KNOW THAT IN A POST CODE
WORLD WORKERS WILL BE EVEN MORE
VULNERABLE TO EXPLOITATION AND
FALSE PROMISES. YOU TO THE
SITUATION THEIR HOME COUNTRIES.
ADDRESSING ISSUES WITH
RECRUITMENT AND THE WORKERS
HOME COUNTRY REMOVED THOSE
VULNERABILITIES. IT STOPPED IT
BEFORE IT STARTS. STOP AT MY
HOME COUNTRY DON'T ALLOW ME FOR
SHOPPING ABSOLUTELY TREAT
ALBIZIA CATEGORIES THE SAME.
AND IF THERE IS A POLICE
INVESTIGATION. BEING ABLE TO
FIGURE OUT WHO THE BAD ACTORS
ARE THOSE THAT AREN'T
REGISTERED FOREIGN LABOR
CONTRACTORS. WILL STREAMLINE
INVESTIGATIONS AND HOPEFULLY
LEAD TO THE DISCOVERY. OF AN
ASSISTANT FOR MORE VICTIMS. IT
IS I'M- RECRUITERS. CREATE AN
UNEVEN PLAYING FIELDS IN A
LEGITIMATE BUSINESSES. WHO
CAN'T COMPETE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T EXPLOIT THE WORKERS. IT'S
EASY TO BE THE LOWEST BIDDER OR
HAVE THE LOWEST PRICES YOU ARE
PAYING FOR LABOR. THIS BILL IS
GOOD FOR BUSINESS GOOD FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND GOOD FOR
MIGRANT WORKERS WERE ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK GOODNESS
PLEASE. HI THIS IS ANGELA. UP
MANY THANKS OF ONE GIANT FAMILY
WERE TRAFFICKING SURVIVOR
REGIONALLY FROM THE
PHILIPPINES. I DON'T KNOW IF
ANY OF YOU HEARD ME SPEAK ON SB
FIVE SEVEN SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN. BUT I THOUGHT HE
WOULD HAVE GREENHOUSE IN THE
PROTECT MANY OUT OF WORKERS
THANK ME. I WAS DEVASTATED WHEN
I HEARD THAT TO BE WITH ON THE
CALL WITH EACH TO BE VISA.
WORKERS BECAUSE OF THE DRAFTING
AND- I CAN IT COME TO THE
UNITED STATES SENATE HSBC FACT
I CAME ON A P. ONE VISA. AND IT
BUT BECAUSE OF HOW CONFUSING
THAT MISSTEP PRACTICE MUST HAVE
ENDED UP TRAFFIC. COMING TO THE
UNITED STATES ENOUGH OF THESE
ARE WITH A PROMISE OF A GOOD
SHOT. AND MULTIPLE OTHER
COUNTRIES PHILIPPINES IT'S LIKE
WINNING THE LOTTERY. I CAME TO
CALIFORNIA WITH A CLIP THAT
HOLDS A LOT MORE THAN TEN OTHER.
OF B. ONE VISAS WHO BELIEVE HE
WOULD BE ABLE TO LEGALLY WORK
IN THE UNITED STATES. WHEN I
ARRIVED IN THE UNITED STATES MY
PASSPORT WAS TAKING AWAY FROM
ME AND I WAS TOLD ME TO BE HELD
FOR SAFEKEEPING. I WASN'T EVEN
IN CONTACT WITH THE PARENTS OF
MY CLIMATE BEFORE AND AFTER MY
HOME COUNTRY. I WAS TOLD THAT-
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM
THE TRANSPORTATION TO THE
UNITED STATES AND TO BE SPENT.
AND I WAS TOLD I WOULD HAVE
WORKED TEN YEARS AT A
RETIREMENT HOME FOR THE ELDERLY
TO COMMITTEE MESSED UP LIVES.
HELLO THANK. YOU THE FIFTY
AFTER STAFF. I WORK EIGHTEEN
HOUR A DAY. WE THEY ARE. TO
SLEEP ON THE- IN THE- AND EIGHT
PEOPLE'S CAR. MAKES ALL THE
STAFF NEXT. TO ME. THIS ARE
MADE WHAT ARE FOR OUR ID. AND
SINCE I DON'T HAVE ONE. BECAUSE
TAKE A BILL RATE FOR THAT YOU
JAIL. MY WHAT AND I. WERE ALSO
CRACKED AND THAT THE FUTURE TO
SKI. WE WOULD BE DEPORTED BACK.
THAT IN TELLING THEM THE STOCK
COMPANY. ISN'T ON TWO. I AM NOT
WORKING TIME THE NEED TO GO
BLANK. IN A MEMBER DIDN'T.
QUITE CHARACTER. BY THE NET. I
KNOW THE TECH OF USE THAT. TO
ME AND MAKE ME WORK RIGHT
HAPPENED EITHER BE. THAT WELL.
AS THE NIGHT EXPERIENCE AND
MAKES. IN THE- WITHIN MY
NETWORK. SB FORTY SEVEN. SHOULD
OVER MORE FEBRUARY FIFTH
CATEGORY. EITHER THAN H. TWO.
NOTHING FOR ANY REASON CREDIT
CARD SHOULD BE EXCLUDED FROM
THEIR- BECAUSE- WORKERS.
SPECIALLY NOW WITH. NINETY AND
THEN I THINK. MANY PEOPLE THAT
ONLY FROM BECAUSE- LIKE
DIFFERENT. CRUNCH WITH. ANY
CHANCE IF THEY CAN. I BELIEVE
IT IS TO. WHICH FOR. AND THEIR-
TO COME. AND HERE YOU KNOW
STATES. MULLIN SHOULD. THAT TO
WORK TWENTY BILLION. AND DAY.
AND BECAUSE- FOR FIFTEEN AND-
FOR THE SAFETY AND THEIR- I
THINK. THE AT LEAST THE STATE.
I HOPE YOU BOTH I SB THIRTY SIX
FOUR AB THREE SIX FOUR. THE
PROTECTIONS I THIRTY. FOR TEMP.
WORK THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SUPPORT
OF AB THREE SIXTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
WILL GO TO A LINE OF ONE NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS PERSONAL
ACCOUNTS ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES CITY MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NEXT TO GO TO
LINE A ONE OH ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SORRY TO A ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING- JERILYN
STAPLETON ON BEHALF OF THE
JEWISH LABOUR COMMITTEE IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. THREE
SIX. THANK YOU OF OUR LINE OF
TO ALL FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER TEARING MEMBERS JENNIFER
WROTE ON BEHALF OF PEPSICO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT TO THE
LINE OF FORTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE FORTY THREE DO
YOU HAVE A SOME YOU YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NEXT CAROLINA ONE
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING SHARON REPORT WITH
THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF ONE NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HANEGBI SAID FREEDOM
UNITED ON WHERE SUPPORT.
LEGISLATION EIGHTEENTH. SIX
FOUR. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE OF ONE NINETY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MONICA THE NURSE
CARE BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES TRANSPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF ONE
NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MICHELLE THOMAS
SHOCK REPRESENTING ALAMEDA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL EARN YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF TWO OH SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI BALCONY
RICHARD BUT THE COALITION TO
ABOLISH SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING
AM PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB THREE
SIX FOUR IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO FURTHER SUPPORT QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU WILL NOW
MOVES TO OPPOSITION I HAVE ONE
OPPOSITION WITNESSLISTED
MATTHEW ALLEN FROM WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION WITH US ON
THE TELEPHONE. MISTER ALAN ARE
YOU ADDRESS- YES I DIMINISH
SURE CAN YOU HEAR ME YES GO
AHEAD PLEASE. YEAH GOOD MORNING
MR CHEN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION AND- IT'S
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO AB
THREE SIXTY FOUR- THE H. TWO A.
VISA PROGRAM IS SIMPLY DOES NOT
INTENDED TO BE COVERED BY SB
FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN- BECAUSE OF
THE LACK OF NECESSITIES CELL-
THE STATE PROGRAMS ARE
REGULATED BY A RESTRICTIVE
APPLICATION AND ARE FORTUNATE
PROGRAM. AT BOTH THE FEDERAL
AND CALIFORNIA LEVEL- IS
SUBJECT TO A SPECIFIC FARM
LABOR CONTRACTOR- REGULATION
PROGRAM IS MANAGED BY THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S. OFFICE THAT
LICENSING PROGRAM- THAT IS-
MANAGE AND ENFORCE FOR THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER PARTY COVERS
THE FARM LABOR CONTRACTOR
PROGRAM AND IN FACT SERVED AS A
MODEL. FOR THE CREATION OF SB
FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN- THIS IS
ACTUALLY MENTIONED- DURING A
DEBATE AT THIS BEFORE SEVENTY
SEVEN AND IS REFERENCE AND
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS QUOTE. CURRENTLY
CALVARY LAW REQUIRES LICENSING
OF FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS ONLY-
DETEST CURTAILED HUMAN
TRAFFICKING RELATED ABUSES- ON
THE QUOTE- FURTHER- PER THE
UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR AND THEIR FACT SHEET ON
THE H. AWAY- PROGRAM QUALITY
EMPLOYERS MUST COMPLY WITH. ALL
APPLE LAWS AND REGULATIONS AND
THAT INCLUDES THE PROHIBITION
AGAINST HOLDING COURT
CONFISCATING. WORKERS PASSPORTS
OR OTHER IMMIGRATION DOCUMENTS-
INITIALLY EMPLOYERS MUST NOT
SEEK OR RECEIVE PAYMENT OF ANY
KIND FROM WORKERS FOR ANYTHING
RELATED TO OBTAIN H. TWO A.
CERTIFICATION. AND THAT
INCLUDES THE EMPLOYER'S
ATTORNEY OR AGENCIES THE
APPLICATION FEES OR OTHER
EQUIPMENT COSTS- IT IS FOR ALL
THESE REASONS- THAT WESTERN
GROWERS BELIEVES THAT THIS BILL
THAT BILL IS DUPLICATIVE OF
EXISTING LAW AND WE ARE OPPOSED
TO AB THREE SIXTY FOUR. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I WILL GO TO
WHO LIKE TO INDICATE OPPOSITE
TO AB THREE FOR NO IS HERE IN
THE ROOM. ANYONE IN THE WITNESS
THE ROOM. SEEING NONE OF THE
REMOTE. STATION RIGHT SEEING
NONE WOULD YOU- OPEN THE LINE
FOR THE WHO'D LIKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION TO AB. THREE SIXTY
FOUR. GIVE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THREE SIXTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS.
ONE NINE NINE ZERO. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE OF FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS BECCA
KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF A
CELLULAR- CALIFORNIA ACT OR
ACTUAL IN SUPPORT I JUST HAD IT
GLITCH DURING THE- MEET. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LEVEL OF
TWO OH TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SHE YOUR CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
BROWN CALLING ON THE NEGOTIABLE
ASSOCIATIONS CALIFORNIA. GOOD
FOR THE CALIFORNIA FRESH FOR
JUICES. ALL OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF TO A YEAR LINES-
OPEN. GOOD MORNING COMPANY. ON
BEHALF OF C. WINE TO K. IN UP
TO THANK YOU. THANK YOU NECK
WEEK ALL I OF TO ALL YOUR LINE
IS. ROBERT MCCREE CAL CHAMBER
OF. OPPOSED TO DUPLICATE IT AND
CAN. THANK THANK YOU MEXICO OF
TWO HUNDRED YEAR OLD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING- BRIAN
LITTLE CAL FOR BUREAU
FEDERATION IN OPPOSITION THE
REASONS BY MISS ALLEN WESTERN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME RIGHTTHANK YOU WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS ARE COMMON. MISTAKES
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I
HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU IN
REGARDS TO- THIS THIS BILL I
SEE THAT THERE COULD BE LITTLE
DUPLICATION OF- EXISTING LAWS.
AND WITH H. TWO WAY YOU'VE GOT
THE FEDERAL AND THE STATE
PROGRAM I GUESS MY QUESTION IS
WHY NOT TAKE IN THE
DEFICIENCIES YOU SEE AND THESE
LAWS AND NOT AND AMEND THEM TO
THE EXISTING LAWS. INSTEAD OF
CREATING ANOTHER LAW. WELL WITH
THAT SAID YOU KNOW. FOCUS ON
THE TO RESERVE PLAYERS THAT
THERE PARTY WE- THEY'RE THE
ONES THAT GO RECRUIT THESE WORK.
THIS IS THE AREA OF. THAT AB
THREE SIXTY FOUR SEATS TO
ADDRESS THAT WAS ORIGINAL
INTENTIONS OF THE AUTHOR BACK
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN STEINBERG.
IT JUST OVER THE AN ERROR THAT
THERE WAS INTERPRETED. NOT
INCLUDED BUT THAT WAS HIS
ORIGINAL INTENT AS WELL. SAID
THAT BUT THERE'S NO REASON WHY
WHAT WOULD BE THE REASON OF NOT
JUST TAKING WHAT WE HAVEN'T AND
MAKING AMENDMENTS TO IT ADDING
THAT INTO IT. WELL WE JUST FEEL
THAT THIS IS THE BETTER WAY TO
DO IT LEGISLATIVELY TO ADD. THE
H. TWO EIGHT R. FOR. BECAUSE
AGAIN A REGION INTENT OF BILL.
THANK YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMON RIGHT SEEING NONE WITH
REGARD TO MAKE CLOTHES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU DO HAVE A MOST AND A AND IS
PASS TO PRO CALDERON PLEASE
STONE I STONE AYE CHAU CHIU
DAVIES DAVIES NO SALAS AND I
HOLD KALRA KILEY MAY. REYES
SMITH. SMITH NOW. SO THE BILL
BE A COLLIE NEEDS FOR MORE VOTE
THANK YOU SOON AS GET PANEL
BACK WITH HIM TO TAKE A UP ALL
RIGHT MS RUBIO. I WERE ITEM
SAID AB A. THIRTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF. TO
PRESENT TODAY ON THE SAME BILL
AND THIRTY AND THAT'S RELATING
TO ENFORCEMENT OF AND I CAB
BUSINESS. I WOULD LIKE BEGIN BY
ALL F THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
AND THE AMOUNT. AND BY THINKING
CAN STAFF FOR ALL OF THEIR AND
THE LINE. ACCORDING TO RECENT
REPORTS ILLEGAL CANNABIS
SELLERS AND CAL I WOULD NUMBER
LEGAL REGULATED BUSINESSES BY
NEARLY THREE TO ONE. THIS
REPORT FOUND THAT WHILE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS GROWERS
COLLECTIVELY PRODUCE ABOUT NINE
MILLION POUNDS OF CANNABIS PER
YEAR. THE DEMAND IN THE LEGAL
CANNABIS MARKET CAN ONLY
SUPPORT AROUND TWO MILLION
POUNDS PER YEAR. THIS LEAVES
ABOUT 80% OF THE CROP EITHER TO
BE DESTROYED OR TO MAKE IT MAKE
ITS WAY INTO THE ILLICIT
MARKET. ESTIMATES PUT THE VALUE
OF THE LOCAL CANNABIS MARKET AT
AROUND EIGHT POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR. ALL
OF THIS ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IS
BOTH UNTAXED AND UNREGULATED.
IN ADDITION TO DWINDLING TAX
REVENUES THE UNDERGROUND MARKET
PRESENTS SERIOUS PUBLIC SAFETY
AND PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS TO
OUR COMMUNITIES. NEWS ARTICLES
FROM AROUND THE STATE HAVE
DOCUMENTED VIOLENCE. AND CRIME
AT THESE UNLICENSED
DISPENSARIES. IN ADDITION THE
CANNABIS PRODUCTS SOLD AT THESE
LOCATIONS DOES NOT MEET
ESTABLISHED QUALITY STANDARDS
AND EVADE STATE TESTING. AB
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT WOULD
TARGET THE ILLICIT MARKET BY
CREATING CIVIL PENALTIES. FOR
INDIVIDUALS FOUND TO BE AIDING
AND ABETTING THE SALE OF
UNLICENSED CANNABIS. THE
LANGUAGE. IN THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS FURTHER DEFINES
AIDING AND ABETTING SO THAT THE
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL CLEARLY
DO NOT APPLY TO EMPLOYEES. AT
ANY LEGAL SHOP. THE AMENDMENTS
ALSO PREVENT THE FINES IN THE
BILL FROM BEING USED AS
LEVERAGE IN CRIMINAL CASES. THE
AMENDMENTS ALSO PREVENT I'M
SORRY THE BILL HAS ENJOYED THE
SUPPORT OF LABOR. A LEGITIMATE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY
AND I WILL NOW- TURN OVER THE
MIKE TO OUR SPONSORS AND
SUPPORTERS ARE TWO SPONSORS
HERE TODAY OR OVER THE PHONE.
OUR OTHER THOUGHT TO RECALL ON
BEHALF OF THE UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS. AND MARVIN
CAñADA WHO WILL TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF THE UNITED CANNABIS
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU
AND I DO HAVE THOSE TWO
WITNESSES LISTED BOTH WITH US
BY TELEPHONE NUMBER TWO THREE
ECHO. AND MARVIN PENNE ARE YOU
ON THE LINE. YOU CAN- THE IS
NOT MARVIN BANANA. HI MAY-
SENATE SEAT THANK YOU. I BUT WE
ON BEHALF OF THE HAS BEEN A FEW
CHEN A COUPLE OF THE- WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. OPPOSITION
SIXTY FOUR WAS APPROVED THE
BORDER. BUT ON THE HELLO FOR.
TO BE IMPOSED ON THE AND ABOUT
TRADERS. PROPOSITION FOUR THEN
PENALTIES ONE NIGHT ABOUT
THREE. STATE AID AND LOCAL GUY.
OUT WERE OPERATE. TO LIKE CAN I
WAS. TO OR NOT PROVIDED TO
COMBAT ILLEGAL CANNABIS I CAME.
INTO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE LEAD
APPROVED A BILL. TO GAVE
HEATING. THAT WE DO AND THE I
IN A- ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT.
HOWEVER AGING DO NOT HAVE THAT.
AND WE SORT BECAUSE ILLEGAL UP
FOR. I THIS TO ME IT UP EIGHTY
PER. RAIDERS WE'RE RESPONSIBLE
FOR SEVEN TESTING. PRODUCT WITH
CHEMICALS AND METAL METAL OF
THE CAR. THAT TO TELL NINE THEY
CRIED. THEY CAN TO A- HERE-
AREA THAT WHEN THEY'RE NOT
SUPPOSED TO. REGARDLESS WHETHER
THEY CALL TO PAR OF COURSE. WE
HAVE- ALL OF IN THE NEWS PROP
THREE THAT AT. THAT THE
OPERATION. THE PENALTY ON THE
BILL WHAT ARE AGAINST IT ACT I
THE ORGANIZER OF THE PACIFIC. I
DID IS ORGANIZED CRIME- AND AS
YOU'LL BE AND- IT IS THE
MAGICAL I. AFTER EMPLOYEE IN.
THE OPERATION MAY NOT KNOW ALL
I DID THAT T. V. E. DALLE
PRAISED V. D. I'M- SURE THERE
ARE PROTECTING ARE IN PLACE- WE-
HAD KIND OF THE- NEED. I ON
ENFORCEMENT AS A KIND. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN- GOOD MORNING I
WANT TO ALSO ACKNOWLEDGES STAFF
UNDER. THEIR DILIGENCE IN THE
REPORTS AND CRAFTING AMENDMENT
OF COURSE ON OUR KNOWLEDGE SOME
RUBIO FOR HER STEADFAST.
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA THIS IS
THE THIRD YEAR THAT WE'VE DONE
THIS BILL AND I REPRESENT
UNITED PUT A COMMERCIAL WORKERS
OPERATIVE TRICO- FOR THE
RECORD- WE ARE COSPONSORED
LEGISLATION. YOUR C. W.
REPRESENTS HONOR SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND WORKERS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND SEVERAL
THOUSAND IN THE CANNABIS SPACE.
WE'VE BEEN INVOLVED WITH THE
WITH CANNABIS FROM THE OUTSET
IN CALIFORNIA TO LEGALIZE
CANNABIS MARKET. BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT IT COULD. INDUSTRY
CAN CREATE MIDDLE CLASS JOBS
THAT CAN BE RACIST AND LIVING
IN SEVERELY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES- THOSE OBJECTIVES
ARE ARE UNDERMINE SEVERELY BY
THE LIST OF MARKET PLACE'S BEEN
DESCRIBED BY BOTH THE SEVEN
MEMBER RUBIO AND- SPRINGER. WE
THINK THIS BILL IS A IS A GREAT
FIRST STEP IN ENHANCING
ENFORCEMENT AND REALLY
CURTAILING MELISSA MARKETPLACE
WITHOUT WITHOUT LEGISLATION
LIKE THIS. WOULD BE COULD YOU
BE UNDERCUTTING THE WAGES AND
BENEFITS OF THE WORKERS INITIAL
BE UNDERCUT WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE A PERMANENT UNDERCLASS
THIS BILL GOES A LONG WAY THERE
ARE PRETENDING THOSE EFFORTS
AND TO- MAKING SURE THAT THE
LEGAL OPERATORS ARE EQUAL
FOOTING. FOR THESE REASONS WE.
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL THANK
YOU. THEY YOU ON THE MOVES TO
OTHERS WHO WERE LIKE HIM TO
SUPPORT FOR A BI ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT ANYONE IN WITNESS ROOM.
SEEING NONE THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE
NO ONE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONES.
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR THOSE WHO ONE
INDICATES AWKWARD FOR AB ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AND ONE MOMENT
WE HAVE ONE Q. ENOUGH. AND AS A
REMINDER WE ARE ON SUPPORT OF
AB ONE AT. THREE ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE- BUT TO TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING- SHERIFF
AMBER'S CHASIN PRIDE ON BEHALF
OF THE CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE L. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO OTHER SUPPORT
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION
I HAVE ONE OPPOSITION WITNESS
LISTED. GENET SENATE PATTON
FROM THE DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
WHO'S WITH US ON THE TELEPHONE
ARE YOU WITH US. THANK YOU-
GOOD MORNING KAREN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS GENET TWENTY THIRTEEN
AND I AM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
DIRECTOR FOR DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE DPA IS THE LEADING
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION.
ADVOCATING FOR DEBT POLICIES
GROUNDED IN SCIENCE- COMPASSION
HELP IN HUMAN RIGHT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE IN OPPOSE
POSITION ON AB ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT. WHICH WOULD AMEND THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
TO EXPAND IMPORTANT RELATING TO
ADULT USE AND MEDICINAL
CANNABIS LICENSING. FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS EPA HAS BEEN
AT THE FOREFRONT OF MARIJUANA
LAW REFORM ICE BEFORE PARTNERS.
HELP DRAFTING BLANK OPPOSITION
TO FIFTEEN IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX AND. PROP SIXTY FOUR IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN. WHAT MARIJUANA
THAT WERE. MARIJUANA AND THAT
NO LONGER ARREST INCARCERATE
DISENFRANCHISE AND OTHERWISE
HARM MILLION. RETICULAR ONLY
PEOPLE OF COLOR COLLECTED
PROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY THE
WAR ON DRUGS. WE APPRECIATE THE
INTENT OF EIGHTY ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT TO PROMOTE COMPLIANCE
WITH LICENSING REQUIREMENTS WE
ARE COMMITTED TO CONTINUED
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROP SIXTY
FOUR IN A MANNER THAT CREATE A
ROBUST EQUITABLE MARKET WHICH
ENSURED THE AVAILABILITY OF THE
FIRM REGULATED CANNABIS
PRODUCTS FOR CONSUMERS.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUAL
HISTORICALLY OPPRESSED BY
CANNABIS CRIMINALIZATION AND
PROTECT THE REGULATED MARKET BY
THE CONFLATING UNLICENSED
DISTRIBUTION I'M I DO WANT TO
ADD TO SUPPOSE THAT THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS ARE AN
IMPROVEMENT HOWEVER IS THE
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLAR DAY FINE
EXPECTED AND THE FACT THAT THE
FINE COULD BE IN PART BY- A
PROSECUTING AGENCY IS. STILL
PROBLEMATIC- THAT SAID HE WILL
THE PA WILL COMMIT TO REVIEW
THE AMENDMENTS THEY AREN'T
PLANT AND CONSIDER OUR POSITION
THE POWER YOU LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
WILL AND OTHER INTERESTED
INTERESTED. TO IMPROVE THE LIFE
HE THINKS IT'S AN IN THE. STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. RIGHT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OTHERS. WHO WOULD TO INDICATE
OPPOSITE I SEE THERE'S NO ONE
IN THE HEARING. ANYONE IN THE
VIDEO ROOM C. NINE ANYONE OF
THE TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING
NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN
THE LINES FOR THOSE WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO AB
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT. YOU'RE NOT
THE VISION OF AB ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF FORTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SECOND KRAMMER MATTER
ON BEHALF THE ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
THEN BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MISTER SMITH. THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION IS
THEIR SECOND SECOND. HAND A
SECOND GO AHEAD MR COUPLE
COMMENTS THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD THE ONES THAT TAKE
FOR BRING IT FORTH AS WE SPOKE
YESTERDAY IN REGARDS TO SOME
ISSUES OF MY DISTRICT. OF HOPE
WE CAN GET THIS ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE. AS IT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER SO WE CAN
EXPAND IT ALL THE WAY BACK TO
THE GROSS AND MY DISTRICT IT IS
A HUGE PROBLEM. IS MY SHARE OF
CALLS IT A LACK MOLD WE KNOCKED
OUT ONE THREE MORE POP UP
THEY'RE STEALING WATER ILLEGAL
GRADING AND ILLEGAL GROWS ON
SOMEBODY ELSE'S PROPERTY THEY
JUST TAKEN OVER I LOOK FORWARD
OF GOODNESS TO THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND. PLEASE CONSIDER ME AS
A CO AUTHOR THANK YOU. OTHER
QUESTIONS. RIGHT SEE NONE THIS
RUBIO ME CLOSE THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALDERON PLEASE
STONE HI STONE I CHAO. TO
DAVIES DAVIES I'D GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
KALRA KALRA KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
REYES REYES AYE SMITH SMITH I.
THE BILL IS OUT RIGHT THANK YOU
WE NOW MOVE TO OUR ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT
MISTER TECH. OKAY THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FIRST I
MEAN JUST- SAY THAT I'M HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR HELP ON. THIS
ALSO APPRECIATE YOUR HELP IN
MAKING THE AMENDMENTS FOR THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
YOU IN PARTICULAR- WE HAVE A
BEFORE SEVENTY EIGHT. HELLO WE
ARE TRYING TO INSURE THAT WE
CREATING A MARKET FOR THERAPY
FORMS AND- ENCOURAGING GREATER
PLASTICS RECYCLING RIGHT NOW
MANY OF THOSE CONTAINERS ARE.
UNFORTUNATELY NOT SENT TO
RECYCLING- NOT RECYCLE PLANTS
BUT ACTUALLY. A PUT INTO
LANDFILL SO IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
A CONSISTENT SUPPLY OF TERRIBLE
FROM REFORMS. TO RECYCLE AND
MEET THE GOALS SET IN THIS BILL
WE WILL BE AMENDED IN LANGUAGE
TO CHANGE HOW THE STATE PAYS.
MATERIAL RECOVERY FACILITIES
WILL BE DOING THIS IN A WAY SO.
THE MATERIAL RECOVERY
FACILITIES WILL BE SHIFTING
AWAY FROM RECEIVING A CO
MINGLED RATE FOUR BALES. OF THE
REFORM CONTAINERS MIXED IN WITH
PLASTIC BOTTLES. INSTEAD M. R.
S. WILL BE INCENTIVIZED TO SORT
AND SEPARATE FROM REFORM
CONTAINERS AND PLASTIC BOTTLES
INTO SEPARATE BILLS- WE HAVE.
TWO WITNESSES WHO I THINK AND
CAN SPEAK VERY QUICKLY ON THE
BILL BUT REALLY APPRECIATE.
YOUR ASSISTANCE WITH THE BILL
AND- HELPING US GET THIS
THROUGH YOUR CAN. PUSH IT THANK
YOU MISTER TAKE I DO HAVE. A TO
AN ASSIST LISTED ROBERT DAVID
ASK OF OUR PLANET. ON THE
TELEPHONE AND SCOTT WILKERSON
FROM BUNDLE FRESH AMERICA'S.
BOTH ON THE TELEPHONE ARE YOU
WITH US- YES I THIS IS BOB.
GROVE OKAY THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CHAIR STONE IN NUMBERS-
I'M BOB DEBIT IF THE CO FOUNDER
AND CEO OF THE COMPANY ARE
POINT EITHER. AND WE ARE PROUD
TO BE THE SPONSOR OF AB FOUR
SEVEN EIGHT. FOUR POINT OF
EARTH IS THE WORLD'S FIRST
MANUFACTURER OF RECYCLED P. E.
T. ALSO NOWN AS PARK AT.
PACKAGING OTHER PRODUCTS
THEY'RE DERIVED FROM POST
CONSUMER BALE PACKAGING- SPOKE
BOTTLES AND THERMAL FORMS. BUT
WE'RE RECYCLING UP WAKE FORM
AND CONVERTING THE NEW BEVERAGE
AND FOOD CONTAINERS ARE
COMPLETELY PERFECTLY INTEGRATED
FACILITY. LOCATED IN BURNING
CALIFORNIA. SINCE THE ENTIRE
MANUFACTURING PROCESS OCCURS
UNDER SINGLE WHOOPS. THE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH OUR PRODUCTS
ARE AMONG THE LOWEST IN THE
WORLD. CURRENTLY THE BEST
ESTIMATES THERE ABOUT ONE
THIRTY THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION POUNDS OF POST CONSUMER
FILIFORM CONTAINERS ARE
DISCARDED IN CALIFORNIA EVERY
YEAR. MOST OF WHICH ENDS UP IN
A LANDFILL- WE DO SUPPORT THE
REVISED LANGUAGE WITH REGARD TO
THE CART RIGHT ACT APPLICATION
OF AB FOUR SEVEN EIGHT. THE
ANTITRUST PROVISIONS SIMILAR TO
OTHER RECYCLING PROGRAMS SUCH
AS THOSE FOR BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS BATTERY SPRING.
MATTRESSES AND CARPET. AS
WRITTEN AB FOUR SEVEN EIGHT
PROVIDES A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
WE HAVE SEEN POSITIONS TAKEN BY
SOME THAT WE BELIEVE ARE AT
ODDS WITH THE INTENT OF AB FOUR
SEVEN EIGHT. APPLE PROPOSAL TO
HAVE DIFFERENT MINIMUM RECYCLED
CONTENT REQUIREMENTS. BY READ
THE TYPE. OF BIKE PLASTIC KITE
MAY CREATE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. FOR EXAMPLE.
DOING SO MAY ENCOURAGE BRANDS
AND RETAILERS TO SWITCH TO
RETIN TYPES WITH A BALL WITH
MINIMUM. YOUR CYCLE CONTACT THE
CHOIR MATES. I THE IN OF A
BEFORE SEVEN EIGHT. THE AMOUNT
OF THE REFORMS AND THE LANDFILL
AND MORNING THE GOALS OF THE
LEGISLATION. WE'VE ALSO HEARD
CONCERNS ABOUT THE AVAILABILITY
OF CERTAIN RESIN TYPES THAT ARE
COMPLIANT WITH THE FDA'S
REQUIREMENTS FOR DIRECT FOOD
GRADE APPLICATIONS. IN ORDER TO
USE RECYCLED MATERIALS. MORE
DIRECTLY CONTACT APPLICATION
THEY MUST BE STATE. WHICH IS
TYPICALLY DETERMINED BY
OBTAINING A LETTER OF NON
OBJECTION. ALSO KNOWN AS THE L.
AND HELD FROM THE USFDA. THAT
IS BASED ON A REVIEW OF THE
RECYCLING PROCESS AND THE
QUALITY OF THE RESULTING
MATERIALS. THIS IS ONE REASON
THE ANTI TRUST PROVISIONS IS
IMPORTANT SO THAT MANUFACTURERS
CAN FACILITATE PURCHASING. OF
RECYCLED THERMAL FORM- MATERIAL
ENFORCER COLLECTION IN ORDER TO
MEET THE RECYCLE CONTENT
TARGETS IN ADDITION THE
PACKAGING MANUFACTURERS WILL BE
ABLE TO WORK TOGETHER TO SET
BAIL QUALITY STANDARDS NEEDED
TO MEET SPECIFICATIONS COOK
FOOD GRADE FORMAL FORM
CONTAINERS. IN ADDITION AB FOUR
SEVEN EIGHT WILL INCREASE THE
DEMAND FOR FOOD STATE POST
CONSUMER PLASTIC RESINS SUCH AS
P. ET QUALITY PROGRAM AND
POLYSTYRENE. BILL BY
ENCOURAGING RECYCLERS THAT DO
NOT HAVE THE FTA L. L. THAT THE
NATION TO OBTAIN IT BECAUSE
CUSTOMER DEMAND WILL EXIST TO
JUSTIFY THE COLLECTION AND
RECYCLING OF THESE WEAPON.
TYPES TO APPROVE GREAT QUALITY.
FURTHERMORE WE BELIEVE IMPROVE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND AVAILABILITY
APPROVED OF POST CONSUMER
RESIDENTS WILL COME ABOUT MAYBE
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT TO THE HIGHER
RATE COLLECTION. RECYCLING AND
DEMAND FOR THESE MATERIALS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY BEING LANDFILLS.
I ASK YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THIS MORNING. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. WITH WILSON
GOOD MORNING CHAIR STONE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SCOTT WILKERSON AND I'M THE
CHIEF PROCUREMENT OFFICER AT
BONDUELLE FRESH AMERICAS BASED
IN IRWINDALE AND SALINAS
CALIFORNIA YOU PROBABLY KNOW IT
AS READY PAC FOODS WE ARE ONE
OF THE LARGEST US COMPANIES FOR
PRE PREPARED SALADS AND FRESH
PRODUCE PRODUCTS. CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO SET THE PACE FOR
THE REST OF THE NATION AS THE
COUNTRY'S LARGEST AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCER AND EXPORTER.
THERMOFORM PACKAGING SUCH AS
CLAM SHELLS HAS TRULY
REVOLUTIONIZED OUR ABILITY IN
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL FARMERS TO
TRANSPORT FRESH PRODUCE TO
CONSUMERS NATIONWIDE. THIS
PACKAGING ALSO HELPS TO PROTECT
PROTECT THE PRODUCE FROM
DAMAGING CONTAMINATION AND IT
REDUCES FOOD WASTE. PRODUCTS
AND PACKAGING MADE WITH POST
CONSUMER RECYCLED CONTENT ARE
INCREASINGLY A GLOBAL PRIORITY
FOR THE WORLD'S LARGEST
CONSUMER BRANDS AND RETAILERS
OUR COMPANY'S OBJECTIVE IS BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THEY HAVE A
100% OF OUR PACKAGING DESIGNED
TO BE RECYCLABLE OR REUSABLE.
OUR COMPANY HAS ALSO MADE FIRM
COMMITMENTS TO THE USE OF
RECYCLED P. E. T. THERMAL FOR.
PREVIOUSLY MOST OF THE RECYCLED
MATERIAL IS FROM PLASTIC
BOTTLES WHICH IS INCREASINGLY
IN HIGH DEMAND AND ESPECIALLY
WITH THE PASSAGE OF EIGHTY
SEVEN NINETY THREE WHICH SETS
MINIMUM CONTENT ON PLASTIC
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS. WE ARE IN
FULL SUPPORT AND EIGHTY FOUR
SEVEN EIGHT BECAUSE THAT WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT THE PACKAGING
WE USE MEETS OUR SUSTAINABILITY
GOALS THROUGH THE RECYCLED
CONTENT MANDATE. THE BILL IS
ALSO CRITICAL TO CREATE A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD WE HAVE MADE
INVESTMENTS INTO RECYCLABLE
PRODUCT THAT ALSO HAS RECYCLED
CONTENT AND THIS BILL WILL
PROPEL THE WHOLE SUPPLY CHAIN.
FOR MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY
RESPONSIBLE PACKAGING. THERE
ARE SOME MANUFACTURERS THAT DO
OPPOSE THE BILL BECAUSE OF THE
RECYCLED CONTENT MANDATE
HOWEVER MANY BRAND OWNERS HAVE
SIGNED THE U. S. PLASTICS PACT
WHICH IS MADE COMMITMENTS THAT
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THE
AVERAGE RECYCLED CONTENT OR
RESPONSIBLY SOURCED BIOBASED
CONTENT IN PLASTIC PACKAGING
WILL BE 30% IS THE DIRECTION
THAT OUR COUNTRY IS MOVING. WE
CAN ENSURE IT'S MAKING THIS
MOVE BACK FROM CALIFORNIA. AB
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT WILL ENABLE
THE THERMAL FARM INDUSTRY TO
COORDINAE ON INVESTMENT. TO
INCREASE COLLECTION AND
RECYCLING CAPACITY TO MEET THE
RECYCLED CONTENT MANDATE IT'S
FOR THESE REASONS I STRONGLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AN EIGHTY
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO OTHERS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR A BI FOR SEVENTY EIGHT. I
SEE NO ONE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
WHEN HIS VIDEO ROOM. NO ONE
THERE ANYONE AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SAY NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR THOSE WHO'D
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A
BI FOR SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEA IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR
FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM MINE
TWO. OH EIGHT. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS GET OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL AND
NATIONAL DEALERSHIP ACTION
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING THIS NECROPOLIS OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE AND
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN Q. THANK YOU YOU.
MAY CLOSE THOSE LINES ALL RIGHT
LET'S SEE WE DO HAVE SOME
OPPOSITION BUT NO ONE SAID IN
HOUSE AS YOU WITNESS.
INFORMATION SO WHAT WILL GO TO
THERE'S NO ONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM ANYONE IN THE- WITNESS
VIDEO ROOM. SEEING NONE HOW
ABOUT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. SEEING NONE SO
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO POSE AB. FOR SEVENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE GATHER THE LINE NUMBER.
NINE TO EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS- COMMITTEE JOE
ACTOR ON BEHALF OF THE PLASTICS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION- WE
RESPECTFULLY THE PROPOSAL MUST
AMENDED MR TANG'S BILL- WE HAVE
THE- MET WITH MISTER KING STEP
IN- FEEL LIKE WE'RE MAKING
PROGRESS- OUR MAIN CONCERN IS
THAT WE DO NOT BELIEVE THERE IS
ENOUGH TO RECYCLE CONTENT TO
MEET THE MANDATES OF THE BILL
RIGHT NOW. AND GET IMMEDIATELY
GOING FORWARD WE DO BELIEVE
ALSO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO-
MAKE EQUAL EMPHASIS ON
COLLECTIONS SORTATION AND
SORTATION AT. STATIONS TO GET
THIS MATERIAL AND WE'RE VERY
PLEASED TO HEAR SOMEONE THINK
SPEAK TO THAT AND WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING HIS
AMENDMENTS BUT WE ARE VERY
OPTIMISTIC WE CAN WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR HIS STAFF WE SUPPORT THE
GET THERE WITH HIM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE TWO TWENTY ONE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD CHAIR NUMBERS I APOLOGIZE
I TRIED TO GET IN UNDER THE
SUPPORT POWER TREAT ON BEHALF
OF THE ALLIANCE OF OUR PLANET
EARTH GREEN IMPACT THE SIX
EIGHT BOND WELL ALREADY PACKED
WORKING WITH VARYING VEGETABLE
FARMERS IN HOLD THE PORT. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN Q. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU ARE PRETTY YOU MAY
CLOSE THE LINES AND BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. RIGHT CNN
MISTER TEN YOU MAY CLOSE- AGAIN
THANKS SO MUCH FOR THE
COMMITTEE'S. WORK ON THE
AMENDMENTS- WE REALLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE CREATING A
CIRCULAR. ECONOMY WE APPRECIATE
THE INDUSTRY'S CONCERNS WE
THINK THERE'S PLENTY OF PRODUCT
OUT THERE AS LONG AS WE CAN.
SORT OF PROPERLY AND GET IT TO
THE PROPER RECYCLING PLANTS
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
FOR A BEFORE SEVENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER TAKE WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE HI STONE AYE CHAU.
CHIU DAVIES. DAVIES NO GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
KALRA KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES
HI RES I. SMITH. BILLS ARE
CALLING NEEDS TO MORE THANK YOU
RIGHT THANK YOU. MS WORKS ITEM
NUMBER NINE A. B. ELEVEN
NINETEEN. THANK YOU IS THERE A
SECOND. SECOND THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
GREAT I'LL TRY TO MAKE IT QUICK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FIRST I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS CLARIFYING
THAT A REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION
FOR AN EMPLOYEE WITH FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES. ONLY APPLIES
WHEN THERE IS AN OBLIGATION
ARISING FROM AN UNFORESEEN NEED
TO CARE FOR MINOR CHILD OR CARE
RECIPIENT. WHO SCHOOL OR PLACE
OF CARE IS CLOSED UNEXPECTEDLY.
AB ELEVEN NINETEEN WOULD
PROHIBIT DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
EMPLOYEES BASED ON THEIR FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES. AS STATED
PREVIOUSLY THIS BILL REQUIRES
AN EMPLOYER TO PROVIDE
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATIONS FOR
KNOWN FAMILY RESPONSIBILITIES
FOR UNEXPECTED SCHOOL OR CHILD
CARE CLOSURES. THE AMERICAN
FAMILY RESPONSIBILITY
DISCRIMINATION OCCURS WHEN AN
EMPLOYER TAKES A NEGATIVE
EMPLOYMENT ACTION AGAINST AN
EMPLOYEE. TO CARE FOR A FAMILY
MEMBER. THIS INCLUDES MOTHERS
OR FATHERS OF YOUNG CHILDREN
PREGNANT OR BREAST FEEDING
PEOPLE. AND EMPLOYEES WITH
AGING PARENTS WERE SIX BOSSES
ARE PARTNERS THAT MAY ENCOUNTER
FAMILY RESPONSIBILITY
DISCRIMINATION. UNDER THE US
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR ROUGHLY 60%
CHILDREN UNDER AGE EIGHTEEN
HAVE BOTH PARENTS WORKING. MORE
THAN ONE IN SIX AMERICANS WORK
FULL TIME OR PART TIME A REPORT
ASSISTING THE CARE OF AN
ELDERLY OR DISABLED FAMILY
MEMBER RELATIVE. OR FRIEND AND
OVER ONE AND TWELVE- EMPLOYED
ADULTS ARE CARING FOR BOTH
CHILDREN AND AN ELDERLY OR
DISABLED INDIVIDUAL. MOST
EMPLOYEES WILL HAVE CARE
RESPONSIBILITIES AT SOME POINT
IN THEIR PROFESSIONAL LIVES
EMPLOYMENT ACTIONS LIKE
TERMINATION REFUSAL TO HIRE
DEMOTION OR BEING LOOKED OER
FOR PROMOTIONS. MAYBE BASED ON
BIASES ABOUT HOW WORKERS WITH
FAMILY CARE RESPONSIBILITIES
WILL OR SHOULD ACT WITHOUT
REGARD TO THEIR THE WORKERS
ACTUAL PERFORMANCE. THIS TYPE
OF DISCRIMINATION AFFECTS
EMPLOYEES OF EVERY INCOME LEVEL
RACE GENDER IN INDUSTRY.
WORKING MOTHERS LOW WAGE
WORKERS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED. A
STUDY FROM THE AMERICAN JOURNAL
SOCIOLOGY FOUND THAT MOTHERS
WERE 79% LESS LIKELY TO BE
RECOMMENDED FOR HIRE. HALF AS
LIKELY TO BE PROMOTED AND
OFFERED IT AT AN AVERAGE OF
ELEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS LESS
FOR THE SAME POSITION AS NON
MOTHERS. MOST ALARMINGLY 80% OF
NEARLY ONE POINT ONE MILLION
WORKERS WHO DROPPED OUT OF THE
LABOR FORCE LESS AND LESS
SEPTEMBER WERE WOMEN.
ADDITIONALLY ALMOST TWO HUNDRED
STATES AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
INCLUDING ALASKA DELAWARE
MINNESOTA NEW YORK. HAVE
PROHIBITED FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITY DISCRIMINATION
WITH LITTLE REPORTS OF ABUSE.
EMPLOYEES ARE STRUGGLING TO
BALANCE THEIR JOBS AND CARING
FOR THEIR FAMILIES DISPARATE
TREATMENT BECAUSE OF THEIR
FAMILY RESPONSIBILITY SHOULD
NOT BE A REASON FOR
TERMINATION. OR OTHER ADVERSE
EMPLOYMENT ACTIONS. WITH ME
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AS
LIZ MORRIS FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF HASTING CENTER FOR WORKLIFE
LAW AND- JULIAN BURNS KINGS
REPRESENTING- PRESENTING ON
BEHALF OF OUR WITNESS ON THE
FERRIES. THANK YOU I HAVE BOTH
WITNESSES THIS MORRIS AND
JULIAN BURNS KING LISTED AS
BEING WITH US ON THE TELEPHONE
ARE YOU. ARE YOU WITH US. WHAT
ARE WE WILL TAKE HIS MORE
CERTAIN MORNING JULIET. OKAY GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THE MORNING THE
HEIGHT OF THE COLD WAR I'M BAD
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER
FOR WORKLIFE LAW. THANK YOU
MANY WORKERS WITH FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES HAVE BEEN IN
CRISIS OVER THE LAST YEAR WHEN
THE SCHOOLS AND PROFESSIONAL
CARE PROVIDERS BUT THEY RELY ON
TO GET THE WORK HAS BEEN
TEMPORARILY UNAVAILABLE BECAUSE
THE COMPANY. MOTHERS IN
PARTICULAR HAV BEEN
DEVASTATED. OFTENTIMES ARE
ECONOMIC SECURITY AND OUR
MENTAL HEALTH BUT THE HARSHEST
IMPACT ON WOMEN OF COLOR SINGLE
MOTHERS AND WORKERS IN LOW
PAYING JOBS. NOT ONLY HAVE THEY
THOUGHT THAT THEIR CHILDREN DR
JIM. ANYWAY HOW MUCH SNOW BONTA
LEARNING FOOD INSECURITY AND
OTHER LIKE PROPERTY. DURING THE
PANDEMIC WORKING PEOPLE WHO ARE
ALSO CARING FOR YOUNG CHILDREN
THE ELDERLY AND FAMILY MEMBERS
THE ABILITY HAPPY HEART
WRENCHING CHOICE. BETWEEN
PROVIDING ADEQUATE CARE FOR
THEIR LOVED ONES KEEPING THE
PAINT SHOP IN A FIVE. BUT THESE
CHOICES ARE NOT NEW
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST FAMILY
CAREGIVERS EXISTED LONG BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC AND IT WILL
UNDOUBTEDLY CONTINUE TO TAKE
AFFIRMATIVE STEPS TO ADDRESS
THAT. I CALIFORNIA IS BEHIND IN
ADDRESSING THAT NEARLY 40% OF
THE AMERICAN WORKFORCE ALREADY
PROTECTED BY STATE OR LOCAL
LAWS THAT PROHIBIT
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
EMPLOYEES ARE GETTING
POSSIBILITIES. CALIFORNIA
WORKERS ARE LEFT OUT. THE
EXPERIENCE OF THE OTHER STATE
SHOWS AND WE RESPONSIBILITIES
DISCRIMINATION MOB WORK FOR
EMPLOYEES AND BUSINESSES ALIKE
ARE ENCOURAGING EMPLOYERS TO
TREAT THEM ATTACK EVER STAY ON
THEIR JOB PERFORMANCE. THAT A
FIVE ONE WHICH HAS THE POWER TO
BOTH THE JOB AND AVOID BOXES.
AB ELEVEN NINETEEN IS
IMPERATIVE CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC
RECOVERY IT WILL ENSURE FAMILY
CAREGIVERS TYPICALLY WOMEN ARE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE FULLY IN
THE LAKE PARK. OAKLAND FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITY IT'S NOT A
PRIVATE POLITICS IF THE HARD
AND NECESSARY WORK OF CARING
FOR THE ELDERLY AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND RAISING THE
NEXT GENERATION OF WORKERS BUT
WE'LL KEEP OUR ECONOMY RUNNING.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
THAT'S WITH US PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JULIAN
CURRENT KING AND I'M READING
THE FOLLOWING STATEMENT ON
BEHALF OF ALL NOT THREE S. MY
NAME IS I'M NOT THIRTY YET THAT
I AM THE MOTHER OF FOUR
CHILDREN MY YOUNGEST THREE B.
AT TWO AND A HALF YEARS OLD.
SHE WAS BORN SEVENTEEN WEEKS
PREMATURE AND HAD BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH THE MOST SEVERE
FORM OF CEREBRAL PALSY. DOCTOR
GAVE HER A 2% CHANCE OF
SURVIVAL AND SHE WOULD CAPS IN
THE NENATAL ICU FOR ALMOST
EIGHT MONTHS AFTER SHE WAS BORN.
TO BE A PLASTIC. AND PREACHER
CHECK YA TO ME TOO. IT DEPENDS
ON A VENTILATOR AND REQUIRES
TWENTY FOUR HOUR SPECIALIZED
CARE TO LET. WHEN RUBY WAS BORN
I WAS WORKING FULL TIME AT THE
BRANCH MANAGER FOR A HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL COMPANY. I WAS A
LOYAL EMPLOYEE AND WAS GOOD AT
MY JOB I EVEN RECEIVED A
COMPANY WIDE AWARD FOR HAVING
THE HIGHEST BUILDING BRANCH I
WORKED ALL DAY AND THEY DID
RUBY IN THE NECK YOU EVERY
NIGHT UNTIL SHE WAS DISCHARGED.
SO MY PERFORMANCE DIDN'T CHANGE
MY TO PROVIDE YOUR PERCEPTION
OF ME THAT. I HAD TO USE MY
HARD EARNED SICK TIME AND PTO
TO TAKE RUBY TO DOCTOR
APPOINTMENTS AND SPECIALIST FOR
THAT. I WAS ALWAYS AFRAID OF
ASKING FOR THE TIME OFF BECAUSE
MY BOSSES WOULD MAKE COMMENTS
AND COMPLAIN ABOUT ME TO MY CO
WORKERS. I RETIRED. RIGHT
BEFORE CHRISTMAS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. I THINK MILLION IT.
AND CONTENT ANXIOUS ABOUT HOW
WOULD PROVIDE FOR MY FAMILY.
THERE WERE TIMES WHEN AGREES
WITH A POWERFUL THAT I ALMOST
BOUGHT THE WILL TO LIVE. BUT I
LOVE MY CHILDREN AND I KNEW I
NEEDED TO PROVIDE FOR THEM. I
FINALLY FOUND ANOTHER JOB IN
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY. I THINK HR
MANAGER. I WAS SO GRATEFUL TO
BE EMPLOYED. I COULD TELL MY
COWORKERS AND MANAGERS
RESPECTED ME AND VALUE MY
EXPERIENCE. DAN ARE AFTERNOON
NURSING TOOK WILL. TO CARE
GROOVY SUDDENLY. WORKING PRESS
BECAUSE OF KOBE. IT'S HOW FOR
ME TO FIND ADEQUATE CARE FOR
TRAINED PROFESSIONALS WHO HAVE
TRICKY AFTER THE EXPERIENCE. SO
I CALLED OCT UPDATED AND THAT I
CAN COMMENT. I HAD NO OTHER
CHOICE. IT WAS THE BEGINNING OF
THE FOR ME AT MY JOB. MY BOX
WITH OBVIOUSLY ANNOYED.
RETALIATED AGAINST ME BY TWO
NINETY PERMISSION TO WORK
REMOTELY EVEN THOUGH EVERYONE
ELSE WAS WORKING REMOTELY. IT'S
LIKE THEY WERE ASKING ME TO
PROVE THAT I WOULD PUT THAT
BEFORE MY CHILD. I NEEDED THE
JOB I CONTINUE TO GO TO THE
OFFICE EVEN THOUGH THE RUBY
PULMONOLOGIST AT IT WITH RICKY.
THIS WAS NOT ENOUGH AND I WAS
FIRED AGAIN. I WAS FIRED TWICE
IN THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF MY
DAUGHTER'S LIFE. BECAUSE I LOVE
AND CARE FOR HER. I DID
EVERYTHING THAT WAS ASKED TO
MEET BOTH OF THESE JOBS. I WENT
ABOVE AND BEYOND TO BE ABLE TO
WORK AND ALL THAT HAVE PROPER
RELIABLE NURSING CARE FOR
REPEAT. THE MAIN MARKET ARE
HUMANS AS WELL. THAT DOESN'T
MAKE ME ANY LESS DEVOTED TO MY
JOB. TO MAKE MY EMPLOYER IS
MORE LIKELY TO FIRE ME. I HAVE
LEARNED A DIFFICULT LESSON THIS
REVIEW WITH BORING. I WAS SO
HAPPY TO HEAR ABOUT THE BILL
BEING PROPOSED BECAUSE THE BILL
WOULD CHANGE MY LIFE. AND MANY
OTHERS AND SITUATIONS LIKE
MINE. I HOPE THIS STORY HELP
YOU UNDERSTAND HOW NECESSARY.
THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. RIGHT OTHERS HE IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN NINETEEN
ANYONE IN THE WITNESS VIDEO
ROOM. SEEING NONE OF THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE
THERE IS NO ONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN
THE LINES FOR THOSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR A
BI. ELEVEN NINETEEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF. AB ELEVEN
NINETEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR
FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM LINE
TO TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS KEVIN YES GO FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB ELEVEN NINETEEN THANK YOU.
ONE MOMENT FOR OUR NEXT COMMON.
NINE TO SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS MARICA
YOSHIHARA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION PROUD T CO SPONSOR
AT ELEVEN NINETEEN STRONGLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS JENNIFER ANTHONY POPCORN AND
COLLEAGUES ON THE COURT. NINE
TWO TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS COULD MEAN A WHILE
KERR WHAT EUROPEAN CALIFORNIA
AND WE HAVE OVER THREE POINT
THREE MILLION MEMBERS WEEKEND
AND SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
NINETEEN. NINE TWO TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS STEPPED IN ROWS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU. NINE
TWO TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS KARINA LIKE
THE WITH THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB ELEVEN NINETEEN THANK YOU
SO MUCH. NINE TO THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
NINE TO NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I HAD. NINE TO NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE TWO
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SORRY THIS IS
MARLON STAPLETON ON BEHALF OF
THE HOLLYWOOD CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR WOMEN
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
ELEVEN NINETEEN ENCOURAGE AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. NINE TO
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
CARE MEMBERS JUST BECAUSE
GOVERNOR ON BEHALF OF EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES PROUD CO
SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT. NINE
TO THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MONICA MURPHY
ON BEHALF OF THE CHARM
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK
AND TRANSPORT THANK YOU. NINE
TWO THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MELISSA SHEA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND SUPPORTED EIGHT
ELEVEN NINETEEN THANK YOU. NINE
TWO TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. KATIE
WATER SMITH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
WORK AND FAMILY COALITION AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN NINETEEN THANK YOU. NINE
TO THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS LIBBY BENEDICT-
REPRESENTING WOMEN'S FOUNDATION
OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN NINETEEN
THANK YOU. NINE TWO TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
ERIN O'NEILL MAULDIN BURKE ON
BEHALF OF WORK EQUITY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN NINETEEN.
NINE TWO TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
RON RAPP SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN NINETEEN THANK YOU. LINE
TWO THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SRT
MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL COUNCIL
OF JEWISH WOMEN AND A CARE
GIVER AND HIRER- OF CARE GIVERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT. OF AB ELEVEN
NINETEEN THANK. LINE ONE OH SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE OF SIXTY MAY BE
ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS JULIA PARRISH SENIOR
STAFF ATTORNEY AT. THE LATE AT
WORK HOUSE CONCERT IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NINE TO FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD MORNING THIS IS PART
OF  LOCAL- WITH THE LINES OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT AND SUPPORT OF ALL
OF THEM. ONE NINE. NINE TO
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS DONNA
PENSION FROM THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA CHARACTERS- RESOURCE
CENTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTEEN ELEVEN NINETEEN AND
JUST ONE DAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BRINGING THE STOCK OR WORK
FOR A FAMILY CARE GIVERS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
OPERATOR WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE ONE
OPPOSITION WITNESS LISTED
ROBERT WILSON FROM THE CAL I'M
SORRY BERMAN. THE ACTUALLY
HOFFMAN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. MORNING MR
KAREN MEMBERS THIS IS ACTUALLY
HOW OFTEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO-
AB ONE ONE ONE NINE AS A JOB
KILLER I DO WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE IN THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE FOR THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THAT SOME
CLARIFICATION AS TO WHAT THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL IS WITH
RESPECT TO THE REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION REQUIREMENTS. WE
DO HOWEVER STILL HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL BUT IT'S UNCLEAR
HERE IS WHAT GAP IS STILL
TRYING TO SELL LABOR COULD YOU
THIRTY POINT EIGHT ALREADY
PROVIDES FORTY HOURS OF LEAVE
PER SCENARIOS WHERE THERE'S AN
UNFORESEEN CLOSURE OF A SCHOOL
OR CHILD CARE CENTER. HE LEADS
STATUTES CAN CARE AND SEE FOR
ALREADY PROVIDE TIME OFF TO
CARE FOR OTHER CARE RECIPIENTS
UP TO TWELVE WEEKS RATHER THAN
WORK WITHIN THE CONFINES OF
THESE CARE ACT LEADS ALREADY
EXISTS THIS BILL CREATES A
VEGAN UNCAPPED REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION REQUIREMENTS FOR
EXAMPLE IF THERE WAS TO BE
ANOTHER COMMON EIGHTEEN THIRD
SHUTTING DOWN SCHOOL FOR A
MONTH OR TWO MONTHS EMPLOYERS
WOULD HAVE TO ACCOMMODATE ALL
EMPLOYEES FOR PARENTS THAT
ENTIRE TIME. IT ALSO
ESSENTIALLY ELIMINATES THE
TWELVE WEEK CAP ON FIFA NOW BY
THE SMALL BUSINESSES WHO JUST
FIVE EMPLOYEES BY KNOCKING THIS
BILL WE ARE PUTTING YET ANOTHER
VAGUE MANDATE ON EMPLOYERS
WANTED THAT IS FREQUENTLY THE
SOURCE OF LITIGATION DURING THE
LAST HEARING ON THE SPELLING
STATED THAT LITIGATION UNDER
THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING
ACTIVE SO WHERE IS BEING STRUCK
BY LIGHTNING. THAN ACTUALITY IN
THE UNITED STATES THE
LIKELIHOOD OF HAVING AN
APPOINTMENT CHARGE FILED
AGAINST YOU IS TEN POINT 5% IN
CALIFORNIA THAT RATE IS 56%
THAT'S NOT EVEN INCLUDING MAN
LETTERS THREATENING LITIGATION
PRIOR TO THE F. EACH TARGETING
CROWD WHICH IS HOW SOME LOCKERS
EXCLUSIVELY MAKE THEIR MONEY.
NO OTHER STATE THAT INCLUDES
PERRIN HEAD OR FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES IS IN IN ITS
ANTI DISCRIMINATION PROVISIONS
INCLUDE A REASONABLE
COMPETITION REQUIREMENTS IN
FACT DELAWARE WHICH HAS THE
MOST BROAD DEFINITION OF FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES SIMILAR TO
WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED HERE
EXPLICITLY STATES THAT THERE IS
NO ACCOMMODATION REQUIREMENTS
AND THAT THE ANTI
DISCRIMINATION PROVISION DOES
NOT APPLY. WITH RESPECT TO THE
EMPLOYERS ATTENDANCE AND
ABSENTEEISM STANDARDS FINALLY
EVEN PUTTING A REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION PROVISION ASIDE.
THE DEFINITION OF FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES IS PROBABLY.
UNDER THE SPELL. AND A VERY
BOLD LINE BETWEEN NOT
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST SOMEONE
BASED ON THE NEED TO CARE FOR
SOMEONE ELSE. AND WE'RE- A
COMEDY. THERE'S ACTUALLY READ
CAL COURT. IN WHICH THE CAT
COURT NINE. JUDGMENT FOR AN
EMPLOYER UNDER. CLAIM BECAUSE
THE SUPERVISOR DID NOT HONOR
THE EMPLOY SCHEDULE REQUEST TO
HAVE AN EARLIER SHIFT TO BE
HOME ON CERTAIN DAYS TO PROVIDE
CARE FOR A FAMILY MEMBER. THE
COURT CREATED THE DE FACTO
COMBINATION REQUIREMENT EVEN
AFTER DIRECTLY STATING THAT
THERE WAS NO REASONABLE
COMBINATION REQUIREMENT FOR
THAT SCENARIO UNDER THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT.
SUCH A BROAD DEFINITION OF
FAMILY RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER
THIS PROVISION IS SURE TO
GENERATE SOME MORE CASES WHERE
EMPLOYERS ARE IN ESSENCE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
ACCOMMODATION. IF THE GOAL OF
THIS BILL IS TRULY TO ENSURE
THE APPLICANTS ARE NOT BEING
TURNED AWAY BECAUSE THEIR
PARENTS. ARE WORKERS ARE BEING
DENIED PROMOTIONS BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN L. RELATIVE TO
CARE FOR THIS BILL REACHES FAR
BEYOND THAT AND IF I COULD DO.
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT
ARE FINANCIALLY DEVASTATED TO
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY. THAT IS
ALREADY SIGNIFICANTLY SUFFERING
DUE TO COLD IT. FOR THOSE
REASONS WE OPPOSE AB. ELEVEN
NINETEEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WELL NOW GO TO OTHERS WHO LIKE
TO INTO OFFICE. TO BE A LOT
NINETY. I SEE NO ONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. WHERE THE WITNESS
VIDEO ROOM ANYONE AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION TO AB. ELEVEN
NINETEEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OF ABELEVEN
NINETEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR FIRST
MIND COMMENT THIS LINE TO
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- KEVIN
TO DROUGHT IT REPRESENTING
NFIB- WE ARE OPPOSED- AS
MENTIONED BY. THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THANK YOU.
NINE TWO ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS TRUDIE HUGHES
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE FOOD
PRODUCERS IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL AND ECHOING ALL THE
COMMENTS MADE BY THE TOP MAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THANK YOU. NINE TWO
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU DON'T ON
BEHALF OF PUBLIC RISK
INNOVATION POLLUTION IN
MANAGEMENT OFTEN ENOUGH PRESENT
IN WITH OPPOSITION THANKS FOR.
NINE TO NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SO SORRY
I MISSED JERRY HUNDRED ANSLEY
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY BUT
LEVELS OF NAKED GET INTO THE
LINE TO SUPPORT A. B. OF THE
NINETEEN. X. SORRY FOR THE
CONFUSION. NO PROBLEM THANK YOU.
NINE TO FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
KATIE HANSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. NINE TWO ZERO THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. H. KEVIN ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CAR WASH
ASSOCIATION AND FAMILY
WINEMAKERS OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NINE TO
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LARA GAME WILL
BE ON THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL OF.
FINE TWO THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING NUMBERS CHANGE HELP
WITH A SIMPLE JUSTIFICATION
CALIFORNIA AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO TELL THANK YOU.
NINE TWO HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING I CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION BRIAN LITTLE
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY THE REPRESENTATIVE
FROM CALCHAMBER THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
IN THE OPPOSITION Q. I THANK
YOU I WILL THEN BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE YOU MAY CLOSE THE
LINES OPERATOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. AS DAVID THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISLED- AS STATED
ALREADY THAT THE ON THE LABOR
CODE DOES PROVIDE UP TO FORTY
HOURS LEAVE- FORWARD THAT
DAYCARE SCHOOLS AT AN EXPECTED
A CLOSE AS WELL AS THERE USED
TO A PICK UP. STUDENTS FROM
SCHOOL IF NEED BE- I ALSO HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY- RIGHT
ACT AND THAT PROVIDES UP TO
THREE MONTHS TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
CARE FOR MEDICAL CARE WHICH IS
FANTASTIC IT'S SOMETHING WE'VE
ALWAYS NEEDED. I GUESS MY
CONCERN IS AS A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER THE POTENTIAL OF-
LITIGATION BEING PUT ON A SMALL
BUSINESSES THERE'S BAD ACTORS
AND THERE'S GOOD ACTORS- BUT WE
HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES EMPLOY THESE PEOPLE
AND SO IF THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
BE THERE ARE. THE JOBS LEAVE SO
WHAT IS YOUR CONCERN WHAT'S
YOUR THOUGHT ON THAT ON THE
LITIGATION THAT COULD COME UP
THERE SPECIALLY WHEN YOU DON'T
HAVE- A REASONABLE- YOU KNOW
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATIONS WHAT
IS THE DEFINITION OF THAT
THAT'S MY CHILDREN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU YEAH THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION FOR **** SO MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE FORTY
HOURS A WEEK OF- DOES NOT APPLY
TO BUSINESSES TWENTY FIVE
EMPLOYEES OR OR BELOW SO I
THINK WE'RE LEAVING OUT A WHOLE
COHORT OF FOLKS THERE- WITH
REGARD TO THE LYTIC LITIGATION-
QUESTION. WE JUST HAVEN'T SEEN
IT IN THIS BILL THAT'S BEEN
PASSED IN OVER TWO HUNDRED
MINUTES OF HOLIDAYS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THERE HAS NOT BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN-
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
HASTINGS LAW DID SOME RESEARCH
ON THIS AND- AND FOUND I THINK
IN TOTAL THERE WERE SEVENTY ONE
TOTAL LAWSUITS PERTAINING TO
THIS SO. IT'S JUST NOT. AS
PREVALENT I THINK IS THE
CHAMBERS SAYING THAT IT WILL
BE- I ALSO THINK THAT THIS BILL
IS IT'S VERY NARROWLY DEFINED
YOU KNOW IT'S- REQUIRES
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION FOR
THE KNOWN FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES AN APPLICANT
OR EMPLOYEE RELATED TO
OBLIGATIONS ARISING FROM.
NEEDING TO CARE FOR A MINOR
CHILD OR CARE RECIPIENT WHO
SCHOOL OR PLACE OF CARE IS
CLOSED OR OTHERWISE UNAVAILABLE
SO IT'S NARROW IN SCOPE- AND
THE LAST THING I'LL SAY WITH
THE FORTY HOURS YOU KNOW THAT
CAN BE USED FOR A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. STALKING I MEAN
THERE'S A WIDE AGE OF THINGS AS
A SHOULD BE. THIS IS VERY
NARROW AND- THE STRANGER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- I REALLY I
THINK I UNDERSTAND PROBABLY
BETTER THAN ANYONE THERE ARE
BETTER THAN A LOT OF PEOPLE-
SITTING UP HERE HOW IMPORTANT
THIS IS I'VE BEEN A SINGLE DAD
NOW FOR- FOURTEEN YEARS IN
EFFECT AS THIS WAS GOING ON MY
DAUGHTER AND I'VE BEEN TEXTING
ABOUT A DOCTOR'S APPOINTMENT
THAT WE NEED TO. COMPLETE AND
IT'S OBVIOUSLY VERY IT'S BEEN
VERY DIFFICULT- AND NUMBER THE
SITUATIONS AND THEN SOME THAT
WERE BROUGHT UP HERE HAVE I'VE
PERSONALLY EXPERIENED HOW HARD
THIS IS TO DO- SO. I APPRECIATE
THIS AND I AND I REALLY SEE AND
UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR THIS
ONE OF THE THINGS I DO WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THOUGH IS. A I DO
THINK THAT THE- THERE NEEDS TO
BE CERTAINTY. AND THE
DEFINITIONS NEED TO BE TIGHTLY
DEFINED FOR AN FOR. A NUMBER OF
REASONS. WHETHER IT'S YOU KNOW
FAIRNESS TO SMALL BUSINESSES-
BUT- BUT IN ADDITION IT'S
AVOIDING LITIGATION YOU KNOW.
FOR THE ACTORS OUT THERE AND I
AM REALLY I DO. THINK YOU KNOW
MOST PEOPLE TRY TO ACCOMPLISH
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW HAVE A-
LEVEL OF UNDERSTANDING FOR
SINGLE PARENTS IN PARTICULAR
HOW HARD IT IS- AND EVEN IF
THEY'RE- IN A TWO PARENT. YOU
KNOW SITUATION THEY THEY- THEY
CAN REALLY FIGURE OUT THAT WITH
ONE OF YOU IT'S HARD. SO I
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO
ARE REALLY TRYING TO COMPLY AND
TRYING TO DO RIGHT. UNDERSTAND
WHAT HOW WHAT THE LEGAL
DEFINITION YEP NOT A
COMMONSENSE DEFINITION OF
REASONABLE. BUT A LEGAL
DEFINITION OF REASONABLE AND
THAT'S HARD TO DO SO COULD YOU
GO THROUGH AGAINYOU SAID THIS
IS. SO COULD YOU TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT YOU KNOW QUOTE QUOTE
REASONABLE AND QUOTE YEP. AND
THEN ALSO TALK ABOUT THE SCOPES
OF THE SURE THINGS. YES SO- IT
REQUIRES COME. AND WHICH COULD
BE WORK FROM HOME YOU KNOW
WHICH WAS SORT OF THE EXAMPLE
THAT WAS- THE LAWYER WHO WAS
READING THE STATEMENT RIGHT-
OTHER PEOPLE ARE WORKING FROM
HOME CAN SHE WORK FROM HOME SHE
HAS TO DO SOMETHING WITH HER
CHILD YOU KNOW- IS IT CAN I.
YOU KNOW MY KIDS IN THE SUCH
SEVEN IN HIGH SCHOOL I WOULD
HAVE BOMB THREATS AT MY SCHOOL.
YOU KNOW AND MY MOM HAVE TO
COME PICK ME UP AND IT WOULD BE
AN HOUR OUT OF HER DAY WERE SHE
NEED TO GO DO THAT. SHE WANT TO
TAKE A WHOLE DAY OFF OF WORK IN
ORDER TO DO THAT BUT WANTED TO
USE SOME OF THAT TIME. RIGHT
AND SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
EXAMPLES SORT OF A REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION. FOR KNOWN FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES SO THESE ARE
KNOWN RESPONSIBILITIES OF AN
APPLICANT OR EMPLOYEE RELATED
TO OBLIGATION. ARISING FROM
NEEDED TO CARE FOR A MINOR
CHILD OR CARE RECIPIENT SO
COULD BE AN OLDER PARENT. OR A
DISABLED PERSON IN YOUR LIFE
THAT YOU YOU CARE FOR ARE NOT
THE PRIMARY CARE GIVER- SCHOOL
OR PLACE OF CARE IS CLOSED OR
OTHERWISE UNAVAILABLE. SO THAT
IS THE NARROW FOCUS OF THE
BILL- IN ADDITION TO THAT- IF
THERE IS UNDUE HARDSHIP TO THE-
EMPLOYER- WHICH IS DEFINED AS
SIGNIFICANT DIFFICULTY OR
EXPENSE. SO FOR INSTANCE IF YOU
WORK AT A SEVEN ELEVEN YOU'RE
THE ONLY EMPLOYEE THERE. AND
SOMETHING HAPPENS THEY HAVE TO
SHUT THE SHOP DOWN IF THEY
CAN'T FIND SOMEONE TO COME IN.
THAT WOULD BE UNDUE HARDSHIP-
WHICH WOULD NOT THEN QUALIFY
FOR THIS AND I AGREE WITH YOU I
THINK MOST EMPLOYERS. YOU KNOW
THEY WANT TO BE ACCOMMODATING
TO THEIR TO THEIR EMPLOYEES AND
I THINK MOST EMPLOYEES WANT TO
DO A GOOD JOB AT THEIR PLACE OF
EMPLOYMENT- BUT THERE ARE
CIRCUMSTANCES IN SOME OF THE
STUDIES THAT I MENTIONED IN MY-
INITIAL STATEMENTS. DO WILL
POINT TO THE FACT THAT WE DO
NEED I THINK TO WRAP HER ARMS A
LITTLE BIT MORE AROUND THIS AND
I'M VERY MINDFUL OF THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY. ESPECIALLY
RIGHT NOW AND DISCOVERED
RECOVERY ERA YOU KNOW AND I'VE
SAT DOWN AND HAD NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE CHAMBER.
I WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO AS
WELL AS A SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY. YOU KNOW VERY COUNCIL
IN OTHER BUSINESS GROUPS AS
WELL AS WELL AS INDIVIDUAL
BUSINESS BUSINESSES I TALK TO.
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO CREATE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCESAND I
AGREE I THINK THAT DEFINITIONS
ARE IMPORTANT AND- SOME MEMBERS
ALSO I CHATTED ABOUT THIS- IN
THE ALASKAN. AND I AND WE WERE
ON SOMEONE- AND I WILL CONTINUE
TO DO SO BECAUSE I DO WANT TO
CREATE A THOUGHTFUL BILL. AND
ON ON SCOPES WOULD SCOPE
INCLUDE AS HARDSHIP FOR
EXAMPLES. IT IN A CERTAIN
PROFESSIONS ENOUGH OR MAYBE A
LAWYER ACCOUNTANT BE EASIER TO
WORK FROM HOME FRIDAY. SEPT THE
SEVEN ELEVEN. SHOP MORE
DISCOURSE. WHAT ABOUT SOME ARE
SORT OF IN THEM WHAT IF YOU
WERE A- MECHANIC LET'S SAY
INTEREST. IS THERE AND THERE
WERE. SEVEN EMPLOYEES GOING
DOWN TO SIX OR SOMETHING YOU
KNOW WHAT. RIGHT WHAT DO YOU DO
SO FOR THAT WHAT'S THE SCOPE
OF. SO I MEAN I THINK IF IT'S A
MECHANIC WHO HAS TO PHYSICALLY
BE THERE. RIGHT AND THAT'S A
JOB THAT REQUIRES A PERSON TO
PHYSICALLY BE THERE. SO THAT
PERSON OBVIOUSLY CAN'T WORK
FROM HOME RIGHT. BUT IF THERE'S
A WAY THAT. YOU KNOW IN A
MOMENT WHERE THEY NEED TWO OR
THREE HOURS TO DEAL WITH
SOMETHING. YOU KNOW CAN THEY
CALL SOMEONE WHO'S OFFERED TO
COMMAND. CAN SOMEONE COVER
THEIR SHIFT. CAN THEY PROVIDE
SOME KIND OF A REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATIONS OF THE PERSON
CAN DEAL. WITH THAT THE SINCE
THE SITUATION AT HAND. OKAY I.
AM THEN I. WILL YOU'RE YOU'RE
GONNA CAN. TO WORK ON SO OF
COURSE YEAH AND I'M A YOU KNOW
AND I'VE TALKED TO THE CHAMBER-
WE HAVEN'T REACHED AN
AGREEMENT. I WILL CONTINUE TO
TALK TO THE CHAMBERS MUCH AS
THEY WANT TO TALK TO ME- THEY
MIGHT GET SICK OF ME BUT I'M
HAPPY TO KEEP CHATTING AND-
AGAIN WITH OTHER BUSINESSES AS
WELL TO SEE IF WE CAN- DO THIS
THE RIGHT WAY. WELL I YOU KNOW
I'M I'M GONNA SAY INDEFINITE
FOR THE SITE. TODAY WE URGE YOU
TO KEEP WORKING ON THE LEGAL
DEFINITION I DON'T WANT TO GET
LOST IN LITIGATE HAVE TO HAVE
THIS BE. JUST BE A TON OF
NEEDLESS. LITIGATION AGAIN HIS
IS SOMETHING THAT. YOU KNOW I
WISH. I COULD HAVE UTILIZED
OVER THE LAST FOURTEEN YEARS
YEAH- BECAUSE IT'S BEEN.
QUALITY CREDIBLY REWARDING
EXPERIENCE FOR ME IT IS
DEFINITELY BAD AND- YOU KNOW
VERY DIFFICULT VERY STRESSFUL-
AND IT'S HARD. IT'S HARD FOR
FAMILY YOU KNOW FOR SINGLE
PARENTS- YOU KNOW WITH KIDS. TO
MANAGE THE EIGHT MILLION THINGS
THAT COME UP BETWEEN SCHOOL
AND- SPORTS OF DOCTORS
APPOINTMENTS OR SOMEBODY
GETTING SICK OR- THINGS AT
SCHOOL IT'S JUST A- IT'S JUST A
TREMENDOUS CHALLENGE WITH ONE
PERSON TRYING TO. IT'S A
TREMENDOUS CHALLENGE WITH TWO
PARENTS. AND ONE IS EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT AND I'VE HAD SIMILAR
SITUATIONS WHICH I MENTIONED IN
MY LAST COMMITTEE. THAT DAY I
HAD A PROBLEM RIGHT- AND WE'RE
LUCKY WE'RE PRIVILEGE RIGHT
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
AREN'T WHO DON'T HAVE THE SAME
PRIVILEGE THAT WE DO- SO WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THIS THE
RIGHT WAY BUT I DO HEAR THE
CONCERNS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON AND I ALSO WELCOME
FEEDBACK FROM THE COMMITTEE OR
OTHERS WHO. WANT TO KEEP
HELPING ME WORK ON THE BILL.
WOULD JUST LOVE TO STICK IT OUT
OF COMMITTEE TODAY. THANK YOU.
THIS TO JEFF. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY- YES I DO- THANK GOD
DOES SOMEBODY DEFINITIONS COULD
BE FINE TUNE A LITTLE BIT MORE
ARE I HAVE A LOT OF US SMALL
BUSINESSES IN MY DISTRICT AND I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE BILL
DOESN'T NEGATIVELY IMPACT THEM
OUT AS MUCH HAVE SO I'M HOPING
THAT UP ANYTIME THE BILL
REACHES THE FLOOR I'LL BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT IT AGAIN OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU MR
TRUMP. THIS COMES OUT I THANK
YOU FOR WORKING ON THIS IT'S
DEFINITELY IN BETTER SHAPE I
THINK AND THEN WHEN WE SIGN
LABOR- I GUESS I JUST KEEP
COMING BACK TO THINKING ABOUT
COST. ACCOMMODATION AND WHAT
THAT COULD MEAN. I'M A LITTLE
CONCERNED ON NOW. AND I DON'T
MEAN TO DO THIS TO VERY VERY
HONEST I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED.
THAT IT DOES THE ACCOMMODATIONS
AVAILABLE TO. WHITE COLLAR
WORKERS- IS MUCH BROADER THAN I
MEAN YOU'RE EXAMPLES ITSELF
SHOW THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
PROBABLY NEED THIS THE MOST ARE
LEAST LIKELY TO BE ABLE TO
UTILIZE THAT. SO I'M NOT SAYING
THIS IS A WAIT THE APPROACH TO
GO OR NOT BUT- I CAN'T HELP BUT
WONDER IN SOME OF THE THINGS
ARE GETTING CONFUSED AND I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
REMIND PEOPLE YOU ABSOLUTELY
CAN TAKE UP IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE DAY- IF YOUR CHILD IS SICK
WE BROKE THOSE PROTECTIONS THIS
BODY DID IN. TWENTY FOURTEEN I
THINK I'M SO SICK LEAVE YOU
KNOW IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
EVERY SINGLE EMPLOYEE DOES
MATTER HOW SMALL. THE EMPLOYER
IS WHICH IS GOOD IT'S FAIR IT'S-
IMPORTANT- AND I WANT PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND THEY HAVE THAT RIGHT
RIGHT NOW- IF THEY HAVE ACCRUED
SICK LEAVE. IT'S PROBABLY NOT
ENOUGH ACCRUED SICK LEAVE WHERE
BILL FOR THAT. BUT I'M
WONDERING IF THIS THE
UTILIZATION OF ALREADY- PAID
TIME OFF. TO BE EXPANDED FOR
THIS PURPOSE MIGHT BETTER FIT
IN THAT STATUTE. I THINK YOU
KNOW BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE
TRYING TO. PUT SOMETHING IN A
DIFFERENT STATUTE THAT MAYBE I
I'M STILL UNCOMFORTABLE WITH
JUST A THOUGHT. THAT IT MIGHT
BE THAT WE JUST. COULD EXPAND
THE UTILIZATION OF PAID TIME
OFF THAT WE ARE SURE I MEAN AND
I'M HAPPY TO DEFINITELY LOOK
INTO THAT BECAUSE I THINK. I'M
NOT. MARRIED TO THIS IDEA THAT
HAS TO BE THIS WAY BUT WHAT I
AM FOCUSED ON IS PROVIDING THE
ACCOMMODATION RIGHT SUPER
IMPORTANT SO I'M HAPPY TO TOTAL
TO LOOK INTO THAT- YOU KNOW
MILWAUKEE ELSE WAS THE
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION- AND
SO WE'RE TRYING TO DO SOME
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THEM AS
WELL- SO I THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE AN ONGOING CONVERSATION AND
THIS IS DEFINITELY. LIKE A
NEWER CONCEPT BUT IT ONE THAT'S
BEEN TRIED IN OTHER PLACES SO
WE WANT TO GET IT RIGHT HERE
BUT- I'D BE HAPPY TO LOOK INTO
THAT. I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION IS IT
TOO BROAD BUT IT ALSO ISN'T SO
NARROW THAT IT EXCLUDES.
INDIVIDUALS WHO DO SERVICE WORK
BASICALLY RIGHT NOW I HEAR YOU
OKAY THANK YOU. RIGHT OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. SIGNALED
THIS WEEK TO MAKE CLOTHES JUST
RESPECT RESPECTFULLYASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE IS I STILL HAVE SOME
WORK TO DO AND WANT TO KEEP THE
PLOT MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU
SERVICES WE DO A MOTION AND A
SECOND MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE HI STONE
AYE CHAU CHOW I CHIU DAVIES
DAVIES NO GONZALEZ CONSULTS AYE
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE RADIUS AYE
REYES AYE SMITH SMITH NOW. THAT
BILLS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU WE NOW HAVE TWO MORE
ITEMS A. B. FOUR TWENTY FOUR
AND A. B. FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
THE JUDICIARY BILL THAT I'LL BE
PRESENTING THIS RACE WHICH YOU.
HELLO COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
FOR
TWENTY FOUR MISTER SEA WOLF
THANK YOU THANK YOU I WILL ALSO.
BE HAPPY TO TAKE THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THAT CAN BE TEARS FORCING
ME TO TAKE. I NAY BEFORE TWENTY
FOUR AB FOUR TWENTY FOURTHS
TRYING IS ANOTHER STUDENT LOAN
BILL TO TRY TO DEAL WITH A VERY
SPECIFIC PROBLEM AND THIS IS.
WHERE SERVICERS AND COLLECTION
AGENCIES ARE UTILIZING THE
COURT SYSTEM AND TAKING
ADVANTAGE. OF INDIVIDUALS THE
THOSE THE STUDENT BORROWERS WHO
ARE NOT VERY SOPHISTICATED AND
DON'T ALWAYS UNDERSTAND THE
SYSTEM. SO THEY WILL GO TO
COURT THE SERVICERS AND THE-
THE COLLECTION AGENCIES WILL
WILL GO TO COURT TO SEEK A. A
DECLARATORY RELIEF ON AGAINST
THAT INDIVIDUAL AND THAT
INDIVIDUAL DOESN'T ALWAYS KNOW
ENOUGH TO GO TO COURT TO
RESPOND IT INTO ADEQUATELY
PROTECT THEMSELVES AND ONCE THE
DEFAULT JUDGMENT IS ENTERED
INTO. THANK WESTON'S ABOUT
EVIDENCE DON'T ARRIVE. AND THEY
WILL OFTEN THESE SERVICERS AND
THE COLLECTION AGENCIES WALKING
GOING WITHOUT CLEARLY BEING
EVEN ABLE TO IDENTIFY THAT THEY
OWN THE DEBT THAT THEY HAVE A
RIGHT. TO SEEK THE DEATH. AND
SOMEONE WHO PUT IS WILLING AND
UNDERSTANDS HOW TO PUSH BACK IN
THAT EVIDENCE REPROCESS WILL DO
SO AND WOULD POTENTIALLY WIN
AND THIS IS WHAT THE DATA SHOWS
IS SO MANY TIMES THE SERVICERS
AND THESE COLLECTION AGENCIES
REALLY CAN'T EVEN DEMONSTRATE.
THAT THEY OWN THE DEBT BUT ONCE
A DEFAULT JUDGMENT IS ENTERED
INTO THEN THAT BORROWER IS
SEVERELY NEGATIVELY IMPACTED
AND REALLY DOESN'T HAVE
RECOURSE ALL THIS BILL DOES
IT'S AN EVIDENCE BILL. IS ASKS
THAT IN THESE CASES THAT THE-
STUDENT SERVICER OR THE DEBT
COLLECTION AGENCY DEMONSTRATE
AFFIRMATIVELY THAT THE ON THE
DEBT THAT THEY CAN IDENTIFY.
THE STUDENT LOAN BORROWER. IN
IN THEN IF THE DEFAULT JUDGMENT
IS ENTERED INTO THE IT IS A
MUCH MORE PROPER. SITUATION AND
WE'VE OVERCOME THE EVIDENTIARY
QUESTIONS THAT'S REALLY THE NOT
OF WHAT THIS IS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTES ON AB FOUR TWENTY FOUR.
AND WITH ME R. MIKE FIERS OF
THE STUDENT BORROWER PROTECTION
CENTER AND ROBIN SMITH OF LEGAL
AID FOUNDATION OF LOS ANGELES
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT AND I
BELIEVE THEY'RE BOTH IN THE
WITNESS VIDEO ROOM IS WHAT.
INFORMATION I HAVE ANOTHER NOT
SO I GUESS THEY'RE PROBABLY
AVAILABLE ON THE PHONE
HOPEFULLY. EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY
FOUR TO HAVE THOSE QUEUED UP.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE MIKE PIERCE
AND ROBIN SMITH ARE YOU ON THE
LINE. I'M HERE- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- THANK YOU SURE THAT YOU
VICE CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS MIKE
PIERCE. ON THE POLICY DIRECTOR
OF THE STUDENT BAR PROTECTION
CENTER- WE'RE A NATIONAL
NONPROFIT COMMITTED TO ENDING
STUDENT DEBT CRISIS IN HERE
TODAY BECAUSE OUR ORGANIZATION-
PRACTICE SPONSOR AND SUPPORT
EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR. EIGHTY
FOUR TWENTY FOUR STILL HOLDS AN
IMPORTANT GAP THE REMAINS IN
CALIFORNIA CONSERVE LAW- THE.
SPEED OF PRIVATE STUDENT LOAN
BORROWERS IN DEFAULT- I THIS
COMMITTEES WHERE'D COLLECTOR
AND DEBT COLLECTION LAWSUITS
WERE BEYOND THE SCOPE OF MR
STONE PLAN MARKSTON BARBEL. AND
IS TWENTY SIXTEEN TO ONE
SERVICING ACT. AS A RESULT SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA STUDENT LOAN
BORROWERS WHO OWE. MORE THAN
TEN BILLION DOLLARS IN PRIVATE
STUDENT LOAN LOANS REMAIN
VULNERABLE TO AN ABSOLUTELY
SHOCKING ARRANGE THE PIECES. IF
THEY BALK FALL BEHIND ON THE
DEATH. BEFORE I CO FOUNDED THE
BAR PROTECTION EXPENSE SEVEN
THAT. AT THE FEDERAL CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION BUREAU.
WHICH BROUGHT ENFORCEMENT
ACTION AGAINST THE BIGGEST
ABUSER OF CALIFORNIA COURTS THE
NATIONAL COLLEGIATE STUDENT
LOAN TRUSTS. NCLT ALONG WITH
BEING OUT OF STATE NONBANK
CREDITORS LIKE NAPPIES. HAVE
PILED THOUSANDS OF LAWSUITS IN
CALIFORNIA COURTS OVER THE PAST
FIVE YEARS. IN THE CFPB'S
LANDMARK LAWSUIT AGAINST NCLT
THE BUREAU FOUND- THE EMPTY
THOUGHT HE FILED FALSE
AFFIDAVITS IN STATE COURT IN
LACKS DOCUMENTS TO BACK UP.
DEBTS IN THOUSANDS OF CASES.
RECENT RESEARCH BY A PARTNERS
AT C. IRVINE CONSUMER LAW
CLINIC SHOWS THAT ACTIONS IN
ACTIONS BROUGHT BY AND PFLP IN
ITS PEERS IN FULLY 90% OF
CASES. FARMERS LACK LEGAL
COUNSEL. THESE TWO WISHES IN
COMBINATION THE LACK OF LEGAL
COUNSEL AND THE ABUSE OF
CALIFORNIA COURT AGREED
UNMITIGATED DISASTER FOR THE
MOST VULNERABLE BORROWERS TOO
MANY OF HIM DISCOVER AFTER THE
FACT THAT THEIR WAGES WERE
GARNISHED FOR DEBT THAT WERE
UNDOCUMENTED. OR INVALID. I THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS AND CREDIT
UNIONS ARE HERE TODAY IN
OPPOSITION I WANT TO CONCLUDE
BY EMPHASIZING THAT THE MAJOR
DRIVERS OF THESE ABUSES ARE NOT
CALIFORNIA BANKS. AND THEY'RE
NOT CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNIONS.
NPSL HE'S NOT BACK AT ALL WITH
A LOAN STUFF INTO THESE TRAPS
WERE MADE BY THE BIGGEST BANKS
IN THE WORLD JPMORGAN CHASE
BANK OF AMERICA AND U. S. BANK.
BANK MADE SUBPRIME STUDENT
LOANS WERE PASSED UP TO
INVESTORS BORROWER STRUGGLE TO
REPAIR A AND DECADES LATER
THESE CASES CONTINUE TO CALL
CALIFORNIA COURTS AND HER
CALIFORNIA BARS. BIG BANKS
AREN'T FILING THESE LAWSUITS
BUT THE LAWSUITS ARE A LEGACY
OF PREDATORY LENDING BY BEING
OUT. OF STATE AND NATIONAL
BANKS. FORTUNATELY A FORTY FOUR
ONE THE FIFTY TO THIS CHIU MR.
GRAD MISTER SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND URGING I. ON EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY FOUR CALIFORNIA STUDENT
LOAN BORROWERS CANNOT AFFORD TO
WAIT LONGER. THANK YOU MR
PIERCE ROBIN SMITH- THE PHONE
LINE. YES I'M HERE GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ROBIN
SMITH I AM A SENIOR ATTORNEY AT
THE LEGAL AID FOUNDATION OF LOS
ANGELES I HAVE BEEN
REPRESENTING BORROWERS AND
PRIVATE STUDENT LOAN COLLECTION
ACTION SIX TWENTY THIRTEEN
DURING THE TIME I HAVE HANDLED
MULTIPLE CASES INVOLVING MANY
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PLAINTIFFS
INCLUDING SECURITIZED LOAN
TRUST LIKE THE NATIONAL
COLLEGIATE AND NAVEEN STUDENT
LOAN TRACKER. THAT FIRED AND
INSURANCE COMPANIES THAT
GUARANTEE PAYMENTS ON DEFAULTED
LOANS A COLLECTION OF PIECES WE
HAVE SEEN ARE COMMON AMONG ALL
THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF PLANS
THAT LAPTOP YOU WILL SUPPORT
EIGHTY TWENTY FOUR FOUR TWENTY
FOUR WHICH WILL PREVENT PRIVATE
STUDENT LOAN HOLDERS FROM
ABUSING THE JUDICIAL PROCESS BY
FILING DEBT COLLECTION LAWSUITS
WHEN THEY LACK THE MOST BASIC
EVIDENCE NECESSARY TO MAKE A
PRIMA FACIE CASE FOR BREACH OF
WRITTEN CONTRACT. I WILL SHARE
CHIU BRIEF STORY ILLUSTRATES
THE HARM THAT WOULD BE
PREVENTED BY EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY
FOUR AND I CHANGED THE NAME FOR
THEIR CONFIDENTIALITY WITH ALL
RESIDENTS THINK OF MOTHERS
ACCORDING TO THE CHILDREN BUT A
LOW WAGE JOB IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
A DEFAULT JUDGMENT AT THIRTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS WAS
ENTERED AGAINST HER FOR PRIVATE
STUDENT LOAN SHE OBTAINED IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN. EVEN THOUGH
THE PLAINTIFFS LACK OF THE
EVIDENCE THAT IT OWNED AND HAD
A RIGHT TO COLLECT ON THE LOT
MS OPERATES CONTACTED OUR
OFFICE FOR HELP BECAUSE HER
EMPLOYER HAD BEEN GARNISHING
25% OF HER DISPOSABLE PAPER
OVER TWO YEARS AND AS A RESULT
SHE WAS STRUGGLING TO PAY HER
RENT AND OTHER BASIC LIVING
EXPENSES. WE DISCOVERED THAT
HER EMPLOYER HAD APPLIED THE
INCORRECT GARNISHMENT FORMULA
AND A LEGALLY GARNISHED OVER
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS WHY WE
WERE ABLE TO GET THIS AMOUNT
REFUNDED IN TOP OVER
GARNISHMENT. ALVAREZ'S WAGES
MAY STILL BE GARNISHED BECAUSE
OUR PAYMENTS ARE NOT LIKELY TO
COVER THE ANNUAL INTEREST RATE
AND THEN THE CREWS THAT WILL
GROW EVEN AFTER WAGES ARE
GARNISHED SHE CANNOT DISCHARGE
THE DEBT THROUGH THE STATE OF
BANKRUPTCY EITHER SHE BASICALLY
HAD NO OPTION. TO PREVENT THE
GARNISHMENT IN THE FUTURE. IN
ANOTHER CASE INTO THAT SIX IS
BEING UPDATES TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR PRICE STUDENT. WITH A-
PERCENT ANNUAL PER. RATE FROM A
BANK TO. HOW WHICH WERE CO
SIGNED BY HER MY- IS BEING
ENTER MY ARE LOW INCOME AT.
AMERICAN WOMEN WHO HAVE NEVER
MADE ANY PAYMENTS ON THE LOAN
AND THEY COULD NOT AFFORD THEM
AND NO AFFORDABLE PAYMENT
OPTIONS ARE OFFERED. TWELVE
YEARS LATER BOTH MEN BAILEY AND
HER MOTHER WERE SERVED WITH A
COMPLAINT. FILED BY A PRIVATE
STUDENT LOAN TRANCHE. THINKING
DAMAGES THE FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR BREACH OF CONTRACT.
WE REPRESENTED BOTH OF THEM AND
ASSERTED VERY DEFENSIVE
INCLUDING STATUTES OF
LIMITATIONS AND THE PLAINTIFFS
LACK OF STANDING DUE TO ITS
INABILITY TO PROVE THAT IT HAD
BEEN A FIND THE INDIVIDUAL UP.
AFTER WE SERVE EXPENSIVE
DISCOVERY UNNOTICED THE
DEPOSITION. OF PLAINTIFF
DISMISSED A LOT THEY- AND THE-
DAMAGE EIGHT TWENTY IT'S
CRUCIAL TO ENSURING THAT LOW
INCOME BORROWERS MOST OF WHOM
ARE UNABLE TO OBTAIN LEGAL
REPRESENTATION. DO NOT FACE A
LIFETIME OF WAGE GARNISHMENT TO
TAKE TO PAY OFF DEFAULT
JUDGMENTS FOR DEBT THEY DO NOT
LEGALLY OUT. FOR THESE REASONS
WE URGE YOUR VOTE FOR EIGHTY
FOUR TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS SMITH. HI IS
THERE ANY PERSON WHO WISHES TO
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES. AND STATE
THE POSITION ON THE BILL IN
FAVOR- ANYONE IN PERSON SAYING
NO ONE ANYONE AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. HEARING NO
ONE OPERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE WISHING TO. STATE THEIR
POSITION IN FAVOR. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FOR
TWENTY FOUR HOURS YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
LINE TO FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
KEVIN INVESCO FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE TO
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHEN MEMBER
TELLING HER THAT I WOULD END
WITH WIDENING GROUP ON BEHALF
OF NEXT IN CALIFORNIA PRIOR
SUPPORTER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE TO FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON ZACHARY CORBEAU WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE ONE FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS LUCY
SALCEDO CARTER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFITS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE TWO FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS RICK FELT THE MARTINEZ ON
BEHALF OF YOUNG INVINCIBLE A
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORTER AND ENCOURAGER
I VOTE. THANK YOU. NINE TWO
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
DANIEL KENDO KAISER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION IN SUPPORT.
NINE TO THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JESSICA STAND ON
BEHALF OF THE GREAT ADVOCATE
AND SUPPORT. NINE TWO FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
COULD LEAD BEARING WITH THE
PUBLIC LAWCENTER IN SUPPORT OF
AB FOUR TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
NINE ONE ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANNUAL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
OPERATOR PLEASE CLOSE THE LINES.
AND NOW IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE A
ROBERT WILSON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
ON THE TELEPHONE. MISTER WILSON
YOU REPAIR CENTER RIGHT THERE
MA'AM. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS MANY ROBERT
WILSON WITH A CALIFORNIA CREDIT
UNION LEAGUE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OFFER SOME BRIEF
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY FOUR TWO FOUR. CREDIT
UNIONS ARE NOT FOR PROFIT
MEMBER OWNED COOPERATIVES THAT
SOLE PURPOSE OF EXISTENCE IS TO
SERVE OUR MEMBER OWNERS. CREDIT
UNION STILL OFFER STUDENT LOANS
AND SERVICE TO THEIR MEMBERS
AND THEY OFFERED HIM A BETTER
COMPETITIVE RATES COMPARED TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SOMETIMES BEING FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT RATES. ORIGINATORS
THE DECLINES AND DUE TO THE
UNIQUE STRUCTURE CREDIT. IS IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
INSTITUTION TO WORK WITH
BORROWERS. BUT SUMMER INSTANCES
CREDIT MEANS MUCH INITIATE
COLLECTION ACTION TO COLLECT A
DEBT. WELL WE UNDERSTAND THE
EXTENT OF AB FOUR TO FOUR AND
AGREE WITH PROTECTING STUDENT
LOAN BORROWERS WE MUST BE
OPPOSED THE BILL. I LIKE THE
LIST OF ITEMS AND DOCUMENTATION
LISTED THAT A PRIVATE.
EDUCATION WHEN IT WOULD HAVE TO
PROVIDE APPEARS TO BE AN
ATTEMPT TO INVALIDATE THE GYM
LIKE THAT. IN THE EVENT THAT A
CREDIT UNION IMPORTANT HAVE
MADE ONE OF THE START. BECAUSE
OF THIS- MAKE THE COLLECTOR
DETALLE THAT. DIFFICULT FOR
CRISES THAT ARE SERVICING THEIR
OWN BOSS. THE CALIFORNIA CREDIT
UNION LEAGUE AGREED TO PROTECT
INSTEAD OF OUR WORST. AND
APPRECIATE HEARING THAT CREDIT
UNIONS ARE NOT THE PROBLEM THAT
THIS BILL IS TRYING TO SOLVE
FOR. WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORED SPONSORS BUT
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE H.
FORTY FOUR TODAY AND ASK FOR A
NO VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER WILSON. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE WHO WANTS TO
STATE THEIR POSITION IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. FOUR TWENTY
FOUR ANYONE IN PERSON SAYING NO
ONE ANYBODY IN THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. HEARING NO
ONE IS OPERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR TWENTY
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. NINE ONE THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THAT AFTERNOON
MELANIE CREDIT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION AND REALIGN
OUR COMMENTS LIKE THOSE
PROVIDED BY THE CREDIT UNION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
OPERATOR YOU CAN CLOSE THE
PHONE LINES ON EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY FOUR. BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FOR THE AUTHOR. SAYING NONE MR
STONE WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE BY US
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO PREPARATIONS STONE
HI STONE AYE CHAU. CHOI AYE CHU.
DAVIES DAVIES NO GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
KALRA RIGHT KALRA KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES AYE REYES AYE SMITH. THAT
BILL IS OUT ALL RIGHT SAID MR
STONE ON AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU THE SO AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT IS THE
COMMITTEE BILL THANK YOU IT'S
THE CIVIL OMNIBUS BILL IT'S A
LITTLE BIT LARGER THIS YEAR
THAN IN PAST YEARS BECAUSE DUE
TO CODE RESTRICTIONS WE'RE
TRYING TO COULD DO THE KIND OF
CLEAN UP THAT OFTEN GETS DONE
IN INDIVIDUAL BILLS. FIXING
CROSS REFERENCES EXTENDING
SUNSET DATES IN DEALING WITH
NON CONTROVERSIAL THINGS THAT
REALLY JUST NEED TO GET CLEANED
UP IT HAS NO OPPOSITION I DO
HAVE STEVE COHEN OF THE
CALIFORNIA LAW REVISION
COMMISSION IS ON THE LINE IF
THERE ARE TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
FOR SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE DOING I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NIGHT OF. HI MISTER COHN IS
ON STANDBY FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. IS THERE ANYBODY
ELSE WHO WANTS TO- TESTIFIED IN
FAVOR. HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
OR SEEN NO ONE IN THE REMOTE TO
TESTIMONY STATION. WE HEAR NO
ONE IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE OPERATOR WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN FAVOR OF AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OFFER YOU CAN CLOSE THE LINES-
WE HAVE NOBODY LISTED IN IN
OPPOSITION. IS THERE ANYBODY
WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. SAYING NO ONE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. HI IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. HEARING NO
ONE OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. Q. MADAM
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN GENERAL AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO COMMENT IN Q.
THANK YOU OPERATOR PLEASE CALL
THE PHONE LINES ON AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. SEEING NONE
MR STONE WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE BY
AS WE ARRIVE OF. THANK YOU
PLEASE TAKE SEVERAL. TO PASS
TO. STONE HI STONE AYE CHAU
CHOW I CHIU. DAVIES DAVIES ACT
AND SALAS GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA KALRA KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN AYE
RADIUS AYE REYES AYE SUBMIT.
FOR ALL RIGHT THAT BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS
RIGHT LET'S GO THROUGH I THINK
WE HAVE SOME MEMBERS WHO HAD
BEEN HERE ALL BILL SO LET'S
ROLL THROUGH AND ASK OTHER
MEMBERS WHO HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE
TO VOTE ON ALL THE BILLS PLEASE
COME BACK TO CHAMBERS WE HAVE A
NUMBER BACK TO HEARING ROOM WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF BILLS ON CALL
BUT LET'S JUST GO THROUGH THE
LIST THIRTY WITH CONSENT TO
CALL ABSENT MEMBERS CONSENT IS
OUT BY THE WAY BUT WE WILL CALL
OUT TO MEMBERS CHAO. CHARGE TO.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN MENTIONED THAT.
OKAY NOW ITEM NUMBER ONE A. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTY IS ON CALL
ARAMBULA I'M GONNA LIVE TO CALL.
CHOW CHOW I CHU. CHU HI HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I RIGHT THE BILL IS
OUT ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWELVE
EIGHTY SEVEN POWER QUE HAN IS
ON CALL I'M GONNA LIVE THE CALL.
CHOW CHAO II HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE REYES. AYE REYES AYE SMITH.
THE BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB NINE THIRTY SEVEN IS
ON CALL THIS IS CAREERS BILL
I'M GONNA LIFT THE CALL CHAO
CHAO II HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I'D
RACE RECITE THAT BILL IS OUT
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE FRIEDMAN IS ON CALL
A MIDDLE IF THE CALL CHAO CHAO
II HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN MANCHAC. THANK YOU
THE BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB EIGHT ONE FOUR LEVINE
IS ON CALL A MIDDLE IF THE CALL
CHAO CHAO I CHU. CHU II HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE KALRA. ALL RIGHTS
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN. I AM FIVE
EIGHT ONE FOUR LEVINE.
MAIENSCHEIN I RAISE RAYSIDE
NEBULOUS OUT ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
THREE SIXTY FOUR RODRIGUEZ IS
ON CALL IF THE CALL CHAU CHAO
AYE CHU CHU I. HOLDEN. THEN I
KALRA KALRA KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I RAYOS REYES AYE
THE BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT IS
ALREADY PASSED THE COMMITTEE
BUT CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CHAO. CHAU AYE CHU CHU I KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN MAIN CHINA. I HAVE
NEVER EIGHT AB FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT TANG IS ON CALL I'M GONNA
LIFT THE CALL CHAO CHAO AYE CHU
CHU AYE KALRA. KALRA KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I.
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR THE REST OF
THE BILLS ARE OUT BUT WILL GO
THROUGH THEM TO ADD ON ABSENT
MEMBERS I'VE NEVER NINE AB
ELEVEN NINETEEN WORKS. TO AYE
KILEY. NUMBER TEN A. B. FOUR
TWENTY FOUR STONE CHIU CHU AYE
KILEY SMITH. I REMEMBER ELEVEN
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH
IS THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE BILL
COLUSA WRIST CHIU CHU AYE KILEY
SMITH. OKAY ARE WE MISSING.
OKAY MEDIA CONSENTS CALL THE OF
THE MEMBERS TO AT. OKAY TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB TWELVE EIGHTY
SEVEN POWER QUE HAN COSTA
MEMBERS MET. SMITH NOW.
TEN
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB FOUR TWENTY
FOUR STONE. SMITH SMITH NOW.
SEVEN ELEVEN AN ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
COMMITTEE BILL SMITH SMITH NOW.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE ARE DONE
WITH OUR HEARING OR THE. I
REMEMBER THREE B. NINE THIRTY
SEVEN. WHAT DO YOU WANT TO CALL
IT IN SO YOU CAN SAY I DO NOT
VOTING SO AB NINE THIRTY SEVEN.
IS MAIENSCHEIN CHANGING AND I
DID NOT VOTING. OKAY PERFECT.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THAT
CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS WE ARE
ADJOURNED. HE WAS VENTURE.